PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE- BUT SEE
THIS IS THAT WAS A CORDLESS A
GROUP READY TO GO. JONES SAWYER
HERE LACKEY. BONTA HERE BRIAN
QUIRK SANTIAGO SEYARTO- QUORUM
IS PRESENT THANK YOU WE'LL BEGIN
BY READING OUR OUR CO GOOD-
REQUIREMENTS WE ENCOURAGE THE
PUBLIC TO PROVIDE WRITTEN
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE HEARING BY
VISITING THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
AT H. H. T. P. S. DOT A. P. S.
F. DOT ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT GOV-
PLEASE NOTE THAT ANY WRITTEN
TESTIMONY SUBMITTED TO THE
COMMITTEE IS CONSIDERED PUBLIC
COMMENT AND MAYBE READ INTO THE
RECORD OR REPRINTED ALL ARE
ENCOURAGED TO WATCH THE HEARING
FROM IT'S A LIVE STREAM ON THE
ASSEMBLY'S WEBSITE AT W. W. DOT
. ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT GOV SO
BACKSLASH TODAY'S EVENT- THE
HEARING ROOM WILL BE OPEN FOR
ATTENDANCE OF THIS HEARING. ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC. ATTENDING
A HEARING IS ENCOURAGED TO WEAR
A MASK AT ALL TIMES WHILE IN THE
BUILDING THE PUBLIC MAY ALSO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS HEARING BY
TELEPHONE WE ENCOURAGE THE
PUBLIC TO MONITOR THE COMMITTEES
WITH THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE.
FOR UPDATES- LET'S BEGIN WITH
OUR HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS AND
HOPEFULLY. THE PHONES ARE
WORKING THIS TIME. SO START
WITH- OFF CALENDAR- THESE ARE
PULLED BY AUTHORS OFF THE
CALENDAR STARTING WITH ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT AB TWENTY SEVENTEEN
MATHIS COLD BY AUTHOR ITEM
NUMBER THIRTEEN A. B. TWENTY ONE
THIRTY EIGHT MERIT SU CHI PULLED
BY AUTHOR ITEM FOURTEEN A. B.
TWENTY ONE FIFTY ONE RIGHT
THIRTY GUESTS PULLED BY AUTHOR
AND ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN AB
TWENTY THREE SIXTY SIX-
PATTERSON POPE BY. AUTHOR WE'LL
NOW GO TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR-
THE FOLLOWING ITEMS HAD BEEN
AGREED UPON FOR CONSENT. BY BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE- ITEM NUMBER
FIVE AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY NINE
GIPSON CRIMINAL PROCEDURE ITEM
NUMBER NINE AB TWENTY TWENTY
THREE BENNETT JAILS DISCHARGE
PLANS AND I DON'T NUMBER SIXTEEN
AB TWENTY ONE NINETY EIGHT. FONG
VEHICLES DRIVING UNDER THE
INFLUENCE- AND I WOULD. HAVE
STAFF MAKE A RECOMMENDATION MOAK
SAYS WE HAVE TO R. C. ISN'T TO
FONG COULD YOU PLEASE PUT THEIR
FIRST INITIAL. ON ALL OF THEM
NOW THAT WE HAVE. I WILL SAY
PRETTY BONTA TO COME TO COULD
YOU PUT. WHICH ONE IT IS SO WE
DON'T GET CONFUSED- IS THERE A
MOTION FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR
. SECOND YOU MAY CALL THE ROLL.
JONES SAWYER HI JOHN SIR HI
LACKEY LACKEY I YEAH BONTA YEAH
BONTA HI BRIAN HI BRIAN I WORK.
SANTIAGO SEYARTO THEY ARE TO I.
THE CONSENT CALENDARS ADOPTED.
AND WE WILL BEGIN THE HEARING I
SEE MISTER CHOICE HERE I DON'T
SEE ANYONE ELSE SO I'M ASSUMING
MISTER CHOICE FIRST. THIS CHOI
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOI YOU MAY
COME TO THE- TO THE PODIUM ITEM
NUMBER TEN. AB TWO ZERO TWO
SEVEN CHOI DISMISSAL OF
ENHANCEMENT- ZERO IT WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY TO BEGIN WE'RE
WE'RE HERE TO LISTEN THANK YOU
CHAIR COME MORNING MEMBERS SAW.
I'M SO PLEASED TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BE ALLOWED TWENTY
TWENTY SEVEN. A. B. PONY TWENTY
SEVEN- ORDER- IT IS SUCH A JOINT
AUTHORED BY- MY COLLEAGUE EVAN
LOW AS A BIPARTISAN MEASURE-
THIS WILL EXEMPT THE HATE CRIME
PENALTY ENHANCEMENTS SELF FROM
THE PROVISIONS OF US SENATE BILL
EIGHTY ONE AUTHORED BY THE
SENATE TO SKIING OR LAST YEAR SO
THAT THE IN HATE CRIME CASES. A
JUDGE HAS THE ABILITY TO ADD THE
A HATE CRIME ENHANCEMENTS. HATE
CRIMES SO IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
REACHED THEIR HIGHEST DOOR. WHAT
IT ALLOW MORE IN NOT DECADES
REACHING. THIRTEEN HUNDRED
THIRTY. OFFENSES IN TWENTY
TWENTY. ASIAN NOT HATE CRIMES-
COSTS DOWN MORE THAN- ON THE-
ARE FROM. TWENTY NINETEEN TO
TWENTY TWENTY- THIS IS SAW A
DURING THE EVEN UP AND THEN MAKE
SOME PERIOD OF THE ASIAN
AMERICANS AND THE PACIFIC
ISLANDER COMMUNITY HAS
EXPERIENCED A SURGE OF HATE
AGAINST THEM- THIS PAST YEAR IN
CALIFORNIA AS A RESULT OF THEIR-
HAS BEEN NO INCREASE- IN
DEPRESSION. AND UP MENTAL HEALTH
THOUGHT IN THIS COMMUNITY. IN
THE HEIGHT OF A RACIAL HATE
AGAINST A ASIAN AMERICANS
FAMILIES SO WE'RE SCARED TO SEND
THEIR KIDS TO A BACK TO SCHOOL
BECAUSE- THEY FEAR THAT THEIR
KIDS SO WOULD BE BOARDED. ASIAN
AMERICANS HAVE FEARED THE FOR
THE- SAFETY EVERY TIME THEY LEFT
OF THEIR HOMES. I READ UP ON
KOREAN COMMITTEE PAPER- JUST
ABOUT EVERY DAY I READ THE
STORIES. ESPECIALLY SENIOR
ELDERLY PEOPLE WERE ATTACKED OF
FOR NO REASON- ON THE STREET THE
THEY ARE OFF. SOURCE SCARED TO
LEAVE THEIR HOMES SO GO OUT
SHOPPING WILL WALK YOU. S. B.
EIGHTY ONE THE CREW. A LOOPHOLE
. IN CALIFORNIA SO SENTENCING
LAWS BY ALLOWING OFFENDERS SO TO
AVOID. HAVING ADDITIONAL
PENALTIES IMPOSED FOR HATE. I
HATE CRIME RELATED APPELLANT-
FELONIES THIS IS A SIMPLY ON
REASONABLE AND- IT GIVES US A
MESSAGE IT TO OFFENDERS THAT THE
CALIFORNIA DOES NOT TAKE A HATE
CRIMES SO SERIOUS TODAY THIS-
AND HATE CRIME ESPECIALLY BASED
UPON OF THE- ORIGINAL-
BACKGROUND THIS OF COURSE SAW-
TO ANYBODY. WHO MAY BE WIPED THE
WHOLE MAYBE BLACK OR BROWN OR
YELLOW DOESN'T MATTER BASED UPON
THEIR HATRED BASED UPON THE A
RHESUS AT DIFFERENT NON LOCAL
THEY SIMPLY GENERATE THE HEY
TRACY- AND THEN A TACKLE THIS SO
WE NEED TO STOP BUT IN THIS
COUNTRY WHERE OF WHAT COUNTRIES
ARE MADE UP UP- NOW ALL THE
IMMIGRANTS SO WITH A DIFFERENT
CULTURE A DIFFERENT ETHNIC
BACKGROUND SO. SO AT THIS BILL
IS SENDING THE MESSAGE. TO OUR
AT LEAST. PUT IT DOWN CENTER
MESSAGE FOR THE CRIMINAL SO ARE
NOW TO- BUT- AND- MAKE UP FOR IT
FEAR. OF ALL OF THE OTHER DAY
LIFE ARE SO OUR OUR LIKE TO- IF
OF THE ORANGE. DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY BILL HARPER WHO
REPRESENTS- THE HATE CRIME UNIT
AND- MISTER FRANK LEAVE PRESSED
ON TOP OF WHAT LOCALIZATION FOR
JUSTICE. AND EQUALITY FOR
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT. OF WHAT
AB TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN. DAY YOU
MAY OPEN UP THE LINES- SENTIMENT
. WITNESS FRANKLY AND BILLY HOP. I BELIEVE THE TESTIFYING BY
PHONE. HELLO HI GOOD MORNING
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING. YOU
MAY BEGIN ABOVE ALL YOU HAVE TO
. FIVE MINUTES TOTAL WHATEVER
WAY YOU SPLIT UP. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS WILLIAM HOCKER AND THE HATE
CRIMES PROSECUTOR IN ORANGE
COUNTY I'M HEARING I'M APPEARING
ON BEHALF OF OUR ORANGE COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY TAUGHT BETTER.
D. A. TALK BETTER AND OUR OFFICE
IS IN THE WHOLEHEARTED SUPPORT
OF AB CUTE SEVEN WHICH WOULD BAN
PIC CRIME PENALTY ENHANCEMENTS
FROM PROVISIONS OF SB EIGHTY ONE
VEHICLE AND MAKE IT SO THAT A
JUDGE IS NOT REQUIRED BY LAW TO
THE COMMITTED CRIMES HAVE MEANT
THAT INSURANCE WHICH INSURES
DEFENDANT COMMIT THESE CRIMES
WILL. SERVE LONGER SPENT THE-
I'M LOOKING THE WHERE. THERE'S
BEEN. UP OF. HEY ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND ACROSS THE STATE AND
ON COUNTY SANTA. A RECENT STUDY
BY OUR HUMAN RELATIONS
COMMISSION FOUND THAT A TOTAL OF
A HUNDRED AND TWELVE FEET CRIME
OCCURRED IN ORANGE COUNTY IN
TWENTY TWENTY. 635% INCREASE
FROM TWENTY NINETEEN WHICH
CONQUERED THE LARGEST ANNUAL
JUMP IN AT LEAST DECADES. THE
ASIAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY IN
PARTICULAR FELT THE HATE
INCIDENTS AGAINST. BEACON
AMERICAN CAN INCREASE BY ONE
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED PERCENT.
WHICH REPRESENTS THE DEEPLY
TROUBLING RIGHTS AND INCIDENT.
IN RESPONSE OUR OFFICE BUT BY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY THOUGHT THAT
SIR CREATED HATE CRIME UNIT. THE
THAT NAY PROP AND- HANDLE THESE
CASES. AND IN THE FIRST TWO
YEARS MISTER. WE ARE MORE THAN
DOUBLE THE NUMBER OF HATE CRIMES
. FIRE TWENTY FIVE YEARS. THERE
ARE UNITS OF PROSECUTING HATE
CRIMES UNDER THE NORMS COUNTY SB
EIGHTY ONE CREATED LOOPHOLE
INTENT THING LOGGED BY ALLOWING
OFFENDERS TO AVOID HAVING
ADDITIONAL PENALTY IMPOSED FOR
HATE CRIME RELATED FELONIES. THE
GOOD ON RECALL TO GIVE THE
MESSAGE TO OFFENDERS THAT
CALIFORNIA DOES NOT TAKE A CRIME
SERIOUSLY. WE BELIEVE THAT
STRONGER SPENDING LAWS ARE
NECESSARY TO DISSUADE THIS TYPE
OF CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR AND REDUCE
HATE CRIME INSTANCES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND HERE IN ORANGE
COUNTY. AND FOR THOSE REASONS WE
SUPPORT AB TWO ZERO TWO SEVEN.
THANK YOU SIR. THANK YOU.
MR LEE. FRANK. MR LEE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING GERMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND EVERYBODY
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT EIGHTY TWO
OH TWO SEVEN WHICH IS OF UTMOST
IMPORTANCE IN FIGHTING AGAINST
HATE CRIMES OF WHICH ASIAN
AMERICANS LGBT AND AFRICAN
AMERICANS OTHER MAJOR GROUPS OF
THE CUPS. ACCORDING TO THE
CENTER FOR THE STUDY OF HATE AND
EXTREMISM ANTI ASIAN HATE CRIMES
I WANTED 2310039% ALARMINGLY
FROM. TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IN THE NATION. SAN
FRANCISCO I PUBLIC WHY BUDGETS
7% IN ANTI CRIMES WHY WE THE
MOST REQUIRE. IN OF ANY BIG CITY
IN THE CENTURY IN TWO OH TWO ONE
ALONE. YEAH I THE JUDGES OF THE
TO HE HAS MEANT BETHANY GOALS
THE WRONG OPPOSITE THAT. THIS IS
USUALLY THE CASE AS AMERICANS
SEE AND THIS NOW MEDIA THEM GIVE
CANNOT OVER. IT WAS GROUND.
ASIANS FEMALE WAS ASSAULTED BY
THREE MEN OF COULD BE.
REPEATEDLY IN THE PRESS OF
BYSTANDER ANY BROAD BASED LIVES
NEAR. SAN FRANCISCO. WE ARE
LIVING IN FEAR SB WILL LIVING IN
OTHER PEOPLE COUNTRY WITHOUT
PROPER LAW AND FOR. EVER OF USE
COLOR LIPSTICK TO DEAL WITH.
INCOME BECAUSE WE EXPEDITIOUSLY
WITHIN A TO THE COURAGE HE GETS
HEY QUAN CRISIS. THE WHOLE
APPROACH IT'S ACTUALLY AN
UNPROVEN THE LOSS OF THE- I
WOULD THINK USED TO WORK EVEN IF
IT DOES. TO SUPPORT IS A
CALIFORNIA'S WHO NEED YOUR
APPROVAL A TOOL TO SEVEN FOUR OP
ED A BETTING DAY CRIMES. THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN VERSES
SHOW MUCH THERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. MORNING COMMITTEE WHO THE
LOAN FROM THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT SHERIFF
CHAD BIANCO WE SUPPORT THEM. NOW
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES OF
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE. AT&T OPERATING A OPEN
THANK YOU MISTER THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR THOSE OF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. NAME
AN ORGANIZATION PLEASE. WE'RE
GONNA GO TO LINE. SIXTY PARDON
ME LINE SIXTY JUST A MOMENT. ONE
SIX. IN JUST A MOMENT. ONE FORTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES THIS
IS THAT YOU CAN BE SURE YOU
PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIAN PRACTICES
GO IN STRONG SUPPORT. EIGHTY TWO
OH TWO SEVEN. LINE FIFTY BILL.
BERMAN IT IS WENDY'S SACRAMENTO
COUNTY FIVE FEELING. TWO OH TWO
SEVEN. LINE HELLO MY IS THE MAN
I STRONGLY. SB TWO ZERO TWO
SEVEN. THE BOX. NINE FIFTY ONE
MY NAME IS LEON FROM LOS THAT
MEANS TO STRONG SO OF A TWENTY
ARE TWENTY SEVEN AND ALSO WE TO
MENTION THAT HE TO RUN IS A FUND
RAISE ITS HATE CRIME TO HUMAN
THANK YOU. WINE FORTY TWO. HI
KIM I'M CALLING FROM FREMONT
CALIFORNIA I VOTE YES ON A B.
TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN I'M STRONGLY
SUPPORTING IT. THANK YOU SIR.
LINE. TWENTY NINE. HELLO THE
PRODUCT OF THE CONTINENTAL
AIRLINE CODES- A. TWENTY ON.
FIVE SIX THREE. NINE THIRTY FIVE
. HI THIS IS JAMES MY CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER AND FOUNDER OF
THE UNITED WHICH IS THE ABBASI
GROUP FOR ASIAN AMERICANS AND ON
A DAILY BASIS I DEAL WITH HATE
CRIMES AND VICTIMS OF HATE
CRIMES. MANY OF WHICH ARE ON
VOICE I MEAN THE NUMBERS ARE UP
THERE. LINE FORTY NINE THE HELLO
MY NAME IS LAUREN HANK FROM
SACRAMENTO I STRONGLY SUPPORT A.
B. TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN THANK YOU
THANK YOU MA'AM. RESEARCHER
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK OKAY NOW
WILL BRING IT BACK- ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION. THE SAME IS SUPPORT
YOU HAVE A- A TOTAL OF FIVE
MINUTES WHATEVER WAY YOU.
DESPITE THAT TIME. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS MARCO GEORGIAN I'M
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION TO
TWENTY AB TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN-
WE DEPLORE THE INCREASE IN HATE
CRIMES AGAINST ASIAN AMERICANS
IN THE WAKE OF THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S. CALLING COPE WITH
THE CHINESE FLEW. THE HATE CRIME
ENHANCEMENT ALREADY PROVIDES FOR
AN ADDITIONAL ONE TO FOUR YEARS
IN STATE PRISON FOR ANY FELONY
HATE CRIME. LAST YEAR S. B.
EIGHTY ONE WAS SIGNED INTO LAW.
AT ENACTING ONE OF THE COMMITTEE
ON THE- REVISION OF THE PENAL
CODES KEY RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
JUDGES SHOULD BE GIVEN LEGAL
GUIDANCE AND EXERCISING THEIR
SENTENCING DISCRETION. A. B.
TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN WOULD TAKE
THAT AWAY. AB TWENTY TWENTY
SEVEN WOULD NOT DETER HATE
CRIMES THE STATISTICS CITED BY
THE DEPUTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY
FROM ORANGE COUNTY ALL OCCURRED
BEFORE S. B. S. B. EIGHTY ONE.
ACTUALLY WENT INTO EFFECT. BOB
RICE LET'S NOT STOPPED BY THE
SENTENCING THAT EXISTED PRIOR TO
A TO SB EIGHTY ONE. AB TWENTY
TWENTY SEVEN WOOD AT IMPOSED A
ONE SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH TO
HATE CRIME ENHANCEMENT IS
CHARGED IN OTHER WORDS IT WOULD
MEAN THAT A JUDGE AFTER HEARING
ALL THE EVIDENCE AND WEIGHING
THE LAWN THE FACTS WOULD BE
TAPPED POWERLESS TO DISMISS A
HATE CRIME AND AUNTS MEANT EVEN
IF THERE WERE WARRANTED BECAUSE
THE INDIVIDUAL COMMITTED THE
FENCE BECAUSE THEY WERE MENTALLY
ILL. THE INDIVIDUAL COMMISSION
OF THE CURRENT OFFENSE WAS
CONNECTED TO SEXUAL ABUSE SEX
TRAFFICKING ANIMATE PARTNER
PARTNER VIOLENCE OR CHILDHOOD
TRAUMA. THE INDIVIUALS THE
JUVENILE WHEN THEY COMMITTED THE
CURRENT OFFENSE. IMPOSING THE
ENHANCEMENT WOULD RESULT IN A
DISCRIMINATORY RACIAL IMPACT.
AND I DO WANT TO SAY THAT AS
SOMEONE WHO WOULD FIT INTO AT
LEAST THREE OF THE CATEGORIES
THAT WOULD BE COVERED BY THE
HATE CRIME STATUTE BUT IT JUST
THINK THIS IS NOT THE WAY A
CHILLING MORE CALIFORNIANS SO WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR NO
VOTE ON AB TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING CHEN MEMBERS FRED
WILLIAMS ACLU CAL ACTION IN
OPPOSITION WHILE THE DESIRE TO
DISCOURAGE HATE CRIMES TO A
PROTECTED CLASSES LAUDABLE GOAL
EXISTING LAW ALREADY PENALIZES
HATE BASED OFFENSES WHILE
PROVIDING APPROPRIATE JUDICIAL
DISCRETION WHEN ENHANCEMENT IS
NOT IN THE INTEREST OF JUSTICE
JUDICIAL DISCRETION IS ONE THE
MOST VITAL ASPECTS OF OUR LEGAL
SYSTEM TYING THE HANDS OF JUDGES
TO IMPOSE AN UPHOLD SENTENCES
THAT THEY BELIEVE ARE ON JUST
RUNS COUNTER TO THE MISSION OF
THE COURTS. CURRENT LAW STRIKES
A BALANCE ALLOWING JUDGES TO
IMPOSE SENTENCES IN ORDER TO
PROTECT PUBLIC SAFETY WITHOUT
LOSING SIGHT OF THE OBLIGATION
OF TE COURTS TO ACT FAIRLY.
EACH INDIVIDUAL CASE PRESENTS A
MULTITUDE OF FACTORS THAT SHOULD
BE CONSIDERED BY THE JUDGE. THIS
BILL REMOVES TOOL THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS PUT IN PLACE TO
CREATE A MORE JUST AND EQUITABLE
LEGAL SYSTEM IS FOR THESE
REASONS AS YOU'VE GOT ACTION
STRONGLY URGES THE NO VOTE. ON
AB TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NEVER GO TO ROOM
WITNESS'S NAME AN ORGANIZATION
IN OPPOSITION GOOD MORNING
COMMITTEE GOING BACK AS FOR THE
ELEVATOR CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. SEEN
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION IN ROME
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINE-
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR- WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO PRESS ONE AND ZERO
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. WE'LL GO TO LINE A.
B. PARDON ME JUST A MOMENT. WHAT. LINE. SIXTY ONE SIXTY YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. WHEN I GO TO
LINE EIGHTY ONE. YEAH I VOTE YES
PLEASE CONSIDER A YES VOTE AB
TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN. THANK YOU.
WELL NOW GO TO LINE FIFTY SEVEN
. HELLO MY NAME IS MICHAEL
DORADO MODELS OF ITS BACK
CAMERON'S APPROACH A. B. TWENTY
TWENTY SEVEN. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. LINE. THIRTY GOOD MORNING
GREGORY CANNELLA BEHALF OF
INITIATE JUSTICE AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
M. ONCE AGAIN LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU MISTER
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. MISTER CHAIR THERE PARDON
ME JUST ONE MORE PERSON JUST A
MOMENT.
WINDS SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THE MORNING CARE AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS DELAYED AND I
LIVE IN LOS ANGELES I'M CALLING
IN STRONG OPPOSITION AB SIXTEEN
OH THREE THANK YOU THANK YOU
LINE. EIGHTY THREE. YOU WANT TO
TURN MEMBERS MY NAME IS MICHAEL
HOBBY I LIVE RIVERSIDE NINE
CALLING TO ENSURE OPPOSITION AB
SIXTY OH THREE THANK YOU. THE
LINE. EIGHTY TWO. GOOD MORNING
KAREN AND MY IS ANDREW GARCIA
KONTOR YOUNG CALLING ON BEHALF
OF AND SAMBAR DINO FOR ON IN ALL
. LINE EIGHTY FIVE. GOOD MORNING
SHARON MEMBERS MY NAME REQUIRED
A TREATMENT FROM BEACH AND I'M
CALL IN CHOI OPPOSITION A
DEPICTING OH THREE OKAY NO WE'RE
NOT ON AB SIXTEEN OH THREE WE'RE
ON A TWENTY TWENTY. ITEM NUMBER
TEN- WE'RE GOING IN THE ORDER OF
HIS MEMBERS APPEAR AND MISTER
CHOICE SO GRACIOUSLY APPEARED
FIRST SO. THIS IS ITEM NUMBER
TEN CHOI AB. TWENTY TWENTY
SEVEN. AND AGAIN LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN FOR OPPOSITION THIS IS
A FOR A BE A TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN
. WHEN I GO TO LINE SEVENTY TWO. LINE. SEVENTY SEVEN. MY NAME
IS DAVID KAY AND I'M FROM
SACRAMENTO I STRONGLY VOTE YES
ON A B. TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU LINE SEVENTY FOUR.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS WILLIE
BROWN FROM OXNARD CALIFORNIA BUT
I WAS CALLING TO SIXTEEN OH
THREE WE'RE NOT ON THAT YET.
SAMBA SURE THERE IS NO ONE ELSE
HAS SIGNALED THEY WISH TO SPEAK
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU WOULD NOW
BRING IT BACK. TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR COMMENTS QUESTIONS ANSWERS.
MISTER MISTER COURT. YES I FIND
THIS BILL JUST CONTRADICTORY.
EVEN THOUGH THE JUDGE THINKS IT
IS FURTHERANCE OF JUSTICE THAT
THE ENHANCEMENT BE DISMISSED
YOU'RE ASKING. THAT THAT THAT
THEY NO LONGER HAVE THAT ABILITY
EVEN THOUGH IT'S IN THE
FURTHERANCE OF JUSTICE THIS JUST
DOES NOT MAKE SENSE TO ME- AND-
WHAT IT WOULD RESULT IN IS MORE
JAIL TIME. MORE RESOURCES SPENT.
ON KEEPING PEOPLE IN JAIL ARE IN
PRISON. AS OPPOSED TO.
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS THAT COULD
HELP IN THIS AREA. AS OPPOSED
TO- TRYING TO HELP PEOPLE WHO
HAVE PROBLEMS ARE KEEP FROM
RECEIPT OF EIGHTEEN SO THIS JUST
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO ME I'M
SORRY I'M GONNA HAVE TO VOTE NOW
. MISTER BRYANT AB I'LL BE QUICK
WE'VE SUGGESTED IN IN THE IN THE
COMMENTS HERE THAT THERE'S A
CAUSAL RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN SB
EIGHTY ONE AND A RISE IN HATE
CRIMES OF THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS SB EIGHTY ONE WAS CHAPTER
LAST YEAR DIDN'T GO INTO EFFECT
UNTIL JANUARY OF THIS YEAR AND
SO THE IDEA THAT WE WOULD UNDO A
LAW SUGGESTING THAT THERE'S A
LOOPHOLE WHEN IT HASN'T EVEN
BEEN EFFECT FOR MORE THAN TWO
MONTHS I THINK IT'S JUST POOR
POLICY. SO I WILL ALSO BE VOTING
. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER COMMENTS
. QUESTIONS YOU MAY CLOSE CHOI.
THANK YOU TO OUR ADDRESS THE
OPPOSITION'S OF CONCERNS. AB
TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN IF YOU READ
CAREFULLY DOES NOT THE-
PROHIBITS A JUDGE FROM
DISMISSING A HATE CRIME
ENHANCEMENT IN THE INTEREST OF A
JUSTICE. THIS BILL STATES THAT
THE OR JUDGE IT IS- NOT REQUIRED. TO DO SO UNDER THE NEW S. B.
EIGHTY ONE LANGUAGE. THE JUDGE
IT WOULD RETAIN THE SAME
AUTHORITY. DR HE WHY SHE HAS A
PRIOR TO JANUARY FIRST OF TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY TOOL TO DISMISS
TO DISMISS AT THIS ENHANCEMENTS
IF YOU WHY HE WHY SHE WANTED TO.
BUT THE WITHOUT THE- NERO NERO
PRESUMPTION IN FAVOUR BUT THIS
MUSCLE LANGUAGE. CALIFORNIA MUST
DO MORE AND THEN AB TWENTY
TWENTY SEVEN GIVES UP A MESSAGE
TO CALIFORNIA HAS A ZERO
TOLERANCE OF FULL HE CRIMES
ESPECIALLY BASED ON RACIAL WALK
COLOR OF THE SKIN. I ASK YOU ALL
TO THINK ABOUT THE YOU ALL
COMMUNITIES- AND THOSE SO WHO
ARE TARGETED SPECIFICALLY FOR
THE RACE OF RELIGION SEXUAL
ORIENTATION AND KNOW WHO THEY
CHOOSE TO LOVE. THAT THE CRIME
COMING FROM THE PLACE OF A HATE
IS UP ON BLOCKS UP DOUBLE. TO
LET THE VICTIMS TO NORMAL WE ARE
ON THE SIDE OF A JUSTICE NOT
UNDECIDABLE CRY. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK WE I'VE WORKED. AND THANK
YOU MR JOINER I THINK FOR BRING
THIS UP I THINK FOR FAR TOO LONG
WE EITHER AS A AS A SOCIETY OR
AS A COMMUNITY OR EVEN HERE IN
THE CAPITAL WE REALLY HAVEN'T
RECOGNIZE ÁP I HATE AND THAT IS
NOT SOMETHING IS JUST SPRING UP
OVERNIGHT I. BELIEVE IT'S BEEN
GOING ON FOR QUITE SOME TIME AND
SO THE FACT THAT WE CONTINUE TO
TALK ABOUT IT IS REALLY REALLY
REALLY IMPORTANT AND I COMMEND
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS TO THE
FOREFRONT AND BRING IT HERE A TO
THIS COMMITTEE. THERE IS A LAW
IN PLACE THAT WE WOULD LIKE
SPURS GAINERS BILL TO START TO
BEGIN I MEAN IT BEGINS IN
JANUARY WEARING HERE IN MARCH WE
REALLY WOULD LIKE FOR THAT TO
BEGIN AND TAKE HOLD IN ADDITION
WHEN I CAME TWENTY TWELVE I WILL
BE HONEST WITH YOU IF YOU ASK ME
WHETHER OR NOT AND- PROMISED
GEORGE AND SOME OF THE OTHER
FOLKS. THAT WE WOULD GIVE JUDGES
DISCRETION OF PROBABLY WOULD IN
A LASTING WE WANT TO DO MAINLY
BECAUSE WE HAD MANDATORY
MINIMUMS AND WE REALLY DIDN'T
GIVE THE JUDGES- WE BELIEVE NOW
AT LEAST I BELIEVE THAT JUDGES
ARE NOW IN THE BEST POSITION
WITH ALL EVIDENCE BROUGHT IN TO
MAKE THOSE KINDS OF THIS
DECISIONS AND NOT TO INHIBIT
THEM FROM BEING ABLE TO MAKE THE
MOST JUST. DECISIONS POSSIBLE
NOT KEEPING THE SCALE ONE WAY OR
THE OTHER AND SO UNFORTUNATELY I
WILL BE VOTING NO TODAY BUT I DO
BELIEVE THAT WE NEED TO CONTINUE
TO BRING THIS UP AND AGAIN I
COMMEND YOU FOR MAKING SURE
THAT- VALUE PROTECT API
COMMUNITY BECAUSE ONCE YOU
PROTECT API COMMUNITY PROTECT
AFRICAN AMERICAN LATINO- IN
OTHER COMMUNITIES THAT THE NEW
PROTECTION FROM FROM HATE.
CRIMES SO. IS THERE A MOTION.
MOVED THERE'S A. ON AB TWENTY
TWENTY SEVEN BY SEVEN MEMBER
CHOI THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER NO
LACKEY. BLACKIE I BONTA
FONTANELLE BRIAN- NO BRIAN NO
QUIRK QUIRK NO SANTIAGO SEYARTO
HI THERE TOO I. I'M SORRY THAT
MEASURE FAILS THANK YOU. PASSED
THE GAVEL ABOUT REGULATORY
CONSIDERATION AS DOES THE AUTHOR
WANT THAT THAT ARE. BOTH
APPRECIATE THAT OPPORTUNITY
FORWARD REQUESTS ARE USUALLY
WITHOUT ANY OBJECTION GROUP WILL
GRANT RECONSIDERATION
UNANIMOUSLY THANK YOU. SO I NEED
TO MAKE A I NEED TO PRESENT SOME
OF PASSED THE GAVEL TO MR LACKEY
. HE WAS AT JUDICIARY. DAVID
WELL THERE ARE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VAL A B. L. A. FORTY SIX. THANK
YOU MISTER AND MEMBERS AND
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR YOUR TIME
AND FOR WORKING WITH ME ON THIS
BILL ARE START BY SAYING THAT
WE'VE ACCEPTED THE COMMITTEE'S
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS AB EIGHTEEN
FORTY SIX IS AN IMPORTANT
MEASURE THAT WILL REQUIRE THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE TO
NOTIFY CRIME VICTIMS AND THEIR
FAMILY MEMBERS IF THEY WILL NOT
BE SENDING A REPRESENTATIVE
REPRESENTATIVE TO ATTEND A
PAROLE HEARING. IF A DISTRICT
ATTORNEY DOES NOT SEND A
REPRESENTATIVE AB EIGHTEEN FORTY
SIX WOULD REQUIRE THE STATE TO
REIMBURSE CRIME VICTIMS AND
THEIR FAMILIES IF THEY NEED TO
HIRE A PRIVATE ATTORNEY MEMBERS
IT IS A TYPICAL PRACTICE FOR A
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE TO
SEND REPRESENT REPRESENTATIVES
TO APPEAR AT PAROLE HEARINGS AND
DEMONSTRATE TO THE BOARD WHETHER
AN INMATE IS UNSUITABLE FOR
RELEASE. THE REPRESENTATIVE CAN
HIGHLIGHT THE SERIOUSNESS OF THE
INMATES CRIMES AND REBUT ANY
MISLEADING ARGUMENTS MADE BY THE
END MAY OR THE INMATE'S ATTORNEY
ABOUT THE CIRCUMSTANCES OF THE
CRIME. THE RECENT POLICIES
ENACTED IN ANGELES COUNTY.
DISTRICT BY LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY GEORGE GASC
GONE ARE ANYTHING BUT TYPICAL
SOME OF THESE POLICIES HAVE
CREATED HORRENDOUS CONSEQUENCES
FOR CRIME VICTIMS AND THEIR
FAMILIES. IN PARTICULAR HIS
POLICY OF FORBIDDING DEPUTIES
FROM ATTENDING PAROLE HEARINGS
HAS LEFT MANY VICTIMS OUT IN THE
DRIVE OUT TO DRY. CRIME VICTIMS
SHOULD NOT HAVE TO FEND FOR
THEMSELVES IN A COMPLEX LEGAL
SYSTEM. WITHOUT THE LEGAL
ASSISTANCE THEY NEED TO HAVE
THEIR LOVED ONES OR THEMSELVES
MEANINGFULLY REPRESENTED AND
PAROLE HEARINGS MANY VICTIMS AND
THEIR FAMILIES ARE UNABLE TO
FULLY VOICE THEIR CONCERNS. AB
EIGHTEEN FORTY SIX OFFERS THESE
CRIME VICTIMS AND THEIR FAMILIES
A NEEDED SOURCE OF SUPPORT
PASSAGE OF THIS BILL WILL DO THE
FOLLOWING. THE BILL WILL REQUIRE
THAT THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE NOTIFY VICTIMS THEIR
FAMILY MEMBERS AND THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS IF THEY WILL NOT BE
SENDING A REPRESENTATIVE TO A
PAROLE HEARING. ADDITIONALLY FOR
VICTIMS THAT SEEK OUT PRIVATE
LEGAL COUNSEL TO ASSIST WITH
PARTICIPATING IN A PAROLE
HEARING WHEN THE LOCAL DA WON'T.
AB EIGHTEEN FORTY SIX WILL
REQUIRE THE STATE TO REIMBURSE
VICTIMS FOR REASONABLE PRIVATE
ATTORNEY FEES OF UP TO NINE
HUNDRED DOLLARS. THESE
PROVISIONS ARE CRUCIAL PERFECT
FOR PROVIDING CRIME VICTIMS AND
THEIR FAMILIES THE SUPPORT THEY
NEED DURING THESE PAROLE
HEARINGS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. AND I DO HAVE TWO
WITNESSES ON THE LINE- RICHARD
BOSS OF HAS A HE WAS THE HUSBAND
OF A CRIME VICTIM AND TOKOPEDIA
OF CRIME VICTIMS UNITED AT A
BOARD MEMBER MOVE THE BILL.
BEFORE THAT WITNESS GOES FORWARD
THERE SEEMS TO BE A LITTLE BIT
OF CONFUSION WE NEED TO CLARIFY
ON THE AMENDMENTS. THERE'S NO
NEW AMENDMENTS OF THE ONES THAT
WERE IN PRINT IS THAT CORRECT
CORRECT. THANK YOU. OKAY
WITNESSES ON THE PHONE. DO WE
HAVE A SUPPORT WOULDN'T
WITNESSES MISTER RICHARD BOSS.
YES SIR YOU MAY PROCEED. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS RICHARD BOSS
THANK YOU FOR THAT YOU TESTIFIED
TODAY. I WISH I COULD HAVE TO BE
HERE THE FORTY YEARS AGO
HORRIBLE COMMITTED AGAINST MY
WIFE CHIU. YOUR A BEAUTIFUL
LOVING TWENTY YEAR OLD. ON A
SATURDAY MORNING CHOOSE OF.
BEATEN RAPED. MURDERED SURE
THAT'S FINE. YOU'RE WELCOME MAN
ONE TIME MERGER IT TOOK FIVE
DAYS AFTER. IN ORDER FOR EIGHT.
YEAH YOU DOWN THE NUMBER BY.
WHEN YOU'RE DONE. IN OTHER TO
THREE YEAR OF ONE WHY TO FIND
FIND OUT THE IDENTITY OF THE OUT
WITH THE- BECAUSE MODERN SCIENCE
IN THE SKILLED ANGELES COUNTY
SURE DEPARTMENT MURDER WAS
FINALLY TRACK DOWN. ARRESTED IN
. NUMBER TWENTY ONE OF ALL WAS
HEARING IMPAIRED. TWO TWENTY
TWO. I'M LOOKING I FOUND OUT THE
WOULD BE NO CAN EITHER JUST BE
ON TO BE OF MY- I FELT ANGER.
AND BETRAYED. REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER DISTRICT WOULD HELP US
COMMITTED HELP. THE SPEECH. THE
PROBOARDS MY WIFE WHAT THE HELP
OF SOME JUNGLE THE CONCERN.
APPENZELL FIELD CAPTAIN MENDOZA
DETECT CONSTABLE ANGELES CA
SHERIFF'S. CAPTAIN USED LONG I
WAS ABLE TO REGISTER FOR HERE IN. TO READ THE BALLPARK.
WELL FOR ONE YEAR BACK IN
SEPTEMBER TWENTY ONE. I WAS
ASKED BY STILL WANTED TO READ MY
IMPACTS EVEN NOT KNOWING WHAT MY
OPTIONS WERE I SAID YES I READ
THE IMPACT STATEMENT. AND AFTER
A LONG STAGE THE NEXT FOR HIM.
THEY NOTIFIED ME THAT THEY WERE
SORRYTHEY ARE HARDLY GRANTED
TYPOLOGY REQUEST ONE YEAR SAID.
WE DID THIS WITHOUT A ME IF I
HAD AN OBJECT. THE FOR ME THE
MAIN THE WILL BE. AND THE HYPE
CHURCH TO HELP HIM BECAUSE WE
COVERED. AND JUST LIKE THAT THEY
CAN COMMANDER DURING WHICH
INCLUDE. I COULDN'T IT THAT
NIGHT WAS TERROR YOU JUST KEPT
THINKING ABOUT THIS. CORN AND
HOW GOING TO REMOTE CALTRAIN
ANGER JUST AT MY- THERE ARE EVIL
PEOPLE IN WORLD. AND SOME CAN BE
. TO I APOLOGIZE ONE OF THE-
BUDGET BUNDY UNTIL LIKE SUCH.
NEXT DAY I EMAILED QUESTION TO
THE CORE WAR. THANK YOU KNOW NOT
TO SHARE MY LOOK BACK MEMBER HIM
I DIDN'T GET AN ANSWER. SO THE
DAY I CONTACT PEOPLE BOARD SHE-
OFFICE WERE NATIONALLY CON. CHIU
SAID MAN IN MIND THE MOST NOW
PARTLY HEARING AND TO BE GIVEN
THE HIGH BUDGET. ALSO IF SHE
THAT ABOUT ONE TO CAPTURE BUT IT
JUST TO THE PRO BOARD I SHOULD
NOTE. THEM THE BEGINNING. IN A
WORD LEGAL NO. A LAWYER DISTRICT
HAD TO INVOLVED THE PROCESS. I
COULD I BY AVOIDED FOUR MONTHS
NEEDLESS IDEA NUMBER. THE CHANCE
OF BOYS MY KIDS PRO THE BOARD.
ROCKIN A ONE YEAR STATE HI
BARGER. TO MAKE THE CASE THERE
ARE MANY MORE VICTIMS. RECEIVE
JUST A FRACTION OF THOSE BUT I
DID. ASSEMBLY NEED REPRESENT TO
MAKE SURE THE ARE. AND THE
PUBLIC JUST AS YOU IDENTIFIED
CAL TO THE THIRTY YEARS. ARE YOU
ARE JUST ABOUT SEEING THEIR- AND
JUST DAMAGED WILL BE. IN OUR- IN
ADDITION. I THINK THE BUSINESS
START FOR ME THE MOST QUARTER IN
I DIDN'T LEGAL COSTS WITHOUT
PROBLEMS FOR HELP. TWENTY OR
DOES IN TURN.
YES GOOD MORNING- THIS IS TOP OF
THE DOOR AND I'M ON THE
EXECUTIVE BOARD OF CRIME VICTIMS
UNITED ALL SHORTLY CALL
MENTIONED. BE A VERY TELLING
PERCENT TESTIMONY MISTER BOSS.
IN THIS FAMILY. IT IS HARD TO
BELIEVE THAT THE VICTIMS OF
CRIME COULD OR WOULD HAVE TO
TURN TO. ATTORNEY INSTEAD OF
RELYING ON THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY. BUT AS WE ALL KNOW
WHAT A FEW DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICES IN THE STATE. WITH THE
ADVENT OF MANY LAWS BUT
PROPOSITION FOR FORTY SEVEN TO
FIFTY MANY PEOPLE ARE BEING
RELEASED WITHOUT VICTIMS HAVEN'T
REPRESENTATION AND WITH MANY
TIMES. IN VIOLATIONS OF MARSY'S
LAW. THIS BILL WOULD BE ISSUED
IN SMALL RETROSPECT COMPARED TO
THE HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. THE STATE SPENDING ON
PUBLIC DEFENDERS AND INDIGENT
DEFENSE TRAVELS. YES WE AGREE
ALL THOSE INCLUDING PEOPLE BEING
CHARGED OF THE CRIME SHOULD
REPRESENTATION. BUT WHO WHO
WOULD'VE EVER THOUGHT WE WOULD
FIND OURSELVES IN A PLACE WHERE
VICTIMS ONCE AGAIN SHE
THEMSELVES. ABOUT PLEASE PUT
YOURSELF IN THE POSITION OF A
VICTIM OR THAT OF THE- IT'S FROM
THERE I AND WE'RE- SHE- IS IT.
THE ON BEHALF OF KERR VICTIMS.
WE HAVE THREE OR SUPPORT OF AB
FORTY EIGHTY FORTY SO. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DO YOU HAVE
ANY PERSONS IN THE ROOM THAT
WOULD LIKE TO. EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL. THANK YOU
CAN STONE STONE ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THE ONLY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. DID
WE HAVE ANY ON THE PHONE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS THEIR-
THEIR SUPPORT FOR AB. EIGHT
FORTY SIX. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTEEN FORTY SIX. PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THERE ON THIS PHONE AT
THIS TIME. THEN GO TO LINE.
SIXTY EIGHT. AS CHAIR MEMBERS
RANDY PERRY WITH THEIR READING%
ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF PORAC IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. LINE. FORTY
EIGHT. THIS CHAMBERS RUNNING
SHERMAN WITH OVERSIGHT SHARE
SENSATION ALSO REPRESENTING THE
POLICE OFFICERS THE VISION OF
ARCADIA BURBANK CLAREMONT CORONA
CULVER CITY FOR TEN IN THE WORLD
ONLY SCHOOLS NEWPORT BEACH HOUSE
THREE HOMEOWNER RIVERSIDE
CANNELLA AND POSTION A BSA- ALL
OVER THE BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU. LINE THIRTY SIX. PARDON ME
JUST A MOMENT. WHY THIRTY
PICTURE ONE IS NOW OPEN. MISTER
CARE MEMBERS LIEUTENANT BRENDAN
UP ON BEHALF OF THE WEALTHIEST
COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND A FINAL
CALL FOR ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO. THERE ARE NO
FURTHER PEOPLE LUCIC THEY WISH
TO SPEAK PARDON ME WOULD HAVE
ONE ADDITIONAL PERSON JUST A
MOMENT.
WE WILL NOW GO TO LINE ONE OH
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALL RIGHT
I'M JOINED I WANT TO MAKE SURE
NO ONE VOTE CARE. FOUR EIGHTY
TWO ZERO TWO SEVEN AND ALSO A
YEAR AB. ONE SIX ZERO THREE
THANK. MISTER CHAIR THERE IS NO
ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL THEY WISH TO
SPEAK. THANK YOU VERY MUCH DO WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES OF AN
OPPOSITION WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
THEIR- OPPOSITION THIS TIME.
RESTORED. YOU MAY PROCEED. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS- MY NAME'S
KEITH WIDELY- THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF ON COMMON LAW WHERE
WE- ARE NONPROFIT THAT WORKS TO.
MAKE A FAIR DISCRETIONARY PAROLE
PROCESS THAT'S THE WORK WE DO- I
HAVE- BEEN STUDYING THIS PROCESS
FOR TWENTY YEARS- AND APPEARED
IN HUNDREDS OF PAROLE HEARINGS
ALSO TEACH CLASSES BERKELEY LAW.
CALIFORNIA PRISONS AND
DISCRETIONARY PAROLE SO I I'M
VERY FAMILIAR WITH THIS PROCESS-
AB EIGHTEEN FORTY SIX CONTINUES
A TREND THAT DELIVERS NO JUSTICE
AND PROVIDES NO RELIEF CRIME
SURVIVORS. MORE THAN FORTY FIVE
YEARS AGO CALIFORNIA SEVERELY
LIMITED THE PAROLE BOARD'S ROLE
BECAUSE IT'S DECISIONS WERE TOO
OFTEN BASED ON BIASED. EMOTION
AND GUT FEELINGS SINCE THEN
WE'VE PASSED LAWS REQUIRING
SPECIAL PAROLE HEARINGS FOR
YOUTH AND ELDERLY AND FOR CRIMES
CAUSED IN PART BY DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. TO COUNTER THAT WE'VE
ALSO SEEN AN EXPANSION OF THE
ROLE OF VICTIMS IN THE PROCESS.
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT THE PRESENCE
OF A VICTIM IN A PAROLE HEARING
IS A STRONGER PREDICTOR OF THE
HEARING'S OUTCOME THAN MOST
OTHER FACTORS. YOUTH ELDERLY THE
ORIGINAL CRIME THE LENGTH OF
INCARCERATION OR THE AMOUNT OF
PROGRAM THE PERSON'S DONE. THIS
IS A PROBLEM FOR SEVERAL REASONS
FIRST- SURVIVORS HAVE NO UNIQUE
INFORMATION ABOUT OF PAROLE
APPLICANTS CURRENT. RISK TO
PUBLIC SAFETY. THE ROLE IN
RECOUNTING THE IMPACT OF THE
CRIME STIRS UP EMOTIONS OF
PAROLE COMMISSIONERS AND THEIR
DECISIONS ARE THEREFORE BASED ON
BIAS EMOTION AND GUT FEELINGS.
JUST AS THEY WERE FORTY FIVE
YEARS AGO SECOND THE PROCESS RE
TRAUMATIZE. COMMISSIONERS
DISCUSSED IN EXCRUCIATING DETAIL
THE WORST THING THAT EVER
HAPPENED TO SURVIVORS WHILE
PROVIDING NO OPPORTUNITY FOR
HEALING. YET OF GROWING BODY OF
RESEARCH SHOWING THAT A MAJORITY
OF SURVIVORS OF VIOLENT CRIME
CHOOSE RESTORATIVE JUSTICE WHEN
GIVEN AN OPTION. WE JUST DON'T
GIVE THEM AN OPTION- IF
CALIFORNIA REALLY CARED ABOUT
SERVING SURVIVORS WE WOULD
INVEST IN THAT KIND OF HEALING
PROCESS. AND NOT ADD TO THIS
HARMFUL HEARING PROCESS. THIRD
AND FINALLY THIS BILL ALLOCATES
DISPROPORTIONATE RESOURCES I
HAVE AN EXAMPLE RECENT EXAMPLE I
JUST HAD A HEARING. WITH EIGHT
SURVIVORS PRESENT IN THE HEARING
. UNDER THIS BILL EACH OF THEM
WOULD QUALIFY FOR AN ATTORNEY.
COSTLESS SEVENTY TWO HUNDRED
DOLLARS FOR ATTORNEYS JUST FOR
THAT ONE HEARING AND THAT'S
COMPARED TO JUST NINE HUNDRED
DOLLARS- FOR THE WANT ATTORNEY
THAT WOULD BE STATUTORILY
REQUIRED TO REPRESENT A PAROLE
APPLICANT THAT'S AN
UNCONSCIONABLE THIS. THIS
COMMITTEE SHOULD MAKE CLEAR THAT
THE LEGISLATURE WILL NOT BLINDLY
ENDORSE BILLS PROPOSED IN THE
NAME OF BECOMES WITHOUT
ASSESSING THE IMPACTS. COSTS IN
ACTUAL CORRELATION TO PUBLIC
SAFETY. WE STRONGLY URGE A NO
VOTE ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
MARCO GEORGE STRAIT HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTEEN FORTY SIX
I WANT TO FIRST SAY THAT WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS BUT
WE'RE SORRY BUT REGRETFULLY MUST
STILL OPPOSE- AND I WOULD JUST
ECHO OF THE COMMENTS THAT MR
WILEY MADE. AND SAY- THAT
BASICALLY. EIGHTEEN FORTY SIX.
IN A VERDANT LEE SEEKS TO
SUBVERT THE RULE OF LAW AND
REPLACE THE FACTORY EVAN PAROLE
PROCESS WITH AN EMOTIONALLY
DRIVEN PROCESS. WHERE THE FAMILY
. BECAUSE OF THAT EMOTION SEEK
TO EXERT UNDUE PRESSURE ON THE
PAROLE COMMISSIONERS. WHO ARE
PRIMARILY TASKED WITH ENSURING
BOTH THE SAFETY OF THE COMMUNITY
AND DUE PROCESS FOR THE
INDIVIDUAL. AND ALSO I WANT TO
SAY THAT PAYING FOR AND VICTIMS
LAWYERS WOULD MERELY CREATE A
BONANZA FOR POTENTIALLY
UNSCRUPULOUS LAWYERS TO PREY
UPON THE EMOTIONALLY VULNERABLE
VICTIMS AND THEIR FAMILIES BY
PROMISING THEM THAT THEY CAN
GUARANTEE THAN AN INDIVIDUAL BE
PAROLED. AND OF COURSE. THIS IS
A PROMISE THAT NO ETHICAL LAWYER
COULD MAKE SENSE THE BOARD'S
DECISION IS SUPPOSED TO BE
GOVERNED BY THE LAW ON THE FAX.
ALL THE WHILE THE TAXPAYERS WILL
BE STUCK WITH PAYING THE TAB.
WASTING THAT COULD HAVE BEEN
BETTER SPENT ON EDUCATION MENTAL
HEALTH CARE AND HOUSING. THESE
ARE PUBLIC GOODS THAT WOULD MAKE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY STAY FOR
EVERYONE. SO WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR NO VOTE. THANK YOU ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
LINEBACKERS FOR THE ELEVATOR
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK YOU
. AND NO THIS IS A PHONE LINES
INTO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
EIGHT FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO IN
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
INDIGO TOTAL SEVENTY ONE THIS IS
FOR OPPOSITION. ONE SEVENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. IS THIS
OPPOSITION SIXTEEN OH THREE. IT
IS NOT. EIGHTY SIX. VELADERO
AGAIN FOR OPPOSITION. TO FORTY
SIX ONE THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE
NOW OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS DONNA
MARC- CALLING ON BEHALF OF LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WHICH ALL
OF US ARE NOT CALLING IN
OPPOSITION TO AB EIGHTEEN FORTY
SIX THANK YOU. LINE TWO. GOOD
MORNING TURN MEMBERS JIM UNDER
ON BEHALF OF A FRIEND COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION OF- CAL AND
RESPECTFUL THANK YOU. LINE
EIGHTY TWO. GOOD MORNING I'M
GARCIA UPON ON ON BEHALF OF
SUBREGIONAL FREEDOM ARE IMPACTED
TO ME NOT IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. LINE THIRTY. THE MORNING
SHARING COMMITTEE HOTEL BEHALF
OF AN ISSUE AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. LINE
SIXTY. PARDON ME. I'M SIXTY YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. WELL. YES YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ALL I THANK. I
APOLOGIZE YOUR YOU'RE YOUR LINE
IS BARELY AUDIBLE WE COULD NOT
HEAR YOU KNOW. MISTER CHAIR
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK RIGHT
THANK YOU I WOULD NOT BRING IT
BACK TO. COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MISTER CORK. SAU MARSH MARSHES
LAW WAS- AN INITIATIVE AND AS
LONG AS WE HAVE THAT INITIATIVE
- I THINK IT'S ONLY RIGHT THAT.
PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT USED TO.
MATTERS OF LAW AND LAW COURT
HAVE SOMEONE TO GUIDE THEM
THROUGH THE PROCESS IF THE DA. A
KILLER FOR TELLY CAL OF THE
QUARTER THIS. DOES WISH TO SEND
SOMEONE A I THINK IT'S ONLY
RIGHT THAT THEY HAVE.
REPRESENTATION I THINK YOUR
ARGUMENTS BY AND LARGE ARE
ACTUALLY AGAINST. MARSY'S LAW IN
WHICH CASE YOU REALLY SHOULD.
THE ONLY WAY TO CHANGE THAT IS
TO HAVE ANOTHER INITIATIVE. SO
I'LL BE VOTING I. RESPOND TO.
BUT I HAVE THE STRUGGLE WITH
THIS ONE I THAT THAT WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR VICTIMS ARE
SUPPORTED THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS
. IN IN IN ENSURING THAT THEY
GET THE SUPPORT THAT THEY NEED.
I DO HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE
NOTICE. OR THE LACK OF NOTICING
AND IMPACT THAT THAT WILL HAVE
ON THE PEARLY. AND IN IN THEIR
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO SEEK
PAROLE- AND I HAVE ADDRESSED
THIS WITH YOUR- WITH YOUR STAFF-
AND WITH YOU AUTHOR AT. HEATEDLY
AND FOR THAT REASON I WILL BE
VOTING NO ON THIS. THANK YOU
WITH SUCH. SO I'M GONNA BE
SUPPORTING YOUR- YOUR BILL
TODAY- AS YOU KNOW A DE. I GOTTA
TELL YOU THERE'S A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE REAL WORLD AND THE
EDUCATIONAL WORLD AND WHAT WE
WISH WOULD HAPPEN. BUT I HAD A
CHANCE- THIS YEAR TO WITNESS. I
WHAT IF FEEL LIKE TWENTY THIRTY
YEARS LATER. WHEN THE A PERSON-
THAT- IS A NEIGHBOR OF MINE. WHO
ARE SUFFERED A HORRIFIC. ASSAULT
AFTER WATCHING HER DAD GET SHOT
IN THE FACE SHE GOT SHOT IN THE
CHEST SHE MANAGED TO SURVIVE.
HER HER PERPETRATOR CAME UP FOR
A PAROLE HEARING. AND THEY FOUND
OUT ABOUT THE LAST MINUTE. AND
THEY WERE CONVINCED THAT THEY
WERE GOING TO LET THIS GUY GO
AND BACK INTO SOCIETY. AND THE
FEAR IN THAT COUPLE. THAT THEIR
LIVES ARE GOING TO BE IN DANGER
THEIR KIDS LIVES ARE GOING TO BE
IN DANGER ISRAEL IT'S NOT
IMAGINED IT'S EDIBLE LASTING
EFFECT OF HAVING A HORRIFIC
CRIME PERPETRATED ON SOMEBODY.
AND SO THIS BILL HELPS THOSE
PEOPLE. HAVE A VOICE BECAUSE
THEY NEED TO HAVE A VOICE THIRTY
YEARS LATER FORTY YEARS LATER.
IT DOESN'T MATTER. WHAT HAPPENED
IN THAT IT HAPPENED THIRTY YEARS
LATER AND THIS PERSON HAS A
MIRACULOUSLY CHANGED. I HOPE
THEY CAN I HOPE THEY HAVE. I
HOPE THEY'VE FOUND WHATEVER IT
IS THAT MADE THEM THAT PERSON
WAY BACK THEN TO MAKE THEM A
BETTER PERSON BUT THAT DOES NOT
ALLEVIATE THE FEAR. THAT THESE
HAVE THESE. AND THEY HAVE TO
HAVE A WAY TO VOICE THEIR FEARS
EVEN IF IT MAKES THAT WHAT YOU
THINK THE PAROLE HEARING WHAT
MAKES IT A BIASED HEARING. THEY
THEY NEED TO HAVE A PLACE IN
THAT HEARING. IT'S NOT THEIR
FAULT THAT THEY ARE THERE. IT'S
THEIR FAULT THE MAYBE THEY
SURVIVED AND CAN BE THERE. AND
SO I'M GOING TO BE SUPPORTING
THIS BECAUSE IT MAKES SENSE
MAKES SENSE FOR VICTIMS. AND
WHILE I'M ALL FOR PEOPLE BEING
REHABILITATED. THERE IS A
LASTING EFFECT ON SOME ACTIONS
THAT PEOPLE TAKING THEIR LIVES.
AND TO SIMPLY DISMISS THAT THE
VICTIMS CONCERNS IN FAVOR OF
THAT AT TO ME IS WRONG. YES MR
LACKEY. YEAH FIRST OF ALL LET ME
JUST A CORRECT ONE OF THE-
INFERENCES- THERE WOULD BE
MULTIPLE NINE HUNDRED DOLLAR
REIMBURSEMENTS FOR MULTIPLE
CHARGES- SO QUESTION TO THE
AUTHORS OUT I. ON THAT IS
ACTUALLY NOT ACCURATE THIS IS
ACTUALLY SUPPOSED TO BE A LAST
DITCH EFFORT TO- REIMBURSE. WHO
HAVE PAID ALREADY PAID FOR
PRIVATE ATTORNEY- AND THE
ULTIMATE REASON IS BECAUSE THE
DA IS NOT SENDING REPRESENTATION
AT THE DA'S SEND REPRESENTING.
THEN THIS WOULD NOT GOING TO
AFFECT. AND THE WORD IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE MAN NINE
HUNDRED DOLLAR REIMBURSES WOULD
ONLY. TAKE PLACE IF THERE'S
MULTIPLE VICTIMS. AND NOT
MULTIPLE CHARGES THAT CORRECT
CORRECT. OKAY AND THE OTHER
PIECE AS WE KEEP TALKING ABOUT.
I'M I WAS A GAS WHEN I HEARD
THAT- IT'S BELIEVE THAT- VICTIMS
PRESENT IN FOR- JUST EMOTION TO
THE JUDICIAL PROCESS. EMOTIONS
ARE NOT ALWAYS MISLEADING- AND I
THINK THAT WE HAVE SUCH A STRONG
FOCUS ON REHABILITATING. THAT WE
FORGET ABOUT THEIR TERMS AND I
DON'T THINK. THE DALLAS A FAIR
PROCESS I THINK THAT- VICTIMS
DESERVE TO BE PRESIDENT THEY
DESERVE TO BE CONSIDERED AND
JUDGMENTS. AND- I'M I'M HOPING
THAT WE CAN MOVE IN THE
DIRECTION OF CONSIDERING
INVOLVING VICTIMS IN THIS
PROCESS WHICH THIS BILL DOES I'M
PROUD TO SUPPORT IT GLAD YOU
BROUGHT FORWARD. IN YOU. DID
YOUR- YOU GOT THAT LOOK I JUST I
- MR LACKEY AGREE WITH YOU THAT-
WE NEED TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO HAVE VICTIMS SUPPORTED- I DO
THINK THAT WE NEED TO ALSO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE. AT THE
BALANCE OF POWER RECOGNIZED
WITHIN THE PAROLE HEARING AND
HAVING AN OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
PEOPLE HAVE THE CURRENT CORRECT
NOTICING SO THAT THEY CAN
PREPARE AND HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO FULLY ADDRESS. THAT EMOTIONAL
MOMENT AND ADDRESS THOSE VICTIMS
CONCERNS IN THAT MOMENT IN THE
PRO HEARING IS ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL WHICH IS WHY A I
IMPLORE THE AUTHOR TO CONSIDER.
INC ADDING A NOTICING
REQUIREMENTS INTO THIS INTO THE
LEGISLATION. AND I THINK IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WERE WILLING TO
HAVE DEEPER CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
WITH WITH YOUR OFFICE. ANY OTHER
COMMENT. OKAY YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU I'M AB EIGHTEEN FORTY
SIX NOTIFICATION AND
REIMBURSEMENT PROVISIONS WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVE THE
ABILITY OF CRIME VICTIMS AND
THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PAROLE
HEARING PROCESS WE'RE DOING THAT
YOU KNOW AS WE SPEAK WE HAVE I'M
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION AND I GUARANTEE
YOU THAT THAT YOU DON'T JUST
WAKE UP IN THE MORNING YOU
DECIDE YOU'RE GOING TO COME AND-
WHICH YOU GIVE YOUR TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION IT WAS
ORGANIZED IT WAS ORGANIZED THAT
BY PEOPLE WHO UNDERSTAND THE
PROCESS. AND ARE VICTIMS DESERVE
THE SAME PROCESS AND THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL HELPS TO ENSURE- AS
YOU JUST HEARD WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT CRIME VICTIMS AND THEIR
FAMILIES ARE BEING NEGATIVELY
IMPACTED BY THE POLICIES OF LA'S
DISTRICT ATTORNEY AND- IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT WE THE STATE
STAND UP FOR CRIME VICTIMS AND
ENSURE THAT THEIR VOICES ARE NOT
HINDERED BY THE COMPLEX THE
COMPLEXITY OF THE JDICIAL
PROCEEDINGS WHEN A DA DOES NOT
ENGAGE IN THE PROCESS I URGE
YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- I I'M
INVOLVED PROBABLY IN IN A MORE
PAROLE HEARINGS THAT I DO NOT
WANT TO MY OFFICE CASTIGATING
LETTERS ONE OF I DID LEARN. IS
ONCE IS PAROLED- WE DO NOT READ
LITIGATE CRIME. IT'S ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT THEY'VE BEEN
REHABILITATED I THINK THIS IS
WHERE MAYBE SOME OF THE
CONFUSION IT IS NOT ABOUT. GOING
AFTER SOMEONE FOR CRIME THAT
THEY COMMITTED WELL GUESS WHAT.
THEY PAID THEIR SAID DEBT TO
SOCIETY. AND SO IT IS IT IS
IMPAIR. THAT YOU UNDER WHEN YOU
GO TO A HE- IS RELATED. IT IS
NOW SAYING WE NEED TO PUNISH YOU
MORE IS NOT SAYING THAT AT ITS-
THE QUESTION IS WILL YOU CAN
REHABILITATED. AND I THINK
THAT'S WHERE AND I DON'T WANNA
GET INTO DEBATE AWARE THAT DA
SHOW UP WHOEVER SHOWS UP AT IT
AT THE END OF THE DAY YOU WANT
TO MAKE. THAT THAT ENDED. HAS
BEEN FULL REHABILITATED AND
WHETHER OR NOT THEY'RE DANGER TO
SOCIETY AND COME OUT AGAIN- I
WANT YOU FOR WORKING WITH OUR
OFFICE. MORE FOR YOU WERE CUT
OFFICE AHEAD OF TIME SO THAT'S
WHY YOU DON'T HAVE TO TAKE
AMENDMENTS BUT ALSO WOULD URGE
YOU TO LISTEN TO IT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA SAID. ABOUT MAYBE
TAKING SOME MORE MEMBERS IF
DISTINCT OR TO GET OUT AND MOVE
FORWARD. BECAUSE I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE KEEP IT
BALLOTS. THAT IS WAIT ONE
TOGETHER AND YOU HAVE TO MAKE.
OF THAT INDIVIDUAL AND WHAT
THEY'VE DONE. WHILE THEY'RE IN
PRISON. TO MAKE THEMSELVES
BETTER. SO THAT WE THEY DO COME
BEFORE. A PAROLE HEARING. NOT
ONLY IS IT FAIR BUT WE
UNDERSTAND THAT WHEN WE MEAN TO.
CRAWL JUSTICE SYSTEM THE LEGAL
SYSTEM WHEN WE LET THEM OUT.
WE'RE PRETTY DARN CERTAIN. THAT
THE COMMUNITY WILL BE SAFE BUT
MOST IMPORTANT AT THE KERR TRY
IN A DAY. THEY BELIEVE THAT.
WHAT THEY DID WAS WRONG. THEY
SERVED OUR TIME AND WE LET THEM
OUT- AND SO- BECAUSE OF YOUR
COOPERATION WITH US TO MEET AND
HAVE AN AMENDMENTS. AND MY
BELIEF THAT YOU WILL LISTEN TO
WHAT. OF SOME OF THE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE IT SAID- AND I
HAVE POKED FAITH THAT YOU WILL
HELP TO IMPROVE THIS BILL. A
CHESHIRE AND I'VE. YOUR ON AB
FORTY EIGHT B. SIX BY A TERRACE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER. GENSER IRAQI. BLACKIE HI
BONTA. BONTA NEL BRIAN NO BRIAN
NO CORK ARE WORK I STEP. SEYARTO
THEATER I. THE MEASURES ON CALL
YOU NEED ONE MORE VOTE. AND WE
WILL. NOW GO TO. A. B. EIGHTEEN
FORTY SEVEN CALAVERAS ITEM
NUMBER THREE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN PERSON COMMITTEE
STAFFER WORKING WITH ME ON THIS
BILL I AB EIGHTEEN FORTY SEVEN
WILL HELP CRIME VICTIMS THEIR
NEXT OF KIN FAMILY MEMBERS AND
OTHER MEANING FLEE EXERCISE
THEIR RIGHTS DURING PAROLE AND
WE SENTENCING HEARINGS. RECENT
REGULATIONS FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS IMPOSE ON
REASONABLY DIFFERENT STANDARDS
AND NOTICE REQUIREMENTS ON CRIME
VICTIMS AND THEIR LOVED ONES IN
SOME CASES THE FAMILY MEMBERS OF
CRIME VICTIM'S ARE THE ONLY ONES
WHO ARE ABLE TO SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF THEIR LOVED ONES WHO LOST
THEIR LIVES AT THE HANDS OF
CRIMINALS. SHOULD THESE FAMILY
MEMBERS BE SUBJECTED TO
DIFFERENT NOTIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS THIS IS WHAT THIS
BILLS ADDRESSING IN MY VIEW IT'S
ENTIRELY UNREASONABLE TO
MAINTAIN THESE DIFFERENT
STANDARDS ADDITIONALLY RECENT
LEGISLATION PROVIDED FOR THE
COURT TO DISPENSE WITH HAVING AN
IN COURT HEARING ON A PETITION
FOR RESENTENCING IF THE
PROSECUTION AND DEFENSE ATTORNEY
AGREED. THIS UNFORTUNATELY
NEGLECTS TO ACCOUNT FOR THE
CONSTITUTION CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT OF CRIME VICTIMS TO BE
HEARD DURING ANY PROCEEDING AND
WHAT'S THE RIGHT OF A VICTIM IS
IMPLICATED. THE STATE NEEDS TO
OFFER CRIME VICTIMS CLEAR WAYS
TO PARTICIPATE IN SITUATIONS
WHERE THE PROSECUTION AND
DEFENSE ATTORNEY AGREED TO
DISPENSE WITH IN COURT HEARINGS.
TO REMEDY THESE OVERSIGHTS AB
EIGHTEEN FORTY SEVEN DOES THE
FOLLOWING THE BILL PROHIBITS THE
BOARD OF PAROLE HEARINGS FROM
REQUIRING MORE THAN FIFTEEN DAYS
MINIMUM NOTICE. THAT A VICTIM
VICTIMS NEXT OF KIN A MEMBER OF
THE VICTIM'S FAMILY OF VICTIMS
REPRESENTATIVE COUNCIL
REPRESENTING ANY OF THESE
PERSONS OR VICTIMS SUPPORT
PERSONS MUST GIVE THEIR
INTENTION TO ATTEND A PAROLE
SUITABILITY HEARING. THE BILL
ALSO PROVIDES CRIME VICTIMS A
MEANS OF HAVING THEIR OPINION
HEARD ON A PETITION OF
RESENTENCING EVEN IF THE DEFENSE
AND THE PROSECUTION BOTH AGREE
TO WAIVE THE HEARING. IF THEY
NOTIFY THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY
WITHIN FIFTEEN DAYS OF RECEIVING
THE NOTICE THAT RESENTENCING IS
BEING SOUGHT. THESE PROVISIONS
ARE NECESSARY FOR HELPING CRIME
VICTIMS MEANING FLEE PARTICIPATE
AND PAROLE AND RESENTENCING
HEARINGS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. I DO HAVE- ONE
WITNESS I PREPARED TO TESTIFY
TODAY WITH CRIME VICTIMS UNITED
. THEY'RE ON THE PHONE. EIGHTEEN
THE OPERATOR REPUBLICAN UP THE
LINE FOR REPRESENTATION CRIME
VICTIMS UNITED. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS TOP OF IT ALL IN AGAIN
ONCE AGAIN TO THIS COMMITTEE
THANK YOU ON BEHALF CRIME
VICTIMS UNITED I AM AN EXECUTIVE
BOARD MEMBER WHEN CRIME VICTIMS
UNITED WAS FOUNDED IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY NINE IT WAS DUE TO THE
UNFORTUNATE NEED OF THE TWO
INDIVIDUALS FOUND THIS
ORGANIZATION LIKE IN HER IT'S
LARGER. THERE DAUGHTER WAS MORE
. AND FOUNDER LITTLE SUPPORT THE
pVICTIMS OF CRIME VICTIMS UNITED
STARTED. I STRUGGLE TO TEST ONE
NINE. I SHOULD WITH THE ASK HOW
DID GET HERE. READ CRIME VICTIMS
UNITED WE'RE FIGHTING FOR THE
VICTIMS OF CRIMES HAVE
STANDARDS. YOU KNOW MAYBE NOT
THE SAME STANDARDS OF THE
PERSONS CONVICTED OF THE CRIME
IN WHICH THEY WERE A VICTIM OF.
BUT TO HAVE STANDARDS THAT CAN
SOMETIMES BE PREVENTATIVE OF THE
VICTIMS OF FAMILY AND WITH THE
NEXT YOU CAN. TAP TO REPAIR
PAROLE HEARINGS. AND HOW THEIR
DAY ESSENTIALLY IN COURT AND I
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU JUST SAID
MOMENTS AGO ABOUT. YOU KNOW THE
FACT THAT WE DON'T WANT TO READ.
THE CASE- IN THE END THE
TREATMENT- PREVENTION BILL BUT
IN THIS INSTANCE THESE VICTIMS.
ARE STILL VICTIMS AND THEY WILL
NEVER NOT BE VICTIMS IT APPEARS
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS IS
MAKING RULES. THAT ARE HURDLES
AND HURDLES THAT CARRY A MUCH
HIGHER BURDEN FOR THE VICTIMS TO
APPEAR AT THIS POLL HEARINGS. WE. HAVE TO ASK OURSELVES WHY. I
TOLD YOU I THIS COME WE HAVE TO
START LOOKING UP FOR VICTIMS. AS
MUCH AS THE BEING DONE FOR THOSE
CHARGED AND IN THIS INSTANCE
CONVICTED OF A CRIME. I DON'T
WANT TO CALL CRIMINALS THEY'RE
CONVICTED OF A CRIME. AND ONE
MORE THING THIS BILL DOES WHY
WOULD WE PREVENT AN ATTORNEY ON
BEHALF OF THE VICTIM. APPEARING
IN PERSON WE ALL KNOW BEING IN
PERSON IS A LOT MORE IMPACTFUL
THAN IT REMOTELY SO ON BEHALF OF
CRIME VICTIMS UNITED WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AND A YES VOTE ON
AB. EIGHTEEN FORTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU. ANY WITNESSES IN HERE IN
THE AUDITORIUM FOUR IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES ON ON CALL THEY
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
OF THE BILL. AB. EIGHTEEN FORTY
SEVEN. I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
PRESS. ONE ZERO. GOING TO GO TO
THE BLIND. SIXTY EIGHT. ONE
SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN PLEASE RESPOND. MISTER
CHARITY PEERS THAT WE HAVE NO
ONE WHO IS SIGNALED THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK OKAY ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
THEY'RE IN A ROOM. ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. YOU SAME GOING TO
THE LINE PHONE LINES ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO AB.
EIGHTEEN FORTY SEVEN. SPEAKING
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. WE'RE GOING TO GO TO LAW
NOT THIRTY. THE MORNING CARE
NUMBERS YOU'RE A GREAT BUT ALL
OF THE HAPPINESS YOU JUSTICE AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK YOU. WHY NOT. THIRTY FIVE. ONE
THIRD. YEAH MY NAME IS RUNNING-
I GIVE ARE CALLING ON BEHALF OF
LEGAL SERVICES FOR PRISONERS
WITH CHILDREN ALL OF US ARE NOT
IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. AS CHAIR THERE IS NO ONE
ELSE TO SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK. THANK YOU NOW BRING BACK
TO COMMITTEE FOR ANY COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU AB EIGHTEEN FORTY SEVEN AS A
REASONABLE BILL THAT PROVIDES
CRIME VICTIMS WITH BETTER ACCESS
TO PAROLE AND RESENTENCING
HEARINGS SO THAT THEIR VIEWS CAN
BE HEARD I RESPECTFULLY URGE AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. CHAIRS
RECOMMENDING I'D CALL THE ROLL.
ON AB EIGHTEEN FORTY SEVEN BY
SEPTEMBER BY A TERRORIST THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER. JONES SAWYER HI LACKEY.
LACKEY I BONTA. VOTING BONTA NOT
VOTING BRIAN. PRICE NOT VOTING
COURT. CORK I SANTIAGO. SEYARTO
C. R. TÔI. THE MEASURE CALL
NEEDS. AND MISTER SALAS ITEM
NUMBER ONE A. B. SIXTEEN OH
THREE SALAS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THEY FOR YOU- ASSEMBLY
BILL SIXTY NO THREE WHICH IS A
MEASURED APPROACH TO FELONY
THEFT PROVISION OF PROPOSITION
FORTY SEVEN NO ACCORDING TO A
RECENT POLL FROM UC BERKELEY A
MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIA VOTERS
VOTERS SUPPORT CHANGING
PROPOSITION FORTY SEVEN FOR
CERTAIN TYPES OF PROPERTY CAT
CRIMES LIKE SHOPLIFTING. AB
SIXTY NO THREE WILL GIVE
CALIFORNIANS THAT CHANCE FOR
FRIGHT BY PROVIDING THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REDUCE THE
CURRENT FELONY THRESHOLD FROM
NINE HUNDRED AND FIFTY TO FOUR
HUNDRED DOLLARS WERE PREVIOUSLY
STOOD PRIOR TO PROPOSITION FORTY
SEVENS PASSAGE IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN. OVER THE PAST YEAR THE
NATIONAL RETAIL SECURITY SURVEY
REPORTED STATED THAT ABOUT 69%
OF RETAILERS SAID THEY HAD SEEN
AN INCREASE IN ORGANIZED RETAIL
CRIME. THE REPORT ALSO NOTES
THAT RETAILERS SAY THE STAFF
HAVE BECOME MORE AGGRESSIVE AND
VIOLENT IN YEARS PAST
ADDITIONALLY CALIFORNIA
PROSECUTORS STATE THAT THE
NUMBER OF DEATHS ARE LIKELY
UNDER REPORTED AS BUSINESS
OWNERS ARE DISCOURAGED FROM
FILING REPORTS SINCE THE PENALTY
AGAINST CRIMINALS HAS BEEN
REDUCED TO A MISDEMEANOR. AB
SIXTY NO THREE PROVIDES
CALIFORNIA VOTERS A CHANCE TO
MAKE THEIR VOICES HEARD ON THIS
ISSUE OF INCREASED THEFT IN OUR
STATE WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY
OVER THE PHONE IS ROGER BARR A
LOCAL BUSINESS OWNER AND- WHO
HAS DEALT FIRST HAND WITH THE
CONCERNING RISE IN CRIME. WITH
THAT I'D PUT YESTERDAY OVER TO
THE WITNESS. THE TESTIFYING BY
PHONE MR BRAR. YOU MAY BEGIN. HI
A GOOD MORNING EVERYONE MY NAME
IS ROCKY BAR ON THE CHIEF
OPERATING OFFICER OF THE
COUNTRYSIDE MARKET A RESTAURANT-
WE'RE HERE IN CENTRAL VALLEY WE
HAVE PLAYED BUT FIVE HUNDRED
FOLKS. AS AN MEMBER BLUE. WE ARE
REALLY STRUGGLING RIGHT NOW WITH
THAT. AND I'VE BEEN WORKING MY
DAUGHTER SO THAT WAS SIXTEEN
YEARS OLD WITH MY FAMILY AND
WE'VE NEVER SEEN WHAT WE HAVE
TODAY. HE UNDERSTANDS THAT THAT
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO BE CHARGED
WITH A CRIME AND SO. EVERYTHING
LOOKED AT OUR STORES WE HAVE
PEOPLE WHO RIDE IN. GRAB ITEMS
AND LEAVE. AND THIS IS JUST ALL
ACROSS THE BOARD UP AND DOWN THE
VALLEY- AND IT'S VERY
INTIMIDATING TO OUR EMPLOYEES
WHO ARE SCARED. FOR THEIR-
SAFETY OUR POLICE DEPARTMENT
THEY DON'T EVEN COME OUT THEY'RE
AWARE THAT. THEY CAN DO AND THIS
IS WHAT WE'RE DEALING WITH ON A
DAILY BASIS- WE'VE NEVER SEEN IT
LIKE THIS. AND THE THIEVES ARE
VERY BADLY THERE UNDERSTAND
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE GOING TO
JAIL IT DOESN'T MATTER IF YOU
RECORD THEM TAKING A PICTURE
WITH YOUR PHONE. IT THERE IS NOT
TO IT AND THE ALMOST BECOME.
EXPIRED LIKE EVERYBODY KNOWS
WHAT THE CURRYING AND THEIR PATH
THAT MESSAGE ALONG TO THEIR
FRIENDS. AND JUST BECOMING
SOMETHING WE'RE DEALING WITH
EVERY SINGLE DAY. AT POLICE
OFFICERS THERE STRAINED A LETTER
NOW THAT THERE'S NO POINT FOR
THEM TO COME OUT- WE EMPLOY
FOLKS AND- YOU KNOW KIDS THAT
COME IN SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN YEARS
OLD THE FIRST TIME JOB. AND
THEY'RE PETRIFIED AND THEY'RE
SCARED AND THEY'RE REAL BIG
LIABILITIES AT THE BUSINESS
OWNER. IT ALSO AFFECTS OUR
VENDORS ECONOMICALLY WE ARE NOT
NO LONGER BUYING NOVELTY ITEM.
WHICH IS THE TRICKLE DOWN EFFECT
TO EVERYBODY INVOLVED IN THE
SYSTEM BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
THOSE ITEMS ARE GOING TO BE
STOLEN. I IMPLORE THIS COMMITTEE
TO. APPROVED SUPPORT AB. OH
THREE. IT'LL BE A HUGE BENEFIT
TO ALL OF US IN THE INDUSTRY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. OF AB SIXTEEN OH THREE
SALAS NEWS THERE IN THE ROOM
RIGHT NOW. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN RESOLUTION MUCH AROUND
HAVE TO CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. MARCHER COMMITTEE
CERTAIN WHO THE LEON WITH HER
SECOND SHARES FARMING AND WE
SUPPORT THEM THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING SURE MEMBERS JEWISH
CHRISTIAN REPRESENTS SO MANY
CULTURES BERMAN INCH IN SUPPORT
OF THE SCUFFLE THANK YOU. NOW GO
TO THE PHONE LINES- IN SUPPORT
OF AB SIXTEEN OH THREE YOU MAY
OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES EIGHTEEN
T. OPERATOR. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SIXTEEN OH
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
PRESS ONE AND YOUR AT THIS TIME
. WE'RE GOING TO FIRST GO TO
LINE. ONE THIRTY THREE. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE BARGAINS ALL THIS ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY THE SANTA
CLARITA IN CAMERA RIO SUPPORT
THANK YOU. USER LINE. FORTY
EIGHT. ONE MISTER MEMBERS RYAN
WITH THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION ALSO REPRESENTING
THE POLICE OFFICERS ASSOCIATION
ARCADIA BURBANK CLAREMONT CORONA
CULVER CITY FOR TEN IN THE WORLD
THE ONLY SCHOOLS NEWPORT BEACH
CALIFORNIA MONA LISA IT'S SANTA
ANA OPPOSING AND PLUS YOU CAN I
GET YOUR ASSOCIATION ALL
IMPORTANT. THANK YOU. LINE ONE
HADN'T- HELLO THIS IS NOT A
CLOSE FROM SACRAMENTO I DON'T
VITAMINS THE LITTLE. BLIND WHY.
THIRTY FIVE. GOOD MORNING JERRY
DR HERNANDEZ NOW LIVING CONTENT
I'LL CALL IN STRONG TO EIGHT ONE
SIX FOUR THREE THANK YOU. THIS
LINE TWENTY ONE. FIND TOWARD ONE
YEAR OLD IS NOW OPEN. HI THIS IS
FELICE JOHN I'M- FROM DINO.
WHAT'S CALLED. SB SIX ONE THREE.
SO WE'RE NOW AT LAW OPEN FOR
INTO THAT ARE IN SOME OF AB.
SIXTEEN OH THREE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THIS IS TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SIXTEEN OH THREE
YOU'RE NOT CAUGHT CALLING AND
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF SIXTEEN
OH THREE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO TO
REMOVE YOURSELF FROM THE QUEUE.
WE ARE ONLY TAKING THOSE TO
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT RIGHT NOW.
WHEN I GO TO LINE ONE THIRTY
NINTH. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
LINE. ONE TWENTY. BY ONE TWENTY
YEAR ONE IS NOW OPEN. ONE HAD
PARDON ME MY NAME ONLY ANY I
WANT TO POP. SIXTEEN OH THREE.
MY NAME IS AMY I WANT TO PUT
SIXTY NO THREE. THANK YOU. AND A
FINAL CALL FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SIXTEEN OH
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. LINE PENN YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
JEANNIE I WANT. A. B. THANK YOU
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SHE'S
DETERMINED. LINE ONE TWENTY SIX
YES THAT THIS FAILURE FROM
SENTIMENTAL I'M SUPPORT- A. B.
ONE SIX OH FREE. WINE ONE FORTY
ONE. HELLO HELLO I'M I'M I'M
HELEN ELK GROVE AND I WANT TO
SUPPORT THE FIELD PLEASED THIS.
TAKE MISTER CHAIR THERE IS NO
ONE ELSE IS SIGNALED BY WHICH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT AND
WE HAVE ONE MORE PERSON IN THE
ROOM IN SUPPORT THANK YOU SO
MUCH KIM STONE OF STONE ADVOCACY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND NOW
WE'RE- BRING IT IN FOR WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. YOU MAY COME TO.
THE TABLE FIVE MINUTES. FIVE
MINUTES TOTAL SPLIT UP ANYWHERE
YOU WANT.
GOOD MORNING TOM OFTEN G. PUBLIC
SAFETY ADVISER FOR CALIFORNIA
FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE SMILE
THIRD COMMITTEE MEETING ABOUT
PROP FORTY SEVEN AND THANK YOU
FOR THE PRIVILEGE OF BEING ABLE
TO TALK. FIRST OFF OF PROP FORTY
SEVEN DID NOT CHANGE THE
THRESHOLD FOR- MISDEMEANOR
FELONY TO FROM FOUR HUNDRED AND
NINE FIFTY THAT OCCURRED FIRST
IN TWO THOUSAND AND TEN. PROP
FORTY SEVEN DID- CHANGE THE
WATER SECTIONS OF IT BUT IT
DIDN'T- MOVE THE THRESHOLD AT
NINE FIFTY. THE PERHAPS EVEN
MORE IMPORTANTLY. AT NINE FIFTY
THERE ARE THIRTY NINE STATES IN
THE UNION TO HAVE A HIGHER
THRESHOLD FOR THE A OF DIVISION
BETWEEN MISDEMEANOR FELONY- OF
VIOLENCE. IF WE RETURN TO FOUR
HUNDRED OTHER WOULD BE ONE STATE
NEW JERSEY WHO HAS A LOWER
THRESHOLD THEY CURRENTLY HAVE A
THRESHOLD OF TWO HUNDRED. TWO
HUNDRED DOLLARS SUPPORT
UNDERSTAND TOO THAT THE PEW
FOUNDATION DID A LOT OF VERY
FLORAL FALL- INDEPENDENT. AUDIT
OF THE IMPLICATIONS OF CHANGING
THE THRESHOLD UP TO SEND SOME
INSTANCES LIKE TEXAS. TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS- IT HAD NO
IMPACT ON EITHER REPORT CRIME OR
INCIDENTS AT ALL IT'S- A
BASICALLY A NEUTRAL- FOR PRIME
PREVENTION POINT OF VIEW IT IS-
AS IS TO OBVIOUSLY CECILIA
DESIGNED TO BE. A WAY TO CASE
MANAGE FRAUD DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
COURTS AND PRISON POPULATIONS.
AND OF COURSE OUR PRISON
POPULATION IS STILL UNDER THE
GUIDELINES OF THE FEDERAL
COURTS. THE THE THREES ARE- IS
I'VE HAD TO DO IT OR BEEN ABLE
TO PARTICIPATE IN ALL HAVE A SO
CENTRAL WHEN IT COMES TO FORTY
SEVEN AND NOT TO BE FLIPPANT
ABOUT IT BUT IF WE COULD JUST
GET BACK TO WHERE WE CAN PUT
PEOPLE IN STATE PRISON FOR THEFT
WILL BE RELEASED A WHOLE LOT
BETTER OFF. AND AGAIN I REMIND
FOLKS FOR DECADES THE CLEARANCE
RATE OR WHICH IS JUST A REST-
DIFFICULT ARREST NOT CONVICTION
FOR ALL CRIMES GO CONNECTED TO
PROP FORTY SEVEN WASHINGTON FEB
RUN SOMETHING LESS THAN 5% 50%
OR EVEN REPORTED 5% OR
IDENTIFIED CAPTURED. YOU COULD
DIVIDE THAT BY ANOTHER THIRD FOR
CONVICTION SO YOU'RE RUNNING
SOMEWHERE AROUND 3% WHEN YOU
LOOK AT BOB OF SERVICE RATES THE
PRIME OR THE HIGHEST RECIDIVISM
RECIDIVISM RATES IN OUR
POPULATIONS JAIL AND PRISON.
FIRST AND SECOND DRUMMERS
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR. MARCADA
CONCLUDED DRUG OFFENSE PROP
CRIMES IN THEFTS THEY RUN ABOUT
SO FIVE. I'VE SAY BECAUSE THE
VERY TARGET POP THE FORTY SEVEN
FUN SIX HUNDRED MILLION TO DATE
A HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET.
THE TARGETS THAT VERY GROUP.
THAT GROUP WHEN THEY ARE
PROGRAMS AND I HAVE VERY
DIFFERENT FEELINGS AND SOME
MEMBERS RESPECTFULLY OF THE
COMMITTEE AROUND THE
IMPLICATIONS OF- A- RAW VOTE
TREATMENT AND REHABILITATION
WHEN THAT GROUP IS TREATED THEY
WERE SORT OF IT AT A MUCH LOWER
RATE. THIS IS BEEN CONFIRMED BY
OUR OWN BORDER STATE AND
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS. AND ALL
AND FINE. THE PROP FORTY SEVEN
HAS UNIQUELY PUMPED. A SIX
<c.red>UNDRED MILLION DOLLARS UNDER</c>
OUR COMMUNITY SINCE TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN FOR THINGS TO INCLUDE
THERE'S ALWAYS TALK ABOUT
VICTIMS ARE SINCERELY RESPECT
THAT. SEVENTEEN FROM OVER A
RELIEF CENTERS ARE NOW OPEN THAT
WEREN'T OPEN PART OF FOR SEVEN.
FOR ALL THESE WE STRONG.
RECOMMEND A NO VOTE ON ON BOTH
ENDS THIRD THRESHOLD. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR. THE FRIENDLINESS
. ACTION IN OPPOSITION ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF THE FROM THE
PREVIOUS DAY UNDER LAW OF THE
COMMITS A MISDEMEANOR THAT MAY
FACE SIX MONTHS AND COUNTING
EVERY VIOLATION THE. DECISION OF
A DIFFICULT TIME. ASK YOU THOSE
FOR MISDEMEANOR THAT IF OTHER
THAN THIS OF THE EDITOR.
POLITICAL NOTWITHSTANDING.
CURRENT THAT LAWS ARE GOING TO
PARTICIPATE IN THOSE IN MANY
OTHER STATES I'M PROBABLY
MENTION IN SOUTH CAROLINA TEXAS-
YOU CANNOT BE CHARGED WITH A
FELONY ABOUT THE AND OF LOSS. IS
AT LEAST TWO. TWO THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED SPECS. SB SIX HUNDRED SO
LAW PRISON. BY REDUCING AMOUNT
NEED TO CHARGE FOUR HUNDRED.
THIS NOT JUST BY ACTUAL THAT.
WOULD CANISTERS OF THE CALL OF
IMPRISONING MORE PEOPLE'S I
GREAT HUMAN AND ASSISTANCE
WITHOUT COMMENSURATE BENEFITS OF
. IT'S BEEN THE REASON AND THE
REASON ECONOMIC HOLLY. THAT WE
ARE NOT. THANK THANK YOU IN THE
OTHER WITNESS IN OPPOSITION ONE
BACK AS FELLOW CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS STRONGLY OPPOSED THANK
YOU. MARCOS FOR THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ONLY CELOS BEHALF OF DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE IN OPPOSITION. A LITTLE
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. JERRY WITH A
CALIFORNIA NATIVE FO PROJECT
BORN A REYES MR SOLVES DISTRICT
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE SIXTEEN OH
THREE RY CLASSIFIED UNDER PROP
FORTY SEVEN MYSELF. THANK YOU
WILL NOW GO TO THE PHONE.
EIGHTEEN OPERATORS WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO AB. SIX OH THREE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR UP FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AND AS A REMINDER.
PLEASE IDENTIFY BY YOUR NAY AND
AFFILIATION ONLY. GOING TO GO TO
LINE TWENTY. SIX THE MORNING
EVERY INLINING ADALAH EDWARDS I
MUST OVER INCOME GROWN UP WITH.
LINE. NINETY FIVE. CLERESTORY
AND I WERE TRYING TO LEARN AND
I'M A STRONG. BY. ONE TWENTY.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS CLARK
GONZALEZ AND I LIVE IN LOS
ANGELES I'M CALLING ON
OPPOSITION TO AB SIXTEEN OH
THREE THANK YOU. LINE. ONE FORTY
SEVEN. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
DAVE MORROW OF FURTHER WORK FOR
THE ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION OF
THE HOPE AND REDEMPTION HE MIGHT
I AM CALLING- IN STRONG
OPPOSITION AGAINST AB SIXTEEN OH
THREE THANK YOU. BLIND. TWENTY
FIVE. YES HELLO MY NAME IS
STEVEN CRISTIANO MY LIFE COACH
ON THE OPEN TENSION TEAM ATLANTA
RIGIDITIES CORPORATION AND I'M
CALLING TO STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
SIXTEEN OH THREE THANK YOU. LINE. GOOD MORNING NUMBERS MY NAME
IS THE DIRECTION AND ALL OF TIME
DONE I AM YOU OPPOSITE THANK YOU
. LINE. ONE TWO SEVEN. GOOD
MORNING JERRY MEMBERS THIS IS AS
LONG AS WITH THE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION AND I'M CALLING IT TO
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. LINE. THIRTY FIVE. HI MY
NAME IS DRAWN OF ALL I GET ARE
POLICY ANALYST WITH LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN ALL OF US NOT CALLING A
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. LINE. ONE THIRTY ONE.
KIM WHEN GOD BEING OF THE PRESS
COMMITTEE ON LET THAT CALIFORNIA
IN OPPOSITION. LINE TWENTY ONE.
WE SHOULD JUMP AGAIN WITH COKE
AND RE PUBLIC BECAUSE THE STRONG
A. B. C. HUNDRED. LINE ONE SIX.
HELLO THIS IS RYAN ELAINE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION APOLOGIES THIS
SUPPORT BUT WE ARE NOT SUPPORT
AMENDED PETITION THANK YOU. WHY
EIGHTY TWO OKAY PRAYER GARCIA
APONTE DALY ON AVERAGE KNOW
FREEDOM ALL AND PROJECT AMIGA IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. WINE
TWENTY. DIVINA ROBERTSON AND I
AM CALLING IN STRONG OPPOSITION
TO AB SIXTEEN ON THIRD SIXTEEN
OH THREE ON BEHALF OF
CONGREGATIONS ORGANIZED FOR
PROPHETIC ENGAGEMENT COPE THANK
YOU. BLIND. SEVENTY ONE. ONE
SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. LINE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
GREGORY CANNELLA A HALF OF AN
JEFF THE OPPOSITE THANK YOU.
LINE. EIGHTY THREE. I NEED A
THREE YEAR LINE NOW OPEN. FIND
THE. FIFTY SEVEN. BUT- CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES SIR- MY NAME IS
MICHAEL JURADO- REPRESENTING-
START NOBODY CAN RIVERSIDE KNOX
OPPOSE A. B. SIXTEEN OH THREE.
LINE. FORTY SIX. GOOD MORNING
CHEN MEMBERS MINIMUM INDIANA
HONEY CATCH AND I'M CALLING AND
RESPECTFUL AND STRONG OPPOSITION
TO AB SIXTEEN OH THREE ON BEHALF
OF THE DOLLARS WHAT THE
FOUNDATION THANK YOU. LINE
TWENTY FIVE. I LIKE THE TOWN
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA CALLED AND
CALL YOU NOT AB THREE. WHY. ONE
EIGHT. WHY ONE THIRTY YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. YES HELLO MY NAME
IS MAKAYLA TIRED AND I'M CALLING
FROM SAM COUNTY BEHALF OF COKE
IN STRONG. THANK YOU. LINE
THIRTY NINE. YES MY NAME IS
CALVIN MOORE AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF INLAND GENETICALLY
CHANGED AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. WINDS. FORTY THREE.
MY NAME IS DAVID KAY AND I
STRONGLY. AGREE I SUPPORT AB
SIXTEEN OH THREE. LINE ONE FORTY
NINE. GOOD MORNING SURE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS KEVIN ROBERTS AMONG
THE STAFF AT THE MOMENT WAS
COALITION I'M CALLING STRONG
OPPOSITION TO AB SIXTEEN OH
THREE THANK YOU. ONE ONE TWENTY
ONE. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
PASTOR SHAWN UP ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND I'M CALLING IN
STRONG OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL
THANK. LINE. ONE THIRTY NINE.
GOOD MORNING CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YEAH OKAY GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS TONY MCNEILL ON THE DIRECTOR
OF ORGANIZING FOR FAITH AND
ABOUT THROUGHOUT THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND WE ARE CALLING IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO AB SIXTEEN
OH THREE. WHY ONE THIRD SEVEN
HELLO MY NAME IS AMBER BROUGHT
MY WORK FOR THE OFFICE OF THE
VIRGINIA REENTRY AND I'M AND
OPPOSITE AS WELL WITH EXTERNAL
CORRECT. LINE. SEVENTY FOUR. ONE
SEVENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. ON THE LINE. THIRTY ONE.
OKAY LINE THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE
GOOD MORNING AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS JOE PATTERSON AND I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF HUNDRED. EIGHT MEN IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO SB FIFTY
NOT THREE. THANK YOU. LINE. ONE
FORTY TWO. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
SHOULD SHE DRAWS ME AND I'M
CALLING FROM ALL OF US OR NONE
IN BAKERSFIELD KERN COUNTY AND
WE ARE IN STRONG OPPOSITION OF
AB SIXTY NINE THREE. BUYING
FORTY THREE. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS JARED HOW I'M CALLING
FROM BAKERSFIELD I'M CALLING IN
STRONG OPPOSITION AB. SIXTEEN OH
THREE. LINE. FOR LINE AND NO ONE
NOW OPEN. BY. NINETY NINE. THE
MORNING CARE AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS LESLIE KEAN AND I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF COKE AND TIMBRE TO
DINO AND I MENTIONED ON THE
POSITION OF AB SIXTEEN ALL
THREE. FIND ONE- TO. HELLO MY
NAME IS KATHERINE I'M CALLING IN
STRONG OPPOSITION OF AB FIFTEEN
OH THREE ON BEHALF OF SHOWS
FAMILY. A LINE. NINE GENERAL
DYNAMICS BY FIND THAT THERE ARE
I AM CALL IN STRONG. HELLO THREE
THANK YOU. WHY ONE FIFTEEN. HI
MY NAME IS JOSH- CALLING FROM
RUDY SALAS DISTRICT EVENINGS
CALIFORNIA- WHERE WE'RE CALLING
IN OPPOSITION ON BEHALF OF THE
PEOPLE IN HIS DISTRICT THE
MOBILE TECH. LINE. THIRTY TWO.
MORNING SHOW WILL MEMBER OF HIS
RODRIGUEZ CALLING FROM LONG
BEACH- I'M CO IN STRONG. TO A.
B. SIXTEEN. ALL NINE THANK YOU.
WHY EIGHTY. THIRTEEN A PLAN FOR
DEALING ON WHATEVER YOU OF ALL
AND MONEY JUST WANT TO CLARIFY
WE ARE IN SHOCK OPPOSITION NOT
SHOWN SUPPORT YEAH. LINE. EIGHTY
TWENTY THREE OH ONE IS NOW OPEN. LINE SIX DAY. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS ROB GO CALLING FROM SAN
DINO OF CONGREGATIONS ORGANIZED
FOR PROFIT CAN GAUGE IT YOUR
STRAW THE TO THE A. B. ONE SIX
OH THREE. LINE ONE TWENTY. ONE
ONE TWENTY OR ONE IS NOW OPEN.
YES FIVE MILLION BY MY IMAGE
STRONGER POSITION OF. FIFTY OH
THREE. LINE ONE SIXTY. TWO GOOD
MORNING NAME IS MARK TAYLOR I'M
IN STRONG TO A. B. THANK- THREE
ON OF THE HOURS IT WAS IN
COLLEGE THANK YOU. FIND ONE
FIFTY SEVEN. MY NAME IS MARVIN
BOB DONNAN FROM LEGAL SERVICES
FOR WHICH I STRONG OPPOSE A. B.
SIXTEEN OH THREE. ONE ONE SIX
FOUR. HELLO MY NAME IS DON
GUARDINO FOR THE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION AS A LIFE COACH WITH
THE HOPE OF REDEMPTION CAME AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE. SIX ZERO
THREE. LINE. ONE NINE. ONE ONE
OH NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
IN A MOVE BONTA LIED. ONE SIXTY
FIVE. HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
IVANA GONZALEZ WOULD LEGAL
SERVICES REPRESENT THE CHILDREN
ON AFFECT YOUR NONE OF THE
COALITION FAMILY UNITY IN STRONG
OPEN OF THE A. B. OKAY. LINE ONE
SIXTY SIX. MORE MY NAME CANDACE
LEWIS AND I AM WE DID TEAM COACH
FOR THE AND I WOULD THEM CLICK I
AM CALLING TO STRONG EIGHTY SIX
YOU KNOW THREE THANK YOU. WHY.
ONE SIXTY. THE MORNING MY NAME
IS WHICH WILL BE DOES THE ALLOW
CALL THE END WAS THE BILL
COALITION HOPE DISSENTING AND
ARMSTRONG OPPOSE. THIS IS
KINDLED. THANK YOU. NINE THIRTY.
ONE THIRTY ONE THE LINE IS NOW
OPEN. FIND. ONE SIXTY NINE.
HELLO MY NAME IS JOHN GAGE I'M A
LIFE COACH WITH THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION HOPE AND
REDEMPTION CHAIN AND I'M A
STRONG OPPOSITION TO A. B.
SIXTEEN ELDERLY SIXTEEN OH THREE
THANK YOU. WHY AND. SEVENTY
THREE. HELLO MY NAME IS ANTHONY
ROMERO I'M A LIFE COACH FOR THE
WHOLE IN RETENTION TEAM FOR ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB. SIX OH
THREE. HI THIS IS ACTUALLY WITH
PEOPLE CALIFORNIA THE LARGEST
GRASSROOTS BIG BASS ME OR
ANYTHING ARE GOING TO STAY IN
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
LINE. SEVENTY FOUR. SEVENTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. ONE
SEVENTY ONE. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES MY NAME IS DELAYED AND I
LIVE IN LOS ANGELES I AM CALLING
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY
SIXTEEN OKAY THANK YOU. ONE
SEVENTY NINE SH SH SH SH. SH
NINE ONE NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A FINAL CALL
FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO. THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. PRESS ONE
BUTTON ZERO. LINE. EIGHTY THREE.
ONE EIGHTY THREE YOU'RE ONE YES
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS MICHAEL HARVEY ON THE
BIKE ON THE STREET BAPTIST
CHURCH- I LIVE IN RIVERSIDE
CALIFORNIA I AM TRONG.
OPPOSITION A. B. YOU KNOW WHAT.
LINE ONE OH NINE. THE MORNING
HERE MEMBERS MY NAME IS VICTORIA
I LIVE IN ATLANTA AND I'M IN
STRONG OPPOSITION OF AB SIXTEEN
OH THREE. ONE ONE SIXTY ONE. HI
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES HI MIKE HI
MY NAME IS FINDING GREAT HUNT
AND I'M CALLING A STRONG
OPPOSITION A. B. SIXTEEN ALL
THREE ON THE BEHALF OF THE
TRYING TO GET HIS ORGANIZED OF
OFFENDING GAUGE MAKE BETTER
KNOWLEDGE CULT. THANK YOU. NINE
ONE SEVENTY SEVEN. THE MORNING
CARE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
CHRISTOPHER ACOSTA I REPRESENT
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION I'M
STRONG OPPOSITION A. B. SIXTEEN
OH THREE THANK YOU. ONE ONE
EIGHTY ONE. THE MORNING MY NAME
IS LYNN ACOSTA I AM PART OF
AIRSPEEDS HOPE AND REDEMPTION
TEAM AND I AM IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO AB SIXTEEN OH
THREE THANK YOU. LINE SEVENTY
FOUR. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
WILLIE BROWN I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF TIME DONE I'M A STRONG
OPPOSITION TO AB. SIXTEEN OH
THREE. ONE ONE FIFTY FIVE. GOOD
MORNING CHARLIE NUMBERS MY NAME
IS ALSO A STORY I'M A LOT CLOSER
THAN SARASOTA COALITION AND I'M
CALLING IN STRONG OPPOSITION SB
SIX ZERO THREE THANK YOU. FIND.
ONE FORTY SIX. GOOD MORNING YOUR
MEMBERS I'M PART OF THE ENTIRE
STUDENT COALITION HARD TEAM AND
I'M A STRONG OPPOSITION OF MAY
BE FICTIONAL GREAT YOU. WHY.
THIRTY ONE. ONE THIRTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. THE YES.
POSSIBLE EXACTLY BOB SLOAN WHO'S
MISSING OF EIGHT SIX MULTI AFTER
HELLO. THE PUBLIC SAFETY
FORMATION AND OF. EMPIRE ME IT
WAS TO HEAR CAN YOU YOUR PLAY.
ASSEMBLY EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR. SAN
BENITO COUNTY UNION THE MEETING
SAFETY CONSTRUED COMPOSITION IN. SIXTEEN THREE THANK YOU. WE
NOW GOING TO GO TO LAW AND- BUT-
I NUMBER NINETY FIVE IT'S NOT
OPEN FOR ME I GOT THE NUMBER
NINETY FIVE PIECEOPEN NINETY
FIVE FOR ME. I'M SORRY THIS IS
ONE PAN RIGHT NOW DID YOU WANT
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. NO I WANT TO STRONGLY. AB. THIRTEEN OH THREE. A. B. OKAY
I'M FROM TELEPHONE SACRAMENTO MY
NAME IS JEANNIE. THANK YOU. THE
NEW NOW GOIG TO GO TO LINE ONE
EIGHTY TWO. MY NAME IS KERRY
BURKE I AM A HARD COACH FOR THE
HOPE IN RETENTION TEAM WITH ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION AND I'M
CALLING STRONG OPPOSITION A. B.
SIXTEEN OH THREE THANK YOU. FIND
ONE EIGHTY THREE. MY NAME IS
JOHN ONE NOW WITH THE HOPE WITH
HIS TEAM WHAT I ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION I STRONGLY OPPOSE- A.
B. EIGHTEEN OF THIRTY. LINE.
SEVENTY FOUR. ONE SEVENTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. IN A MOVE
ON TO LINE EIGHTY THREE. LINE
EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. MISTER CHAIR THERE IS NO
ONE OUT TO SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH
TO SPEAK. THAT WILL BRING YOU
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. OF FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. MR LUCKY
AT HAND ON A BUTTON SO. YEAH I'M
I'LL BE BRIEF COLIN WAS PRETTY
EXTENDED THEIR SO HIM AND TRY TO
GET TO THE POINT HERE- RETAIL
THEFT IS A REAL PROBLEM LADIES
AND GENTLEMAN AND- THIS IS OUR
THIRD. PROPOSAL TO TRY TO BRING
SOME REMEDY. WHAT WHEN THE
GOVERNOR RECOGNIZES THE RETAIL
THEFT IS A PIVOTAL PROBLEM AND
HIS PROPOSED A SUBSTANTIAL FUNDS
TO ADDRESS THE PROBLEM. WE NEED
TO FIGURE SOMETHING OUT. AND-
I'M HOPING. THAT THIS MEASURE
IMMINENT WON'T BE THE END ALL BE
ALL BUT IT'LL BE A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION AND HAS MY
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. I'LL MAKE A
MOTION APPROVED. IS THERE A
SECOND SHOT. ANY OTHER COMMENTS
. CNN YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR IF I COULD JUST
ADDRESS SOME OF THE POINTS THAT
WERE BROUGHT UP- I KNOW THE PEW
INSTITUTE- REPORT WAS BROUGHT UP
EARLIER BUT I WOULD SAY THAT
EVEN THE BERKELEY REPORT THAT
WAS BROUGHT UP IN YOU KNOW CITY
OF THE UNIVERSITY OF BERKELEY IS
NOT KNOWN AS- ONE OF THE MOST
CONSERVATIVE- REPORT SO WE CAN
GET IN THE STATE BUT EVEN THEY
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE WAS AN
ISSUE. HERE THEY EVEN REPORTED
EVEN FROM THEIR RESPONDENTS
SIXTY FIVE PERCENT- SIGN
INCREASING RETAIL THEFT RIGHT
59% SAID THEY WOULD ACTUALLY
WELCOME A LIMITED- REMEDY TO
THIS ISSUE WHEN YOU LOOK AT YOU
KNOW THE GOVERNOR DOING
SOMETHING LIKE MR LACKEY SAID
ARE YOU LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED TO
THE RITE AID WORKER DOWN IN LOS
ANGELES THAT WAS SHOT AND KILLED
BECAUSE THEY WERE TRYING TO
PREVENT SOMEBODY FROM STEALING
WHEN YOU. AT SAN FRANCISCO THERE
WAS A WOMAN THAT HAD OVER A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SEPARATE
INCIDENCES OF. CRYING BECAUSE
SHE WAS TAKING THINGS FROM A
TARGET THAT ABOUT THE VALUE WENT
OVER FORTY THOUSAND DOLLARS.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT. ANY WHEN YOU
LOOK AT JUST WHAT'S HAPPENING
ACROSS THE ENTIRE STATE AND WHEN
YOU START ASKING PEOPLE. YOU
KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON IN YOUR
STORE WHAT'S HAPPENING AND THEY
SAY LOOK- JUST LIKE WE HAD- THE
TESTIMONY EARLIER IT'S PEOPLE
ARE COMING IN AND JUST DEALING
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THERE'S NO
REAL REPUTATION. RIGHT THAT'S
WHY YOU SEE THE THINGS HAPPENING
AT. AT TARGET THAT'S WHY YOU SEE
THESE THINGS AND WHY YOU HAD ALL
OF THESE CALLS. COMING IN FROM
ALL PARTS OF THE STATE EVERY
REGION OF THE STATE THIS IS A
PROBLEM. WE'RE TRYING TO DO WITH
AB SIXTY NO THREE IS JUST HAVE A
VERY. TARGETED APPROACH A VERY
MEASURED APPROACH TO SAY LOOK WE
NOT ONLY RECOGNISE THIS PROBLEM.
BUT WE WANT TO HELP ADDRESS IT
WHEN I'M TALKING TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT LOCALLY WHEN I'M
TALKING TO THE BUSINESS UNDER.
WHEN I'M TALKING TO CUSTOMERS.
THEY SAY LOOK. IN THE THRESHOLD
WAS LOWER AT FOUR HUNDRED
DOLLARS WE DIDN'T SEE THE
PROBLEMS THAT WE SEE NOW. NOW I
KNOW THAT THERE'S- DEBATE ON.
WHETHER THIS WILL ACTUALLY MAKE
A DIFFERENCE AND WHETHER OTHER
STATES HAVE HIGHER LIMITS IT'S
FINE BUT HERE IN CALIFORNIA IF
YOU JUST TALK TO THE LOCALS. IF
YOU JUST TALK TO OUR BUSINESS
OWNERS THEY WILL TELL YOU. SINCE
THIS CHANGE THIS IS WHAT WE'VE
SEEN IF WE COULD GO BACK AND SAY
LOOK. LET'S GO BACK TO WHAT IT
WAS PRIOR AND HOPEFULLY THAT
HELPS ALLEVIATE THE SITUATION AT
THE END OF THE DAY I WANT TO
JUST MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
PROTECTING CONSUMERS. THAT WE'RE
PROTECTING OUR STORE CLERKS SO
THAT WHAT HAPPENED DOWN IN RITE
AID DOESN'T HAPPEN TO OTHERS-
WINDY YOU LOOK AT THE AMOUNT OF
AGGRAVATED ASSAULTS THAT ARE
HAPPENING TO OUR EMPLOYEES. AT
OUR STORES WE WANT TO TRY TO
HELP ALLEVIATE THAT I BELIEVE
THIS IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT.
RIGHT DIRECTION I JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU AND- IT IS A
PROBLEM IN THE GOVERNOR DID
RECOGNIZE IT I WISH YOU HAD BEEN
. OR AT LEAST YOU HAD
OPPORTUNITY TO LISTEN TO THE-
PUBLIC SAFETY HERE WHEN WE
TALKED ABOUT THE- THE
GOVERNOR'S. BASIC QUARTER
BILLION DOLLARS INVESTMENT IN
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT- WHICH
OBVIOUSLY I WAS VERY EXCITED
ABOUT BECAUSE IT IS BY BILL.
ORGANIZED RETAIL FOR THAT THEN
I'M THE ONE THAT EXTENDED THE
LEAD TO SUNSET. AND ALSO TOOK
OUT SOME PROVISIONS I THOUGHT
WAS HARMFUL- I THINK NOW
HOPEFULLY WE GET IN OUR OFFER
YOU THE SAME IF THIS BILL DOES
NOT MAKE IT OUT HERE. THAT WE
ALL COME TOGETHER IN A
COLLABORATIVE POLICING STRATEGY-
RIGHT NOW IS COMPROMISED AS WITH
ME BASED POLLUTION IF AND WE'RE
REALLY NOT GETTING TO- A
COMPREHENSIVE PROPER CONSERVE
SOLUTION TO THE PROBLEM. WE'RE
ALL GOING TO SIDE ARGUED ABOUT
WHICH ONE IS BETTER. AND SO I
WILL GIVE YOU TO DO THE SAME
OPPORTUNITY THE GOVERNOR HAS
GIVEN US RESOURCES IMPROBABLE
GIVE US MORE. EVEN WHEN SOMEONE
MENTIONED THAT YOU KNOW WE NEED
BATMAN OR WHILE WE WAIT FOR
BATMAN TO COME IN ABOUT BATMAN
IS THE ATTORNEY GENERAL THAT IS
THE IS THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL WE DO HAVE A BATMAN. WHEN
OTHERS DO NOT DO THEIR JOB AND
EXACERBATE THE SITUATION BECAUSE
THEY DON'T LIKE THE LAWS THAT
ARE IN PLACE BECAUSE THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO LAW ENFORCEMENT.
WHERE LAWMAKERS WE MADE THE LAW
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO ENFORCE IT
IS NOT BEING. ENFORCED IN A WAY
THAT WILL REDUCE CRIME AND WE'RE
NOT DOING WHAT WE NEED TO DO
UNDER REHABILITATION SIDE TO
ENSURE THAT WHEN. WHEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT CAPTURE THESE
INDIVIDUALS THEY'RE ABLE TO
FUNNEL THEM INTO RICE RESOURCES
SO THEY DON'T PERCENT OF A- SO
IT IS A COMPREHENSIVE. OF
COLLABORATIVE WHEN I SEE
COLLABORATIVE IS NOT COMP IT'S
NOT IT'S A PARTNERSHIP MR. IT'S
A COLLABORATIVE PARTNERSHIP WITH
POLICE AND COMMUNITY NOT. TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT YOU WILL TAKE
WHAT THE OTHER SIDE WOULD TAKE
AND SO ON. IF THIS BILL DOESN'T
GET OUT WE STILL NEED TO HAVE
FOR A DISCUSSION. ON HOW WE CAN
ACTUALLY FOCUS LIKE A LASER ON
HOW WE CAN IN ORGANIZED RETAIL
THEFT. UP OTHERWISE AS I SAID
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE AND OTHER
COMMITTEES ON THE OTHER PEOPLE
THAT WILL GET TO THE ADVANTAGE
OF THE CRIMINALS. THAT'S WHAT WE
ARE DOING WE'RE ALLOWING THEM TO
CRIMINALS TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
OUR DYSFUNCTION. AND WE NEED TO
STOP THIS DESTRUCTION. WORK
TOGETHER. AND WITH THAT FOR THE
REASONS IT WOULD STATED ABOUT-
YOU REALLY HAVE TO BE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT
LAW ENFORCEMENT WILL GO AFTER TO
FILL THE PRISONS. THAT IS NOT A
SOLUTION THAT IS WHAT LOWERING
THE THRESHER WILL ULTIMATELY DO
IS JUST FILLED THE PRISONS AGAIN
WE'VE ALREADY BEEN TO THREE
STRAIGHT VERY DONE IT BEFORE.
AND IT DIDN'T WORK TO BE A GAY
PEOPLE OF WHO ARE FEARFUL OF
CRIME GAVE HIM A WARM FEELING
THAT THESE PEOPLE WERE
INCARCERATED IN A PRISON
PLANTATION SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE.
BUT IT. GIVE A BLACK BROWN
COMMUNITIES LIKE YOU WOULDN'T
BELIEVE. AND SO WITH THAT
UNFORTUNATELY I'M A RECOMMENDED
NO VOTE BUT I DO WANT TO KEEP
THE DOOR OPEN. DEBT WE COME UP
WITH A COLLABORATIVE
COMPREHENSIVE POLICING STRATEGY
. THANKS FOR THAT INVITATION
MISTER CHAIR AND I APPRECIATE
THAT AND- APPRECIATE YOU HERE IN
THE BUILDING OKAY. I'M AB
SIXTEEN AT THREE BY SOME MEMBERS
SALAS THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER. JONES SAWYER NO
LACKEY LACKEY I BONTA. VOTING
BONTA NOT VOTING BRIAN NOW BRIAN
NO QUIRK. QUIRK KNOWS SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO NOT VOTING SEYARTO ZERO
TWO I. THE MEASURE FAILS. THANK
YOU. NOW WE HAVE. MISTER GIBSON
BURST IN FILE ORDER. THEY'RE
ACTING IN MAIENSCHEIN BUT IF
CHEN DOESN'T SHOW MAIENSCHEIN IS
NEXT YES. P. ITEM NUMBER FOUR
GIPSON- AB NINETEEN TWENTY FOUR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN TWENTY
FOUR WHICH SEEKS TO REDUCE
BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT BUT THOSE
WHO WERE ON I WANT TO UNDERSCORE
WORK ON PROBATION ALTHOUGH THEY
WERE CONVICTED OF A LESS SERIOUS
CRIME. THIS IS A GROUP OF PEOPLE
. THAT FACE MORE BARRIERS THAN
THOSE WHO SERVED PRISON
SENTENCING. I'VE COME ACROSS
MANY INDIVIDUALS IN MY DISTRICT
. WHO WERE ON PROBATION. THEY
MADE A MISTAKE MEMBERS THEY PAID
THEIR DEBT TO SOCIETY. AND SINCE
THEN THEY HAVE HAD TO FACE.
OBSTACLES ROAD BLOCKS JUST TO
GET BACK ON THEIR FEET. THE
NAVIC AND NAVIGATING THEN THE TO
THE NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES OF
THESE BARRIERS. YES FELT BEYOND
THE INDIVIDUAL AFFECT THESE ARE
FOLKS WHO ARE NOT. STRUGGLING
WHO ARE NOW STRUGGLING. TO MAKE
ENDS MEET FOR THEIR FAMILIES. DO
YOU KNOW WHAT IT FEELS LIKE.
BEING ABLE NOT TO TAKE CARE OF
YOUR FAMILY. BEING LESS THAN A
MAN A WOMAN. BUILDING JUST LAST
DAM. HAVING HAVING TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN FEEDING YOURSELF OR
FEEDING YOUR BABY. THIS IS THE
REALITY THAT MANY OF MY DISTRICT
AND THOSE ACROSS CALIFORNIA FACE
EACH AND EVERY DAY. OURS AND OUR
SOCIETY HAS REFUSED TO FORGIVE
THEM. HAVING MADE A MISTAKE. AND
JUST NEED SOMEBODY TO FORGIVE
THEM JUST SO THAT THEY CAN WRITE
A NEW NARRATIVE FOR THE LIVES
MOVING FORWARD. WHEN SOMEONE IS
DENIED A SECOND CHANCE TO
PROVIDE FOR HIS OR HER FAMILY.
THE ENTIRE COMMUNITY THERE'S A
SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC IMPACT A
CRIMINAL RECORD SHOULD NOT BE A
LIFE SENTENCE FOR UNEMPLOYMENT.
AND POVERTY. THIS MEASURE NOT
ONLY BRINGS US A STEP CLOSER TO
GIVING THOSE WHO HAVE PAID THEIR
DEBT TO SOCIETY A FAIR SHOT TO
REBUILD THEIR LIVES. BUT IT IS
ALSO A TESTAMENT. TO WHAT WE
BELIEVE REHABILITATION SHOULD BE
AND LOOK LIKE IN THIS STATE.
THIS BILL WOULD STREAMLINED
APPLICATION PROCESS TOWARDS
OBTAINING A CERTIFICATE OF
REHABILITATION. HEY CERTIFICATE
OF REHABILITATION ALLOWS THE
COURT TO FIND A PERSON THAT HAS
BEEN REHABILITATED. CURRENTLY IT
IS HARD FOR THOSE CONVICTED OF A
LESSER OF SERIOUS OFFENSE TO
OBTAIN A CERTIFICATE THEN THOSE
WHO ACTUALLY SERVED PRISON IN
THIS STATE. I SCRATCH MY HEAD
BECAUSE THIS DOESN'T MAKE SENSE
TO ME. LET ME BE CLEAR
CERTIFICATE OF REHABILITATION
DOES NOT STEAL. OR X. BONDS A
CONVICTION. RECORD OR RESTORE
CIVIL RIGHTS BUT IT CAN IMPROVE
A PERSON'S CHANCE OF BEING
GRANTED AN OCCUPATIONAL LICENSE
. WE'RE TALKING ABOUT GETTING
BACK TO WORK. PUTTING PEOPLE
BACK TO WORK WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
FOLKS WHO HAVE PAID THEIR DEBT
TO SOCIETY AND NEED TO FIND A
JOB TO KEEP A ROOF OVER THEIR
HEADS. BOOT ON THE TABLE. AND
SUPPORT THEIR FAMILIES. PEOPLE
EXCLUDED FROM EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES ARE MORE LIKELY TO
FALL INTO A CYCLE OF CRIME. WE
CAN CHANGE THIS. WE CAN STOP THE
CYCLE WE CAN DO IT TODAY.
MEMBERS OUR FOCUS SHOULD BE
TOWARDS SUPPORTING THE
REHABILITATION PROCESS AND
ENCOURAGING PEOPLE TO GET BACK
INTO THE WORK FORCE AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE IT IS OUR JOB TO
HELP THOSE PEOPLE MOVE FORWARD
AND WRITE A NEW NARRATIVE. IT IS
TIME TO PUT JUSTICE
REHABILITATION AND REDEMPTION.
AT THE CENTER OF CRIMINAL
JUSTICE. SYSTEM IN THIS STATE.
AB NINETEEN TWENTY FOUR IS A
COMMON SENSE MEASURE THAT WILL
SERVE AS A TOOL TO PROVIDE A
BETTER OPPORTUNITY. FOR PEOPLE
LIVING WITH ALL RECORDS AND
READY TO GET BACK TO WORK. AND
GET THE PEACE OF AMERICAN DREAM
JOINING ME TO PROVIDE SUPPORTING
TESTIMONIES WHICH TO GILBERT AND
MRS KIRBY FROM THE CALIFORNIA
SAFETY AND JUSTICE. JOHN. YOU
MAYBE GET. CALLING BY PHONE. THE
BILL SECOND IS GO BURDEN. MISTER
GILBERT MISS HOLLY. KIRBY YES WE
CAN HEAR YOU PAY YOUR RENT. I'LL
CHECK BACK IN THE MORNING JANET
CAN BE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
GILBERT JOHNSON I'M THE
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE THANK Y. TIME DONE
MANAGER. I'LL BE READING TODAY'S
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF AB
NINETEEN TWENTY FOUR ON BEHALF
OF ONE OF OUR TIME DONE MEMBERS
WERE NECK OF BAITING. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS WHEN
ACTIVATING AND I AM THE
PRESIDENT AND FOUNDER OF
COMMUNITY REFLECTIONS AND
LOCATED IN SOUTH LOS ANGELES.
COMMUNITY REFLECTIONS WORKS TO
ADDRESS THE IMMEDIATE NEEDS OF
FAMILIES AND INDIVIDUALS AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES OF
WESTMONT AND WESPAC. I'LL BE
SPEAKING ABOUT THE DIFFICULTY OF
OBTAINING MY CERTIFICATE OF
REHABILITATION AND WHILE I
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT
LEGISLATION THAT WILL MAKE IT
MORE ACCESSIBLE FOR PEOPLE TO
RECEIVE A CERTIFICATE OF
REHABILITATION. FIRST OFF I'M
SIXTY FIVE YEARS OLD AND I'VE
BEEN IN THE SYSTEM SINCE A
TEENAGER I GREW UP IN DEEP
POVERTY AND A VERY DEPRESSING
TIMES WHERE LOW PERFORMING
SCHOOLS DRUGS. THE
INDUSTRIALIZED NATION AND POLICE
VIOLENCE PUTS MANY OF MY PEERS
AND ME INTO CRIMINAL ACTIVITY I
STILL HAD TO TAKE FULL
RESPONSIBILITY FOR MY ACTIONS
AND HOLD MYSELF ACCOUNTABLE. YET
IT WAS VERY CHALLENGING TO
BECOME A PRODUCTIVE CITIZEN DUE
TO THE CONVICTIONS AND MANY
RESTRICTIONS PLACED ON ME BY THE
SYSTEM. WHEN I LEARNED ABOUT
OPPORTUNITIES TO MOVE FOR WITH
MY LIFE AND WITH GOES OUT HALF
THE MANY YEARS SUCH AS BEING A
PUBLIC SERVANT AND A SUCCESSFUL
ENTREPRENEUR I WOULD HIGHLY
EXCITED AND DETERMINED AT THE
SAME TIME. ONE OF THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES TOWARDS FREEDOM
WAS. A CERTIFICATE OF
REHABILITATION. WELL IT TOOK ME
TO YEARS TO RECEIVE MONSTER TO
REHABILITATE. I STAYED THE
COURSE AND LEARN HOW TO FILE MY
PAPERWORK DO A LOT OF TRIAL AND
ERROR. PEOPLE WHO COME TO MY
COMMUNITY INTAKE CENTER SEEKING
HELP WITH CERTIFICATES OF
REHABILITATION AND OTHER LEGAL
ASSISTANCE HAVE MENTIONED THAT
THE LOWER YOUR FEES CAN BE
HIGHLY EXPENSIVE. I HAD TO DRIVE
BACK AND FORTH TO THE COURTS
BECAUSE I HAD SO MANY
CONVICTIONS. IN WITH GAS PRICES
BEING SO RIDICULOUSLY HIGH I
IMAGINE THIS WILL CREATE HUGE
BARGAINS ALL UNEMPLOYED PEOPLE
OR THOSE IN NEED OF FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE. WHEN I TOLD MY STORY
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION STAFF ABOUT WHY I
FEEL I DESERVE TO BE
REHABILITATED. I CRIED BECAUSE
OF A LOT OF THE A LOT OF THE
TRAUMA RESTART THIS AND BROUGHT
UP- EMOTIONS IT WAS A LOT OF
PRESSURE TO GET ALL OF THE FORMS
FILLED OUT CORRECTLY. AND WHEN
HE CAME TO MY DATE TO GO BEFORE
THE JUDGE I WAS PANICKING
ANXIOUS AND TRIGGER BECAUSE THE
MY PTSD FROM PRESIDENT AND JUST
GROWING UP IN SOUTH CENTRAL
ROLE. THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS I
HAD TO DO A LOT OF LEG WORK TO
GET SUPPORT AND CHARACTER
REFERENCE LETTERS FROM
INDIVIDUALS AND ORGANIZATIONS
THAT I WORK WITH SINCE MY
CORPORATION. I BEGAN THE PROCESS
AND EARLY TWENTY NINETEEN AND
FINALLY RECEIVED MY CERTIFICATE
OF REHABILITATION. IN MAY OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND- ROSS THIS
IS A VERY STRESSED IN. YEAH
AFTER LIKE A HUGE WEIGHT HAS
BEEN LIFTED OFF OF MY BACK. I
WORK WITH A LOT OF FORMERLY
INCARCERATED PEOPLE IN MY
COMMUNITY AND FOR THEM TO SEE
THAT I CANRECEIVE MY
CERTIFICATE OF REHABILITATION.
AND MOVE FORWARD IN LIFE THEY
CAN DO IT TOO WILL BE PLACED ON
THE SUCCESSFUL SUCCESSFUL BACK.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU NOW WILL BRING AN END TO
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM THERE ARE
. IN SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING SURE
MEMBERS A LITTLE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE PROP CO SPONSOR IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. YEAH
GOOD MORNING GLENN BACKUS FOR
ELEVATOR CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. MARCO
GEORGIA MY HALF THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ESPINAS WITH ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION IN SUPPORT THANK. YOU. NO GO TO THE PHONE LINES
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. YOU WHICH
CHAIR FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO FIRST ONE ZERO.
WE'LL GO TO LINE SIX. THE
MORNING CARE NUMBERS ANTHONY
DIMARTINO BEHALF OF TIME DONE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. BY ONE TWENTY
NINE. GOOD MORNING DERAILMENT
COLLISION LOS ANGELES STRONG
SUPPORT. LINE EIGHTY TWO.
HUNDRED GARCIA CONDOMINIUM ON
BEHALF OF THE COMPANY YOU KNOW
FREEDOM ALL I'M PROJECT I'M NOT
IN SHOCK THE PORT THANK YOU. BY
ONE NOTE. AND ONE OF TO YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. FIND ONE
NINETY SIX. ONE ONE NINET SIX
ZERO ONE PARDON ME GOING TO GO
TO LINE ONE TWENTY ONE. FIND ONE
TWENTY WHAT ONE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. GOOD MORNING. FASTER
CHANTELLE YEAH I HAVE AGREED TO
PROVIDE THE SOCIALLY OF
CALIFORNIA CALLING IN SUPPORT.
LINE SEVEN ONE. THE MORNING SHOW
I'M NOT SURE WHERE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS THE LASER AND I LIVE IN
LOS ANGELES I AM CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT A. B. NINETEEN
TWO FOUR. ONE SEVENTY FOUR.
SEVENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. NOBODY MADE A MOVIE BROWN
TIME DONE ON SUPPORT. THIS BILL
. ONE ONE NINETY FIVE. HI MY
NAME IS MARGARET DON'T COMMENT
FROM LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN IN
OAKLAND CALLING IN IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN TWENTY
FOUR THANK YOU. FIND ONE SEVENTY
FOUR. HI GOOD MORNING THIS IS
GREGORY CANNELLA BEHALF OF
INITIATE JUSTICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. FIND. ONE
SIXTY SIX. FIND ONE SIXTY SIX OR
ONE IS NOW OPEN. WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO LINE ONE SIXTY FIVE.
BY ONE SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. BUT A MOVE ON TO LIGHT
NINETY FIVE. RIGHT HELLO. YES
SIR YOU'RE WIDE OPEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. CAN YOU HEAR ME MY NAME
IS TERRENCE STEWART AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF HER FINE
DINING IN A BOX HISTORICAL CORE
DID MANAGE. THANK YOU. NINE
EIGHTY THREE. LINE EIGHTY THREE
YEAR ONE IS NOW OPEN. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON COMBINED ONE
NINETY NINE. GOOD MORNING MY
MEMBERS WOULD BE MADE UP THE- MY
CALDERON AND REGION GORLICE
HARDLY DEFICIENT. AND GOING
SUPPORT THE. TWENTY FOUR. BURKE
USE. WHY **** Q. HOW. GOOD
MORNING CHEN MEMBERS MY NAME
MYRON FROM LONG SHALL I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT TO
NINETEEN TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU.
LINE ONE SEVENTY SIX. HELLO. YES
SIR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OKAY
MULLIN BUT DIRECTLY I LIVE IN
SAN DIEGO I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
LIKE I'M GONNA GET MY SHOULDER
TRONG. AB ONE TRICK. AND A FINAL
CALL FOR AN WHO WAS TO SEE AND
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. FIND ONE
NINETY EIGHT. GOOD MORNING THIS
IS JOHN WEINBERG- BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT AND
ALSO CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. LINE ONE SIXTY SIX.
THE ONE SIXTY SIX OF ONE NOW
OPEN. FIND ONE OH TWO. HELLO MY
NAME IS KATHERINE VON ONLINE
CONSCIOUS WRONG IF THE COURT AB
NINETEEN TWENTY FOUR ON BEHALF
OF SHIPS REFORM. ONE ONE SIXTY
FIVE. AND ONE SIXTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. LINE THIRTY
FIVE. THANKS THIRTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. PINE EIGHTY
FOR A. STE STE ONE EIGHTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. WELL THIS
YES SIR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH
YES SIR. MY NAME IS MICHAEL
HARDY IN THE PATH OF THE BY
PROVISIONAL BAPTIST TERM SUPPORT
OF AB NINETEEN TWENTY PORTS
THANK THIS. THANK YOU ONE EIGHTY
THREE IT'S. SURE THERE IS NO ONE
ELSE TO SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK THANK YOU ARE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO IT A.
B. NINETEEN TWENTY FOUR IN THERE
IN THE ROOM. HIM STONE STONE
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION AND RESPECTFUL
POSITION. THANK YOU OR ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. OKAY
WE'LL GO TO PHONE LINES TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. MISTER CHAIRED APPEARS
THERE IS NO ONE IS SIGNALED THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK THANK YOU
BRING BACK TO COMMITTEE ANY.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FOR MR BONTA
DID MISTER BRYANT. NO OKAY. NO
THE BILL. THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD HAPPY TO SUPPORT IN
AND- THANK YOU TO THE WITNESSES
SPOKEN SUPPORTERS ESPECIALLY MY
BY THE GIVER JOHNSON. MOTION
MOST OF THE BILL. OVERHEATED
OKAY I'M I'M LATE SECOND THIRD
CORRECT- NO OTHER COMMENTS YOU
MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS I WANT
TO THANK THOSE WHO CAME WHO
SPOKE VERBALLY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL- APPRECIATED MR JOHNSON AND
ALSO- WINNETKA STORY CERTAINLY
HOPEFULLY THAT PEOPLE WILL
LISTENING TO- THE HEARTFELT-
ISSUES THAT- THAT HE HAD TO GO
THROUGH- AND THIS IS ABOUT AGAIN
REALLY REDEMPTION- WE NEED TO DO
BETTER. IF WE AS CALIFORNIANS
BELIEVE IN A PERSON'S ABILITY.
TO REHABILITATE THEMSELVES AND
RETURNED TO THE COMMUNITY WE CAN
NOT CONTINUE TO BE BUILT BLOCKS.
OF BARRIERS TO THESE
OPPORTUNITIES- I'M REMINDED OF A
SONG- BY DONNA KIRKLAND WE FALL
DOWN WE GET BACK UP. THIS IS THE
TIME TO HELP THOSE WHO FALLING
DOWN GET BACK UP. IT'S TIME TO
APPLY WHAT I BELIEVE THAT I LIVE
BY EACH AND EVERY DAY IT'S CALL
GRACE AND MERCY WOULD YOU PLEASE
GIVE THOSE WHO WANT. AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GET BACK UP AGAIN
THE GRACE AND MERCY THEY NEED TO
MOVE FORWARD IN THIS STATE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RELIABLE. THANK
YOU TEARS RECOMMENDING I'D
CALDERON. ON AB NINETEEN TWENTY
FOUR BY SEVEN MEMBER GIPSON THE
MISSION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER GENSER IRAQI. BONTA BONTA
I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I SEE YOUR
TOTAL. THE MEASURE PASSES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH COMMITTEE. MR
MAIENSCHEIN. YOU CAN GO NOW
OCTOBER SITTING TO WAIT YOU'RE
HERE WE'RE GOING DO YOU FOR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS MY
BUDGET GETS MESSED UP IT'S ON
YOU. BOB HAULAGE EISEN IN. I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I WANT TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS AS
PROPOSED IN THE ANALYSIS THE
CALIFORNIA PENAL CODE TRAITS
ALMOST ALL RESTRAINING ORDER
VIOLATIONS AS MISDEMEANORS
ALARMINGLY VIOLATIONS INVOLVING
UNLAWFUL ENTRY INTO THE VICTIM'S
HOME CARRY THE SAME PENALTIES AS
VIOLATIONS OCCURRING VIA TAX TO
SOCIAL MEDIA AND PHONE AND
UNLAWFUL ENTRY INTO THE VICTIM'S
HOME IS INTRUSIVE AND DANGEROUS
PARTICULARLY IN CASES OF
INTIMATE PARTNER VIOLENCE. AB
TWENTY FORTY WILL ALIGN THE
PENALTY FOR FORCIBLY ENTERING
INTO THE VICTIM'S HOME TO THAT
OF VIOLATIONS THAT RESULT IN
INJURY OF THE PROTECTED PARTY.
THIS BILL WILL PUNISH PROTECTIVE
ORDER VIOLATIONS WITH EITHER A
TWO THOUSAND DOLLAR FINE. FOR
THIRTY DAYS IMPRISONMENT IN A
COUNTY JAIL. THIS BILL WILL GIVE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE VICTIMS A
SENSE OF SECURITY IN KNOWING
THAT THEIR HOUSEHOLD AND FAMILY
ARE FURTHER PROTECTED FROM THEIR
ABUSER. WITH ME ON THE LINE I
HAVE REBEKAH ZIP ON BEHALF OF
THE SAN DIEGO CITY ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE. WHEN EVERY YEAR THANK
YOU. GO AHEAD THANK ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I REBEKAH
THAT THE CHIEF OF THE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND SEX CRIMES UNIT IN
THE SAN DIEGO CITY ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE APPEARING VIA TELEPHONE
ON BEHALF OF SAN DIEGO CITY
ATTORNEY MARA ELLIOTT. I WORK
WITH VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE WHO HAVE OBTAINED
PROTECTIVE ORDERS AGAINST THEIR
ABUSERS A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
VICTIM MAY RETURN HOME ONLY TO
DISCOVER THAT HER ABUSER HAS
BEEN IN THE HOUSE THAT HE HAD
PERHAPS RANSACKED IT OR WORSE IS
STILL THERE IN HER HOME
VIOLATING HER SENSE OF SAFETY
AND WHAT SHOULD BE A SANCTUARY
OFTEN IN VIOLATION OF A VALID
SERVED PROTECTIVE ORDER FROM A
FAMILY COURT. THIS INVASION OF
PERSONAL SAFETY AND PRIVACY
CREATES A SPECIAL TYPE OF TERROR
. USERS CAN OBTAIN INFORMATION
ABOUT THEIR VICTIMS THAT ALLOW
THEM TO TRACK THE VICTIM
INCLUDING THE VICTIM'S SCHEDULE
AND INFORMATION ABOUT THE
VICTIMS FIFTY PLAN. I PERSONALLY
SEEN DOZENS OF CASES WHERE AN
ABUSER ENTERED THE VICTIM'S HOME
AND FLAGRANT DISREGARD. OF A
PROTECTIVE ORDER. ONE VICTIM
HOME ALONE WITH HER THREE SMALL
CHILDREN COWERED IN A BEDROOM
WHILE HER ABUSER BROKE THROUGH
HER FRONT DOOR WITH A CROWBAR.
ANOTHER PERSON CAME HOME TO FIND
THEIR ABUSER BURNING HER
PERSONAL PROPERTY ON THE STOVE.
AB TWENTY FORTY AS A MANDATORY
MODERATE CUSTODIAL SANCTIONS
THAT WILL DETER ABUSERS. ALLOW
VICTIMS TIME TO REGROUP CHANGE
LOCKS POR MOVED TO PROTECT THEM
FROM DANGER. CURRENT LAW DOES
NOT OFFER VICTIMS SUFFICIENT
PROTECTION FROM THIS TYPE OF
VIOLATION. AB TWENTY FORTY WILL
ALSO AID JUDGES BY FLAGGING
ELEVATED PROTECTIVE ORDER
VIOLATION SO THAT THE
INFORMATION CAN BE CONSIDERED
AND BAIL AND SENTENCING
DECISIONS. AND I'M AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE THANK YOU FOR THE TIME.
THANK YOU WITNESS ARE YOU HAVE
ANOTHER PRIMARY WITNESS- NOW SO
WILL NOW OPEN UP- IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE- WHAT ENSUED LIKE
TO AND IT LOOKS LIKE WE DO WHICH
IS STONE. STE KIM STONE STONE
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. LUCIA MUCH THERE ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO TO THE
PHONES FOR THOSE IN SUPPORT.
ADMINISTRATING INTO EIGHT. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR THOSE WHO
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. WE'RE GONNA GO
TO LINE FORTY EIGHT. ONE SHERMAN
WAS ONE CHANNEL THE RESEARCHERS
OF FICTION AND THE P. AIDS FOUR
KEY CLAREMONT. OVER CITY
PORTANTINO WOULD ALWAYS NEWPORT
BEACH HOUSE POMONA WILL FAMILY
AND- UPLAND AND PLUS YOU GET
SHIPS THE SHOW ON COURT THANK
YOU. THAT WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
WHO SIGNAL THE THEY WISH SPEAK.
THANK YOU- DO WE HAVE PRICE.
WITH ENOUGH. IF THEY'RE HERE- DO
YOU HAVE A PRIMARY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE MISTER
EIGHTEEN T. NOW. OKAY SO THEN
WE'LL JUST YEAR- ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE- FROM
EIGHTEEN T. FOR THOSE OF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE. YOUR CHAIR NO ONE TO
SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH TO SPEAK.
YOU TO HAVE A POPULAR BILL MR
MAIENSCHEIN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR- MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
ANY COMMENTS MISTER SEA ACTOR
JUST TO MAKE A MOTION TO APPROVE
THE BILL OKAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU- WELL. LET'S SEE YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
MISTER CHAIR PROPITIATE THE WORK
OF THE COMMITTEE THE CHAIR
SUPPORT AND RESPECT I THINK THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT'S YOU KNOW
NECESSARY AND PROVIDES- A LEVEL
OF RELIEF AND CERTAINTY TO
VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE. YES AND ONE OF THE
REASONS I LIKE IT AND PERHAPS
ONE OF THE REASONS THE CHAIR
LECTURE BELL. IS I THINK THE-
PENALTY IS APPROPRIATE THIRTY
DAYS IN JAIL IS A- ORDER OR TWO
THOUSAND DOLLAR FINE IS FOR MOST
PEOPLE A PRETTY. SEVERE
CONSEQUENCE. ARE WITHOUT GOING
OVERBOARD AND FOR THAT REASON
I'LL BE SUPPORTING IT AND SO
DOES THE CHAIR. I WILL GIVE THE
GAVEL OVER TO THE CHAIR. ARE WE
AT MEMBER COMMENTS VIDEO YEP-
RECOMMENDED I BOOKED. YES AND AB
TWENTY FORTY BY A SEVEN MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER IRAQI
BLACKIE I BONTA BONTA HI BRIAN
BRIAN I WORK I WORK AT A SAN
DIEGO SAN DIEGO I ARE OUT. THERE
TOO I. THAT MEASURE PRESS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS. WE NOW HAVE A ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN AND. TWELVE- AB
TWENTY THIRTY THREE SMITH AND AB
TWENTY THREE THIRTY THREE SMITH. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
TODAY I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB TWO
ZERO THREE THREE. CURRENTLY
CALIFORNIA'S CONCEAL CARRY
WEAPONS CCW PERMITS ARE VALID
FOR TWO YEARS OR UP TO FOUR
YEARS DEPENDING ON THE
OCCUPATION OF THE APPLICANT.
AFTER WHICH IT MAY BE RENEWED.
AB TWO ZERO THREE THREE WHAT
EXTEND THE POSSIBLE POSSIBLE
POSSESSION AND USE OF A CCW
PERMIT FROM TWO YEARS UP TO FIVE
YEARS. CURRENT LAWS BURDENSOME
FOR CCW HOLDERS WHO COME IN FOR
A RENEWAL EVERY TWO YEARS
KNOWING FULL WELL THAT THE
PERMIT WILL BE RENEWED. IN
ADDITION TO SAVING RENEWAL COST
FOR CCW HOLDERS. AB TWENTY
THIRTY THREE WOULD REDUCE
ADMINISTRATIVE WORKLOAD FOR
SHERIFFS AND POLICE CHIEFS
SAVING THE MONEY AND TIME. I
WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT THIS BILL
DOES NOT MAKE IT EASIER TO GET A
CCW LICENSE. NOR DOES IT
GUARANTEE THE PERMIT WILL LAST
FOR FIVE YEARS. AB TWENTY THIRTY
THREE. RETAINS THAT CCW
APPLICANTS MUST STILL SHOW GOOD
MORAL CHARACTER. HAVE GOOD CAUSE
A COMPLETE THE NECESSARY
REQUIREMENTS ADDITIONALLY CCW IS
CAN STILL BE CANCELED. WHEN THE
ISSUE OUR BELIEF THAT THE
APPROPRIATE. PROPRIA BASED ON
MISCONDUCT BY THE HOLDER. THIS
BILL REDUCE COSTS FOR BOTH
RESPONSIBLE PERMIT HOLDERS AND
THE DEPARTMENTS BY KEEPING ALL
THE SAFEGUARDS SURROUNDING THE
CCW PERMIT PROCESS FOR THOSE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
LINE VOTE. THANK YOU AND I
BELIEVE YOU HAVE TO WITNESSES BY
TELEPHONE- ROY GRIFFIN- LEISURE
RIGHT TO SEE RPA AND LIEUTENANT
BRIAN. BIG RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
DEPUTY. MAY OPEN UP LINE
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATORS FOR BOTH
THOSE WITNESSES. YOU BOTH HAVE
FIVE MINUTES TOTAL. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS ARE A GROUP
OF LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION HERE TO TESTIFY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY THIRTY THREE AB TWENTY
SURGERIES OR SHARE SOME POLICE
CHIEFS THE OPTION DO WHAT'S BEST
FOR THEIR COMMUNITIES GIVEN THE
DIMINISH THE LEADERS THIS OPTION
WILL RESULT IN A HUGE SAVINGS TO
COMMUNITIES DROP CALIFORNIA OR
RESTRUCTURED MEETING BIG
MANDATES. WITH LIMITED STAFF AND
BUDGET THIS ALSO TRANSLATES INTO
HUGE SAVINGS OF TIME AND MONEY
FOR OUR CONCEALED CARRY PERMIT
HOLDERS. THE RENEWAL PROCESS IS
TIME CONSUMING TROUBLESOME AND
COSTLY EXTENDING THIS PROCESS TO
REACH FIVE YEARS THE CITY TWO
YEARS WE'LL BIG SAVINGS. I WOULD
LIKE TO EMPHASIZE THESE ARE NOT
YOUR EVERYDAY GUN OWNERS.
INDIVIDUALS WERE THE BEST OF THE
BEST. THEY HAVE PROVEN THEIR
NEED TO THE COMMUNITY. AND ALL
THE LEADERS THAT HAVE- THAT
ENDEAVOR TO WOULD YOUR CAN SAFE
. DAVID ADDITIONAL TRAIN JUMPED
MANY WHO TO OBTAIN THIS PUMP.
THEY MAY STAFF UP BY THE
JURISDICTIONS IN STRICKEN WITH
THE LAW. THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE
AND ASSOCIATION WORKED CLOSELY
WITH SOLANO COUNTY SHERIFF'S
INSURANCE FORMS FROM THE STATE
LAST YEAR'S PROVIDE TRAINING TO
ASSIST ENERGIZING CCW PROCESS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
CONFERENCES A PROVIDED A HUGE
STEP FORWARD AND STATEWIDE
PERMIT CONSISTENCY AB TWENTY
THIRTY THREE WOULD BE A NOTHER
BIG STEP IN THIS DIRECTION.
MEMBERS I STRONGLY ENCOURAGE YOU
TO VOTE YES ON THIS MUCH NEEDED
WELL THOUGHT OUT AND COMMONSENSE. LEGISLATION THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME.
LET ME MISTER CHAIR WHAT WAS THE
NAME OF THE OTHER ROW WITNESS.
YEAH RIVERSIDE AND PARDON ME
JUST A MOMENT JUST A MOMENT
PLACE. MISTER VERY DO YOU HAVE
BEEN JOINED TO THE MAIN
CONFERENCE AND YOU'VE BEEN ASKED
TO SPEAK. GOOD MORNING.
AS YOU MIGHT ALREADY GO YES ARE
YOU CERTAINLY ARE PLEASE PROCEED
UGH. GOOD MORNING I HOPE THE
VENUE I'M HERE TO CORRECT ONE
I'M- JUST BECAUSE TO BE
HONORABLE- PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE- MEMBERS OF THAT
COMMITTEE CONNABLE CHAT IS
CORRECT THAT IS CORRECT MR VAGUE
YOU ARE ON THE LINE. OKAY MY
NAME IS BRIAN BIG I'M LIEUTENANT
BRUCE HERE OUR MEN. UNDER YOUR
CHAD BIANCO AND I CURRENTLY HAVE
BEEN MANAGING HIS- CARRY
CONCEALED WEAPONS UNIT. SINCE
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN. AND I'M
HERE TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH- BILL A.
B. TWENTY THIRTY THREE. AND I'M
ON THAT BILL- REPRESENTING
CHURCH AYE BIANCO WE'D LIKE TO-
SHOW SUPPORT ON THAT BILL- YOU
ARE. EXPLAINS FURTHER IS NOT
JUST THOUSAND NINETEEN MANAGING
. PROBABLY ONE OF THE LARGEST
CCW UNITS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- YOU SPENDING THE
PERMIT FROM TWO THREE TO FOUR
YEAR. CYCLE TO A FIVE YEAR WAIT.
BE EXTREMELY HELPFUL IN TERMS OF
OUR STAFFING LEVELS- IT'LL SAVE
US. SOME OUT OF PAPERWORK
PROCESSING- THAT WE DO- EVERY
TWO YEARS EXPECTING FOR THE
STANDARD FORGET. IN THAT SENSE.
IT ALSO SAFETY- APPLICATION-
THAT TIME IF YOU YEARS TO RENEW
THEIR PERMITS. AS WELL AS- FOR
THE MOST PART OF IT IT'S SORT OF
A REDUNDANT CYCLE WITH THE
MAJORITY OF APPLICANTS THE FIRST
TIME THAT THEY RECEIVED THEIR
PERMIT. FOR THE LAWFUL
REQUIREMENTS GOOD BECAUSE GOOD
MORAL CHARACTER- THAT PERCENTAGE
THAT INFORMATION DOESN'T CHANGE
VERY RARELY IN THE TWO YEAR
CYCLE- AND ALSO AS FAR AS COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH STATE THEM COST
- IN TWO YEARS I THINK WE
AVERAGE. ABOUT 95% RENEWAL RATE
MARKET IS BEING HOW OVERALL
TOTAL OF. MS OUR PARTY CURRENT
PERMIT HOLDERS THAT MAKES.
I AM PARDON ME MR CHERRY JUST
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT THE
MICROPHONE THAT YOUR AD IS
BARELY AUDIBLE OVER THE
CONFERENCE I'M SORRY DID I HEAD
OFFSO- IT ARE YOU DONE. MISTER
BIG- YES SIR IS THERE ANY
QUESTION- YOU FOLKS DIDN'T
HAPPEN TO ME OR ANY QUESTIONS I
CAN ANSWER FOR YOU. NOT YET JUST
HOLD ON WE'RE NOT GOING TO BRING
IT BACK TO ROME ON. AND HAVE
WITNESSES THERE IN THE ROOM AND
SUPPORT. MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
RESOLUTION MUTCHLER ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. SEE INACCURATE NOW GO
TO THE PHONE LINES RT ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. OF AB
TWENTY THIRTY THREE. FOR THOSE
WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WHEN YOU GO TO LINE TWO OH
EIGHT. HI YES MY NAME IS STEVE
RODDA I'M WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RIFLE AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION AND
THE NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION
AND THE U. S. NAVY VETERAN AND I
STRONGLY URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
APPROVE A. B. TWO ZERO THREE
THREE. THANK YOU. LINE. FORTY
EIGHT. FIVE FORTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. WE'RE GONNA GO
TO LINE TWO OH ONE. GOOD MORNING
JAMES FRAZIER VENTURA COUNTY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
THIRTY THREE. LYING TO TWENTY.
HI GOOD MORNING- MY NAME IS
DARREN BUT WELL I AM A FEW W.
OLDER PERMIT HOLDER- MEMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THIRTY
THREE THANK YOU. LINE TWENTY
THREE. MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE DAN
READ WHAT'S YOUR REGIONAL
DIRECTOR OF THE NATIONAL RIFLE
ASSOCIATION ALSO YOU'RE GONNA
USE OF CALIFORNIANS STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS LEGISLATION.
FIND TO SIXTEEN. IS IT ME YES
YES SIR. YEAH MY NAME IS JACK
MARSHALL I'M AN ARMY VETERAN. I
AM A- CALIFORNIA RIFLE PISTOL
ASSOCIATION MEMBER RANGE UP SURE
. I AM ALSO A NRA MEMBER AND I
AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWO
ZERO THREE THREE. THANK YOU BYE
LINE TWO SEVEN PAYING. YES MY
NAME IS SANTA CLARA I'M A MEMBER
OF THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND
PISTOL ASSOCIATION I'M A MOTHER
OF THREE MOTHER IN LAW THAN
AFGHANISTAN MARINE VETERAN AND I
AM STRONGLY IN FAVOR OF THIS
LEGISLATION. THANK YOU. BLIND
BLIND. BY TO TWENTY THREE ON ME
JUST A MOMENT. TWENTY TWENTY
THREE OH ONE IS NOW OPEN. HI
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS TOM
EISENSTAEDT I AM A PRIVATE
CITIZEN AND I AM STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF BILL TWO ZERO THREE
THREE AND APPRECIATE YOU VOTING
ON IT YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU. ONE FORTY. OKAY SURE
DISTEMPER COMMAND ON THE CHAIR
OF THE SOUTH SACRAMENTO CHAPTER
OF THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND
PISTOL ASSOCIATION. IN IN A
REMEMBER- IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL RESPECTIVE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT YOU US
IN THIS BUILDING FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR. ONE TWO NINE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS PAT
HURTIN I AM A LIFE MEMBER OF THE
NRA I AM A LIFE MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION I'M THE CHAIRMAN OF
THE TO HIM A COUNTY GUN OWNERS
WHICH IS A CHAPTER OF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION. AND ALSO A RETIRED
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
SERGEANT AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THIRTY
THREE AND I WOULD CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE A YES VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR LISTENING BY. LINE
TWO HUNDRED AND NINE TWO ZERO
NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI
THIS IS JIM WESTFALL- MEMBERS J.
R. P. A. N. D. N. R. ELLIE AND-
THEREFORE SPELMAN I'M STRONGLY
SUPPORT A. B. TWENTY THIRTY
THREE THANK YOU. ONE TO FIFTEEN.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KATHY
GRANT I AM ON THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OF THE CALIFORNIA
RIFLE AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION. I
HAVE FIFTEEN GRANDCHILDREN AND I
WOULD STRONGLY. WHEN YOU PUT
YOUR BILL THANK YOU. ONE TO
EIGHTEEN. HI MY NAME IS DAN
TROLLS I AM A C. R. PA
CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION MEMBER AND OF THE
NRA MEMBER I AM A CCW HOLDER AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB TWENTY
THIRTY THREE AND I WISH YOU GUYS
WOULD PLEASE VOTE YES ON IT.
THANK YOU. LYING TO TWELVE. MY
NAME'S JAMES O'BRIEN I AM A C.
R. P. A MEMBER LIFETIME NRA
MEMBER FORTY YEAR CALIFORNIA
HUNTING LICENSE HOLDER. AND I
WOULD DEBT PREACHER COURT FOR
THIS BILL AB TWO ZERO THREE
THREE THANK YOU. BY. TWO TWENTY
TWO. THAT'S FINE TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. HELLO THIS IS A LISTENER
ANGOLA AND MY THIRD FOR A CCW
HOLDER A MEMBER OF THE C. PA AND
THE NRA AND I VERY MUCH REPORT-
AB TWO THREE THREE AND I HOPE
THAT YOU ALL WILL VOTE IN
SUPPORT OF THAT AS WELL. THANK
YOU. LINE. ONE THIRTEEN. YES
HELLO INCLUDED- C. HOLDER AND I
AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY THIRTY THREE AND EVERYONE
NEEDS TO CONSIDER THAT
CALIFORNIA MAY PUT THANK YOU
FINE FORTY EIGHT LINE FORTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. BY
MISTER MEMBERS RYAN SHERMAN WITH
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION
AND OR OAKLAND SUPPORT BY THE
ARCADIA BURBANK CLAREMONT CORONA
CULVER CITY FOR AN ENGLISH ONLY
SCHOOLS. WHAT BEACH CALIFORNIA.
ALONA RIVERSIDE SANTANA ONE IN
BE AWARE PLASTERED SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION ON SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU. LINE TO
FOURTEEN. HI MY NAME IS PAUL
KATZ I'M A RESIDENT OF VENTURA
COUNTY I HAVE ONLY EXERCISE MY
SECOND AMENDMENT RIGHTS IN THE
LAST YEAR AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
AB TWENTY THIRTY THREE AND
ENCOURAGE YOU TO VOTE IN FAVOR
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ONE TO
TWENTY ONE. HI MY NAME IS JERRY
HUME I AM AN ART MEMBER AND I
SUPPORT AB TWENTY THIRTY THREE.
THANK YOU BYE TWO TWENTY SEVEN.
HI MY NAME IS JEFF TURNER I AM A
DEMOCRAT VOTER FROM FEES I
CALIFORNIA I HAVE BEEN A CCW
HOLDERS SINCE. TWO THOUSAND.
ABOUT RIDDLE'S BEING MAINLY AT
YOU THAT. LINE. TO TWENTY EIGHT.
ONE TO TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
SIR. NAME AN ORGANIZATION GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS. MY NAME IS
RON LANDER CHAIRMAN OF THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY C. R. PA
CHAPTER I'M A STRONG SUPPORTER
AS WELL AS MY MEMBERS AND THEIR
THREE HUNDRED FAMILIES OF TWO AB
TWO ZERO THREE THREE. THANK YOU
BYE TWO TWENTY NINE. HELLO MY
NAME IS JOSE LOPEZ OFFERS I'M A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE
DISASSOCIATION AND ARE A IN A
CCW HOLDER. I STRONGLY YOU'RE
ASKED FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR AB
TWO THIRTY THREE TWO ZERO THREE
THREE SORRY THANK YOU. ONE TO
THIRTY. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
CARLENE ELLIS I'M A MEMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND PISTOL
ASSOCIATION I AM A COMPETITIVE
POSITION- WITH INTERNATIONAL
DEFENSIVE PISTOL ASSOCIATION I
AM A FIFTY W. HLDER AND I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWO ZERO
THREE THREE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND A FINAL CALL LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN THERE WITH
THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIRED. THERE
IS NO ONE ELSE WHO SIGNALED
PARDON ME WE HAVE ONE ADDITIONAL
PERSON JUST A MOMENT. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR CHEN AND I
GUESS THIS YEAR ASSEMBLY YOU
KNOW COUNTY ABOUT ELEVEN
THOUSAND CCW HOLDERS THAT I HAVE
IN THIS COUNTY WERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
ONE TO THIRTY ONE. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MIKE KELLY
IF I'M A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE PISTOL
ASSOCIATION AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL TWO ZERO THREE
THREE THANK YOU. THIS FEATURE
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK. THANK
YOU OF ANY ONE IN THE ROOM IN
OPPOSITION. YES. GOOD MORNING
YEAH IT'S STILL MORNING ACT
SHARON MEMBERS ARE BACK IN
MARKETS ON BEHALF OF THE BRADY
CAMPAIGN AB TWO ZERO THREE THREE
WOULD BE A STEP BACKWARDS FOR
GUN SAFETY IN OUR COMMUNITIES
CURRENTLY FOR A CONCEALED CARRY
PERMIT TO BE ISSUED IN
CALIFORNIA THERE MUST BE A
BACKGROUND CHECK A FINDING OF
GOOD MORAL CHARACTER AND THAT
THE APPLICANT MEETS RESIDENCY
REQUIREMENTS GOOD CAUSE AND TH
COMPLETION OF A FIRE SAFETY OF
COURSE FURTHER A CONCEALED KERRY
LICENSE MAY BE LIMITED BY THE
ISSUING AUTHORITY AS A TEAM
WARRANTED THIS INCLUDES TIME
PLACE MANNER AND CIRCUMSTANCES
RESTRICTIONS IT IS IMPERATIVE
THAT THOSE WISHING TO CARRY
CONCEALED FIREARMS IN PUBLIC. BE
SUBJECT TO THE SCRUTINY AND
PROCESS REGULARLY THIS BILL
FALLS SHORT OF THIS THERE'S
SIMPLY TOO MUCH THAT CAN CHANGE
IN AN INDIVIDUAL'S LIFE OVER THE
COURSE OF FIVE YEARS AS THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS POINTS OUT A
PERSON'S MENTAL HEALTH OR LIFE
CIRCUMSTANCES MAY HAVE CHANGED
IN A WAY AS TO NOW MAKE THE
PERSON AT REST OR NO LONGER
HAVING GOOD COSTS SIMILAR
SIMILAR HE HAD THE RIGHT TO
CARRY CONCEALED FIREARMS SHOULD
ONLY COME WITH AN OBLIGATION TO
BE WELL TRAINED IN FIREARMS AND
FIREARM SAFETY REQUIRING
TRAINING ONLY EVERY FIVE YEARS
IS INSUFFICIENT AND WOULD PLACE
CALIFORNIANS AT RISK. IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT CALIFORNIA
CONTINUE TO BE A LEADER AND
MAINTAIN STRONG STANDARDS IN THE
FACE OF THE MOVEMENT TO PERMIT
LESS CARRY AND OTHER STATES
STATES WITH HIGHER WEEK
CONCEALED CARRY PERMITTING LAWS-
ASSOCIATED WITH 13215% HIGHER
RATES OF VIOLENT CRIME AND 11%
HIGHER RATES OF FIREARM HOMICIDE
I'D ALSO LIKE TO SAY THAT IN THE
HOUSE SUPPORTS AB TESTIMONY THEY
BROUGHT UP COST A LOT AND COST
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT IF THAT IS
THE ONE CONCERN THEY COULD
CONSIDER RAISING THE FEES FOR
COMPACT CONCEALED WEAPONS PERMIT
APPLICANTS FOR THESE REASONS
BRADY AND BRADY CALIFORNIA
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWO ZERO
THREE THREE. AN ORIGINAL VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU BUT WILL NOW
GO TO THE TO LINE OR ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. TO AB
TWENTY THIRTY THREE. FOR ANYONE
WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. M.
PARDON ME I. PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THERAPY WAS TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. MISTER CHAIR THERE
IS NO ONE WHO SIGNAL BUT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK THEY WILL BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS WITH
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
MISTER SEA AFTER THANK YOU. SO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD THIS ISN'T SO MUCH A BIG%
GUN RIGHTS BILL IS IT IS A
GOVERNMENT STREAMLINING BILL TO
ELIMINATE REDUNDANCY AND- AND
TAKE AWAY SOME OF THOSE PROCESS
SEES- CLOG UP THE SYSTEM SO TO
SPEAK. WHEN OFFICERS ARE
INVOLVED IN DOING ALL OF THAT-
IN DOING THIS EVERY TWO YEARS I
THINK ANYBODY IN THE ASSEMBLY
CAN ATTEST TO TWO YEARS GOES BY
PRETTY QUICK- BECAUSE IT SEEMS
LIKE- WE'RE ALWAYS HAVING TO.
GET OUT THERE AND HE'D RUN FOR
SEATS AGAIN BUT- BUT ANYWAY- I'D
LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR
ON THIS BILL- IF YOU'RE TAKING
CO AUTHORS. WE HONOR THAT OKAY
IN APPRECIATE THAT AND
APPRECIATE THE BILL IN THE
ATTEMPT TO HELP STREAMLINE
GOVERNMENT A LITTLE BIT. AND I
THINK. PEOPLE NEED TO ALSO MAKE
THE DISTINCTION BETWEEN- CZW
CARRIERS AND THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
INVOLVED IN IN IN GUN VIOLENCE-
VERY FEW OF THEM ARE C. C. W.
CARE. SO SO ANYWAY- PRECIADO
YOUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY
OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS. YOU
MAY CLOSE THIS IS YOUR FOR WANT
TO REGENERATE TODAY DOESN'T
CHANGE THE PROCESS WHICH GOT TO
GO THROUGH TO GET THE C. C. W.
ALL IT'S GOING TO DO EXTENDED
TIME. YOUR LICENSE CAN BE
REVOKED AT ANY TIME SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MICHAEL.
OKAY SO THIS IS AS YOU PROBABLY
NOTICED BILL TRIED. IN THIS
COMMITTEE- SEVERAL TIMES IT'S
AND IT FAILED MISS COMMITTEE
SERVICE OVER TIME. IN A REASON
IS BECAUSE THE LAST THING LAW.
THE EXISTING C. C. W. PERMIT
HOLDERS- I THINK ARE PROBABLY.
THE MOST CONSCIENTIOUS AND OF
GOOD MORAL CHARACTER PROBABLY IN
THE WORLD- IT IS BECAUSE WE HAVE
THIS PROCESS IN PLACE THAT THEY
HAVE TO COME BACK. EVERY TWO
YEARS. EXTENDING IT MAY HAVE
SOME ADVERSE WITH THAT TERM- IF
IT IF IT AIN'T BROKE DON'T FIX
IT. WELL RIGHT NOW THE SYSTEM.
ISN'T BROKEN- IN THAT COULD BE
CORRECTED BUT I DON'T THINK ANY
CCW. OWNER HAS BEEN INVOLVED IN
MASS SHOOTINGS OR ANY OF THAT-
AND I FIRMLY BELIEVE IS BECAUSE-
GOVERNMENT. WHICH DOESN'T ALWAYS
WORK ALL THE TIME THIS IS ONE
AREA. WHERE WE'RE AT 1100%
ACCURACY AND THE ROAD WANTED
PERCENT ABILITY TO ENSURE THAT
THE PUBLIC STAY SAFE- AND SO
UNFORTUNATE WITH DAD I'M GOING
TO. RECOMMEND A NO VOTE BUT I
UNDERSTAND WAT YOU'RE WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING BUT REALLY WOULD
LIKE FOR YOU TO LOOK AT. WHAT'S
HAPPENING NOW IN REALITY. THAT
THAT THE C. C. W. CARRIERS RIGHT
NOW BECAUSE OF THE- WHICH I
THINK YOU'RE CALLING STRINGENT.
REGULATIONS BECAUSE OF STRINGENT
REGULATIONS I THINK THE PUBLIC
HAS BEEN SAFE AND WE'VE ENSURE
THAT- BECAUSE OF A LIFE CHANGE
THE FORCES OR SOMEONE GETTING
ANGRIER THE MENTAL STATUS CHANGE
OVER FIVE YEARS- WE CAN GET THEM
A LOT SOONER. AND HOPEFULLY TAKE
AWAY THEIR GUNS OBVIOUSLY WE
MUST BE DOING IT BECAUSE AGAIN.
THERE HASN'T BEEN ANY ANY
PROBLEMS WITH THAT. ALL THE ROLE
. I THINK YOU NEED TO MOTIONS
ALL OF PROVIDE THAT OKAY. AB TWO
ZERO THREE THREE BY THE MEMBER
SMITH THE MOTION IS TO PASS
JONES SAWYER. JONES SAWYER NO
LACKEY LACKEY HI BONTA BONTA
KNOW BRIAN BRIAN NO QUIRK YOU
KNOW QUICK NOTES SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO KNOWS THEY ARE TO. I
THINK THEY ARE TOO HIGH. THE
MEASURE FAILS YOU MAY NOW GO ON
TO YOUR NECKS. IDM THE ONE OUNCE
RECONSIDERATION. I WILL ASK FOR
RECONSIDERATION BECAUSE I DO
BELIEVE IT IS GOING TO SAVE THE
PUBLIC TAXPAYERS MONEY AND THE
INDIVIDUAL PLAN FOR THE LICENSE
. OKAY THERE'S NO OBJECTION BUT
THIS IS ABOUT SAVING LIVES NOT
NECESSARILY MONEY YOU TALK ABOUT
MONEY OVER LIVES OKAY BUT WE
RECONSIDERATION. A BY UNANIMOUS
CONSENT. OKAY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS TODAY I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY
THREE OUR NATION IS FACING A
CRISIS THESE LAST FEW YEARS HAVE
SEEN A MAJOR INCREASE TARGETED
AN AMBUSH STYLE ATTACKS AGAINST
OUR POLICE OFFICERS LAST YEAR
ALONE THREE HUNDRED FORTY SIX
OFFICERS WERE SHOT IN THE LINE
OF DUTY. IN SIXTY THREE DIED AS
A RESULT OF THOSE INJURIES.
CALIFORNIA WAS RANKED AMONG THE
WORST FOR POLICE OFFICERS. IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. WITH SIX
OFFICERS BEING SHOT AND KILLED.
THE TWENTY UP ONE OTHERS INJURED
. AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY THREE
WHAT AT STATUTES AS A POLICE
OFFICER TO THE LIST OF
CHARACTERISTICS WHICH QUALIFY A
CRIMINAL ACT AS A HATE CRIME.
OTHER STATES HAVE ALREADY
RECOGNIZED THE DANGERS POLICE
OFFICERS FACE DUE TO THEIR
PROFESSION. AND HAVE TAKEN STEPS
TO ENSURE THAT THEY ARE
PROTECTED. THE IT IS THEREFORE
TO TIME THAT CALIFORNIA FOLLOW
SUIT IN ENSURING THAT ACTS OF-VIOLENCE AGAINST POLICE OFFICERS
IS RECOGNIZED AS A HATE CRIME.
THIS BILL IS CRUCIAL AT A TIME
WHEN LAW ENFORCEMENT IS WORKING
TO BRIDGE THE DIVISION WITHIN
THE COMMUNITIES THEY POLICE.
LET'S REINFORCE THAT NOTION.
THAT INDIVIDUAL SO TARGET POLICE
OFFICERS BECAUSE OF THE BADGE
THEY WEAR. SHOULD BE PUNISHED
FOR THAT MALICE WHETHER THOSE
OFFICERS ARE SITTING IN A PATROL
CAR OUTSIDE A METRO STATION OR
REPORTING UP ON A MULTIPLE CAR
CRASH AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY
THREE SENDS A MESSAGE THAT
TARGETED ATTACKS ON POLICE WON'T
BE TOLERATED INSURERS ADDITIONAL
CRIMINAL PENALTIES IF A CRIME
SPECIFICALLY TARGETS A VICTIM
BECAUSE OF THEY ARE A POLICE
OFFICER. FOR THAT REASON I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE
THANK YOU AND I DO HAVE AN AIR
OF DICUS WITH MY WITNESS OKAY
ASSEMBLY YOUR COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT WITNESSES AND WOULD
YOU SAY THE NAME SHANNON DICUS
SHANNON DICUS. IT IS A MASSIVE
CALLING WITNESS. EIGHTEEN T.
OPERATOR COULD YOU OPEN UP THE
LINE.
MISTER CHAIR PARDON ME I
APOLOGIZE WERE YOU CALLING FOR
WITNESS YES WE WERE- THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY. SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT DICHAS. M. PARDON ME
I MISTER CHAIRED APPEARS THAT
SHERIFF DICUS MAY HAVE DROPPED
OFF THE CALL. K. WHAT WE'LL DO
IS WE'LL GO TO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. AND IF HE DOES COME ON
ANYTIME WILL BRING THEM BACK IN
SO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. OF AB.
TWO THREE THREE THREE TWENTY
THREE THIRTY THREE. IT THAT ARE
IN THE ROOM ME COME TO THE TO
THE MICRO. ONE HR COMMITTEE WILL
GO DOWN FOR THE RECESSION AS FAR
AND WE SUPPORT BILL. THANK YOU.
JULIE IS A CHRISTIAN FROM SEMI
CANCERS APARTMENT IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. THANK YOU SIR. AND IT
NOW WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES
OF WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY THREE THIRTY THREE. YOU
MAY OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THOSE WHO
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. PARDON ME
IF YOU IF YOU ATTEMPTED TO PRESS
ONE THE JUROR ALREADY PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO CAN PLACE.
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO LINE. TWO
TWENTY EIGHT. ONE TO TWENTY
EIGHT YOU'RE ONE IS NOW OPEN. HI
AM I RIGHT RIGHT THAT RIGHT.
BLIND EIGHT- MISTER MEMBERS RYAN
SHERMAN WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S SUBSTATION AND PLH
MARQUITA BURBANK CLAREMONT GONNA
CLOVER CITY FOR TRAINING LOWER
SCHOOLS NEWPORT BEACH CALIFORNIA
AMOUNT OF RIVERSIDE DANIELLA AND
UPLAND ALL IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
YEAH THANK YOU SIR. MANY OTHERS
ON THE LINE EIGHTEEN THE
OPERATOR. I KNOW MISTER CHAIR
THERE IS NOT HOWEVER I BELIEVE
THAT WILL HAVE SHANNON DICUS
WITH THE SHERIFF DICUS WITH US
IN JUST A MOMENT. THANK YOU.
FIVE FORTY EIGHT SURE THANK IS
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU. HM
GOOD MORNING GERMANY WHERE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE PENSION AND I GUESS
ISSUE OF THE SAN MARINO COUNTY
THE MEN AND WOMEN OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT USED TO RISK THEIR
LIVES FOR THEIR COMMUNITIES.
THEY DO THIS DESPITE THE DAILY
REST OF THEIR PERSONAL SAFETY.
TOO OFTEN WEARING A UNIFORM
SUBJECTION TO BECOMING A TARGET
OF VIOLENT AND HATEFUL
CRIMINALS. AN EXAMPLE OF THIS IS
WHAT WE SEE ON NATIONAL NEWS
WHERE LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
ARE BEING SHOT AND KILLED WELL
SIMPLY SITTING IN THEIR PATROL
CARS. THERE ARE WORKING
DEDICATION AND NOT GONE
UNNOTICED AND ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY THREE THIRTY THREE WELL
RESTORE JUSTICE TO THE MEMBERS
OF OUR PROFESSION WERE
VICTIMIZED FOR SIMPLY PUTTING ON
A BADGE. ASSAULT AGAINST A PEACE
OFFICER SALAS 7% INCREASE
NATIONALLY BETWEEN TWENTY
NINETEEN TO TWENTY TWENTY. WITH
OVER SIXTY THOUSAND ASSAULTS
OCCURRING IN TWENTY TWENTY ALONE
. LAW ENFORCEMENT IS USED TO
STEPPING UP IN GOVERNING WRONG
THIS BILL SOLDERING CO AUTHORS
HAVE COURAGEOUSLY STEPPED UP BY
WRITING A PROVISION OUTLINING A
PEACE OFFICER AS A PROTECTED
CLASS WITH RESPECT TO HATE
CRIMES. A DESIGNATION THAT NOT
ONLY SHOWS WE'RE WILLING TO
SUPPORT LAW ENFORCEMENT WELL ONE
AND MAYBE TERROR VIOLENCE
AGAINST THEM. RECRUITING MEN AND
WOMEN TO JOIN LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
BECOMING INCREASINGLY DIFFICULT
. TOO OFTEN THOSE WHO WOULD JOIN
DON'T AND THEIR FAMILIES WORRY
THEY MIGHT BECOME ONE MORE
STATISTIC A VICTIM OF VIOLENCE
TARGETING LAW ENFORCEMENT. WHEN
THERE'S NO ONE LEFT TO ANSWER
THE CALL WE WILL HAVE TO ASK
OURSELVES WHAT MORE COULD WE
HAVE DONE. LIKE MANY AGENCIES
ACROSS THE STATE AND COUNTRY OUR
DEFICIT FACED INCREASED VIOLENCE
IN FEBRUARY OF TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE DETECTIVE JEREMIAH MACKAY
WAS SHOT AND KILLED BY
CHRISTOPHER DORNER WHO
SPECIFICALLY SET UP TO TARGET
COPS. IN OCTOBER TWENTY EIGHTEEN
DEPUTY ROBERT JOHN WAS SHOT TO A
CLOSED DOOR OR ANSWERING A CALL
FOR SERVICE. IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE PARDUBICE EXPERIENCE
SIGNIFICANT SPIKES IN VIOLENCE
W. DUSTIN WILSON WAS SHOT AND
WAS NEARLY KILLED WHILE ON A
VEHICLE CHECK. SERGEANT DOMINICK
BACA WAS SHOT AND KILLED WHILE
TRYING TO APPREHEND THE SUSPECT
AFTER PURSUIT. DEBBIE CARLOS
VELASCO WAS THE VICTIM OF AN
UNPROVOKED AMBUSH WITH AN
ASSAULT RIFLE ASSEMBLY
ATTEMPTING TO MAKE A TRAFFIC
STOP. THE FOLLOWING NUMBERS
REPRESENT THE NUMBER OF DEPUTY
SHERIFF'S OFFICIALS IN SAN
MARINO COUNTY. AND TWENTY
SIXTEEN TWO HUNDRED SIXTY NINE.
IN. TWENTY SEVENTEEN FOUR
HUNDRED SEVENTEEN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN SIX EIGHTY SIX. TWENTY
NINETEEN SIX TWENTY SIX AND
TWENTY TWENTY SIX SEVENTY THREE.
FROM TWENTY SIX TO TWENTY TWENTY
THERE'S BEEN A HUNDRED AND 50%
INCREASE IN VIOLENCE AGAINST OUR
JAPANESE. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
THREE THIRTY THREE CAN HELP SLOW
THE ONGOING ASSAULT ON PEACE
OFFICERS AND SEND A POWERFUL
MESSAGE THAT THERE'S NO PLACE
FOR HATE BASED VIOLENCE
INCLUDING VIOLENCE DIRECTED AT
MEN AND WOMEN. WHO HAVE CHOSEN
TO SERVE A LIFE OF SERVICE. I
INCLUDING PEACE OFFICERS IN LIST
OF ACTUAL OR PERCEIVED
CHARACTERISTICS OF VICTIMS THAT
QUALIFY. WILL BE BETTER EQUIPPED
TO DEFEND OUR OFFICERS IN
INSTANCES WHERE HATE CRIMES ARE
PERPETRATED AGAINST THEM OUT OF
BIAS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND CONSIDERATION I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU PASS
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
THIRTY THREE. THANK YOU WE WILL
NOW. GO TO OPPOSITION. YOU HAVE
FIVE MINUTES. THE. MARGO GEORGE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION I
WANT TO SAY THAT WERE
SYMPATHETIC TO THE TOUGH AND
SOMETIMES THANKLESS JOB THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAVE AS A PUBLIC
DEFENDER FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS I
SAW FIRST HAND WHAT ON A LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAD TO DEAL WITH- AB
TWENTY THREE THIRTY THREE WILL
NOT MAKE POLICING SAFER CRIMES
AGAINST POLICE ARE ALREADY
PUNISHED WITH HARSHER
PUNISHMENTS THAN CRIMES AGAINST
CIVILIANS RANGING FROM DOUBLE
THE COUNTY JAIL SENTENCE FOR
ASSAULT TO ON. THE DEATH PENALTY
OR L. WANT FOR MURDER. HATE
CRIMES HAS TRADITIONALLY BEEN A
CATEGORY BASED ON DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST IMMUTABLE
CHARACTERISTICS SUCH AS AGE.
COLOR DISABILITY GENDER I. D.
NATIONAL ORIGIN RACE SEX AND
SEXUAL ORIENTATION. SOME OF US
IN THIS ROOM HAVE THOSE
CHARACTERISTICS. AND WE CAN'T
CHANGE THEM I CAN'T CHANGE MY
AGE I CAN'T CHANGE THE FACT THAT
I'M FEMALE WELL PERHAPS I COULD
MAIL DAYS BUT DON'T CHOOSE TO IT
WOULD BE VERY- BUT LIFE
ALTERING- BUT PEACE OFFICER
STATUS IS DIFFERENT IT'S AN
OCCUPATION THAT CAN BE EASILY
CHANGED. ADDING POLICE OFFICERS
HAS THE POTENTIAL FOR LONG TERM
DISTORTION OF THE HATE CRIME
CATEGORY. BECAUSE UNFORTUNATELY
WE'VE SEEN IN THE LAST NUMBER OF
YEARS OF QUITE A FEW INDIVIDUAL
OCCUPATIONS TARGETED. BUSINESS
INSIDER REPORTED IN OCTOBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THAT 31% OF
HOSPITAL NURSES HAVE REPORTED AN
INCREASE IN VIOLENCE UP FROM 22%
IN MARCH OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
ONE AND FOUR NURSES FACES
PHYSICAL VIOLENCE ON THE JOB.
AND THE HOSPITAL IS THE MOST
DANGEROUS SPORT ONE OF THE MOST
DANGEROUS WORKPLACES IN THE
COUNTRY ACCORDING TO OSHA. SALES
CLERKS HAVE BEEN SHOT AND KILLED
FOR ASKING ON CUSTOMERS TO WEAR
FACEMASK. ELECTION POLL WORKERS
SURVEYS HAVE FOUND THAT 17% OF
AMERICA'S A LOCAL ELECTIONS WERE
OFFICIALS HAVE BEEN THREATENED
DUE TO THEIR JOBS DURING THE
TWENTY TWENTY ELECTION CYCLE AND
THE CO THAT NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
AB TWENTY THREE EIGHT. THIRTY
THREE IS BAD PUBLIC POLICY
BECAUSE IT DIMINISHES THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF THE CRIME
DESIGNATION AND FOLLOWS THE
FILLED PARADIGM OF TRYING TO
DEAL WITH OUR SOCIAL PROBLEMS
WITH INCREASED CRIMINALIZATION
AND CARS AND INCARCERATION. SO
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR NO
VOTE ON A B. TWENTY THREE THIRTY
THREE. THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN THE IN THE
ROOM THAT ARE IN OPPOSITION.
WHEN I GO TO THE PHONE LINES
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION- TO AB.
TWO THREE THREE THREE TWENTY
THREE THIRTY THREE ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE. FOR ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
TWENTY THREE THIRTY THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO. ONCE AGAIN
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND
GO TO LINE EIGHTY TWO. ANDREY
AND KRISTINA BONTA DELI ON WITH
SAMBAR DINO FREEDOM ALL AND
PROJECT AMIGA IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. ONE ONE FORTY FOUR.
PARDON ME. LINE ONE FORTY FOUR.
AND JUST ANOTHER MOMENT. HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES HI GARY
WITH PROGRAM PRIVATE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWO THREE THREE
THREE. BY. TWO THIRTY NINE. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS GOING TO CO
SIGN ON BEHALF OF THE ENTIRE
DEFINITION WEEK WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE AB. TWO THREE THREE
THREE. MISTER CHAIR THERE IS NO
ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH
TO SPEAK. THANK YOU WE NOW BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS YES RIGHT.
NOT POLICING IS AN INCREDIBLY
DANGEROUS PROFESSION- AND I
APPRECIATE WHAT THE AUTHORS
TRYING TO DO THERE AS WAS
ALREADY MENTIONED THERE ARE
ALREADY A NUMBER OF LAWS. THE
PLACING HIM HAS WITH A CRIMES
AGAINST POLICE OFFICERS PENAL
CODE. TWO FORTY ONE C.
SPECIFICALLY DEFINES ASSAULT ON
A POLICE OFFICER AND REYES THE
PUNISHMENT BY UP TO ONE YEAR IN
COUNTY JAIL OR A FINE OF TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR BOTH JAIL
AND A FINE IT'S LITERALLY DOUBLE
THE PUNISHMENT. THAT SOMEONE
ASSAULTING A PERSON WAS NOT A
POLICE OFFICER WE GET. THIS SIX
SIX FOUR E. ATTEMPTED MURDER ON
A PEACE OFFICER. RESULT RESULT
IN A WHILE. TWO FORTY THREE BE
BETTER IN A POLICE OFFICER TO
MISDEMEANOR BUT THIS TO FORTY
THREE C. WHICHRAISE THE TOLL
WOBBLER TO FORTY THREE D. WHICH
RAISE IT TO. A SERIOUS FELONY.
ONE FORTY EIGHT BE RESISTING
ARREST WHICH GETS ADDED TO MANY
MANY MANY MANY MANY MANY
ENCOUNTERS WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF PROTECTED
CLASSES IT WAS ITERESTING TO ME
THAT ONE OF THE WITNESSES
BROUGHT UP CHRISTOPHER DORNER
WHO HIMSELF WAS A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER WHO WAS
UPSET FEELING THAT HIS PROTECTED
CLASSES A BLACK OFFICER HAD BEEN
VIOLATED BY SOME OF HIS
COLLEAGUES IT'S A TERRIBLY
TRAGIC HORRIBLE. HORRIBLE CASE
BUT I DON'T THINK THAT IT RISES
TO THE CONVERSATION ABOUT HATE
WHEN WE HAVE A IMMUTABLE
CHARACTERISTICS FOR BLACK FOLKS
ARE JEWISH COMMUNITY- API
COMMUNITY AS WE HEARD EARLIER
TODAY THERE'S A LOT WE'VE GOT TO
DO TO ADDRESS HATE AND I DON'T
THINK YOUR CHOSEN PROFESSION
RISES TO THE SAME. AS THE
IMMUTABLE CHARACTERISTICS THAT
MANY FOLKS WERE BORN WITH SO I
WILL BE RESPECTFULLY VOTING NO
ON THIS ONE. YOUR COMMENT. WITH
THAT YOU MAY CLOSE MISTER SMITH
IS THIS BILLS DOES NOT DO
ANYTHING FOR REAL RESISTING
ARREST WITH THE DEPUTY IS
STRICTLY AMBUSH STYLE ASSAULT ON
OUR MEN AND WOMEN IN UNIFORM
BECAUSE THEY WERE THE BATCH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
AND I AND I SYMPATHIZE IN FACT I
OF MY BLOOD STILL BOILS WHEN I
SEE YOUNG PEOPLE JUST SCREAM AND
HOLLER AT. LAWFORD'S OFFICE WHO
JUST DOING YOUR JOB LIKE KEEPING
THE PEACE AND WE DO HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING PREEMPTIVE FIGURE OUT
A WAY. TO GET- LAW ENFORCEMENT
THE KIND OF RESPECT THEY USED TO
HAVE IT'S OBVIOUSLY GONE WAY
DOWN. ANYBODY THAT'S WILLING TO-
KILL A LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER
REALLY SHOULD NOT BE AMONGST US
AND SHOULD BE TAKEN OFF THE
STREET AND SO I BELIEVE WE DO
HAVE LAWS THAT IT RECOGNIZES
THAT THAT THAT PERSON IS
PROBABLY THE MOST DANGEROUS
PERSON YOU COULD HAVE SHOULD
HAVE IF YOU'RE NOT AFRAID TO
KILL LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER
AND- THE BUT I THINK WE DO HAVE
EXISTING LAWS THAT CAN THAT CAN
HANDLE THAT CAN TAKE CARE OF
THAT AND ULTIMATELY PROTECT THE
PUBLIC. IF NOT THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS AND
FORTUNATE WITH THAT I WILL
RECOMMENDED A NO VOTE. PROVIDE
THE MOTION. CALDERON ON AB
TWENTY THREE THIRTY THREE BY
SEVEN MEMBER SMITH THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER NO LACKEY LACKEY HI BONTA
BONTA KNOW BRIAN. NO BRIAN NO
QUIRK. QUIRK KNOWS SANTIAGO
SEYARTO THEY ARE TO I. THE
MEASURE FAILED. DOES HE WANT
THAT. OKAY YOU'RE WELCOME MISTER
TEEN- I DON'T NUMBER SIX A. B.
ONE NINE FOUR SEVEN NINETEEN
FORTY SEVEN. THANK YOU MATURE
LET ME JUST DOUBLE. THANK THE
CHAIR AND ALL THE COMMITTEE
STAFFER WORKING WITH ME ON THIS
BILL WE ARE GLADLY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS- AB
NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN- STEMS FROM
THE SIGNIFICANT JUMP INHATE
CRIMES IN OUR STATE. AND IN OUR
COUNTRY IN PARTICULAR TARGETED
TOWARD ASIAN AMERICANS- IN
PARTICULAR SAN FRANCISCO A
RECENT STATS SHOWED THAT IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE HATE CRIMES
JUMPED OVER FIVE HUNDRED
PERCENT. IN IN LA HE CRIMES
JUMPED OVER A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THREE PERCENT-
TARGETING- API'S HAVING SAID
THAT WHILE THERE THE JUMP
AGAINST API'S ARE STILL THE
LARGEST. AFRICAN AMERICANS STILL
REDUCE REMAIN UNFORTUNATELY THE
LARGEST- THE LARGEST RECIPIENTS
OF HATE CRIMES AND HATE
INCIDENTS IN OUR STATE. THIS
WEEK THIS BILL IS REALLY-
FOCUSED ON REQUIRING LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO ADOPT A
DETAILED SPECIFIC POLICY
INSTRUCTING OFFICERS ON HOW TO
IDENTIFY RESPOND TO AND REPORT
HE CRIMES- WE SEE TOO OFTEN IN
SOME COUNTIES WHERE THERE ARE NO
HATE CRIMES A REPORT I BELIEVE
SAMPOERNA DINO RIVERSIDE.A
REPORTED- ZERO TWO NO HATE
CRIMES SAID THAT HE COMES AREN'T
OCCURRING IN THOSE JURISDICTIONS
JUSTICE STOP PERHAPS OFFICERS
ARE ABLE TO RESPOND THEY CAN'T
REPORT OR PEOPLE DON'T FEEL
COMFORTABLE COMING FORWARD.
REGARDLESS WHAT WE WANT IS WE
WANT- POST TV WORKING WITH EVERY
SINGLE LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY IN
THE ENTIRE STATE TO DEVELOP A
BEST PRACTICE- SO THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES HAVE THE
ABILITY TO CALL AND TRAIN THEIR
OFFICERS ON REALLY HOW TO BEST
RESPOND IDENTIFY. AND TO REPORT
THESE HATE CRIMES ON. I THINK WE
CAN ALL AGREE THAT THESE.
INCIDENTS ARE UNFORTUNATELY AND
WE'VE SEEN A RISE OF THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS THERE'S BEEN A HUGE
FRUSTRATION- THAT HAS ALSO RISEN
DUE TO COLD IT AND FORTUNATELY
WAS CERTAIN COMMUNITIES BEING
TARGETED ARE BEING BLAMED FOR
THE VIRUS WE'RE SEEING. THAT
UNFORTUNATELY- YOU KNOW MY
COMMUNITY IN THE APP I COMMUNITY
HAS BEEN ONE OF THE MAJOR
TARGETS- JUST A FEW THINGS THAT
AB NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN DOESN'T
DO IT DOESN'T EXPAND PENALTIES
OR EXPAND WHAT A HATE CRIME IS
SO DOESN'T CHANGE THE
DEFINITIONS. IT ALSO ENSURES
THAT HATE CRIMES ARE REPORTED AS
HATE CRIMES AND VICTIMS- I HAVE
THE ABILITY TO GO GET THE
RESPECT AND THE DIGNITY THEY
DESERVE ALL ACROSS CALIFORNIA SO
THAT- WE HAVE CHARLES JOHN HERE
FROM THE CALIFORNIA ASIAN
PACIFIC AMERICAN BAR
ASSOCIATION- AS OUR FIRST
WITNESS. AT THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIR JONES SAWYER MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS CHARLES
JOHN I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASIAN PACIFIC
AMERICAN BAR ASSOCIATION. DEEPLY
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND YOUR
CONSIDERATION. I THE THAT THESE
- THE HATE CRIMES ARE NOTHING
NEW ALTHOUGH THEY HAVE BEEN
RISING WHAT'S DIFFERENT NOW IS
THAT. WE HAVE TECHNOLOGY TO BEAR
WITNESS TO THIS HATE. AND YOU
MAY HAVE SEEN. THE VIDEO- OUT OF
JURISDICTION IN NEW YORK- QUEEN
AMERICAN WOMAN NAMED ESTHER LEE.
WHO WAS TAKING A TRAIN HOME. AND
MAN APPROACHED HER- CASSIRER
DIDN'T RECEIVE THE REACTION THAT
HE WANTED- SPEWED BOTH
GUARANTEES AT HER- VULGAR
GESTURES. AND SPIT ON HER TWICE.
AND CALLED HER A KERRIER. A
KERRIER. AND THE INVESTIGATING
OFFICER IN THAT SITUATION-
DESPITE THE REQUEST THE VICTIM.
REFUSED TO. INVESTIGATE IS A
HATE CRIME AND IN ADDITION
REFUSE TO EVEN INCLUDE THE WORD
CARRIER IN THE REPORT BECAUSE IT
WAS NOT RELEVANT IN HIS VIEW
DESPITE HER REQUEST. SHE
INQUIRED AND HE SAID THAT IT
WASN'T BECAUSE THE PERSON DIDN'T
SAY ASIAN CARRIER OR CHINESE
CARRIER IT DIDN'T RISE TO THE
LEVEL OF THE HATE CRIME. THESE
CRIMES CERTAINLY ARE. BECOMING A
CUTE IN THE TIME OF COATED- BUT
THEY DIDN'T START WITH CODE- IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN IN. WHAT I THINK
WE CAN ALL AGREE WAS A VERY
DIVISIVE- ELECTION THAT'S WHEN
WE STARTED SEEING THE RISE OF
HATE CRIMES. NOT JUST AGAINST
EAST ASIANS AGAINST IMMIGRANTS
CALIFORNIA WAS THE NUMBER ONE A
PLACE WHERE WE START WE HAD THE
GREATEST RICE THE NUMBER OF HATE
CRIMES THESE PILOTS AND HATEFUL
ACTS- IMMIGRANTS IN PARTICULAR
HISPANICS- WORK THAT WE SIDE
DRAMATIC JUMP- THAT'S WHEN I
PERSONALLY STARTED BECOME
INVOLVED IN THIS ISSUE- WHEN I
HEARD ABOUT SIX AMERICAN MAN.
STOPPED AT A STOP SIGN IN
RICHMOND CALIFORNIA NOT TOO FAR
FROM- NOT TOO FAR FROM WHERE I
LIVE- HE- A WHITE PICKUP TRUCK
FILLED WITH MEN. PULLED UP
ALONGSIDE HIM THREW A BEER CAN
AT HIS- CAR CHASE THEM TO THE
NEXT STOP WHITE AND WHEN HE
ROLLED DOWN HIS WINDOW. TWO
TALKED TO- THESE PEOPLE COSTING
HIM.
EXCUSE ME HE ADDED THEY REACHED
INTO. HIS CAR AND KNOCKED OFF
HIS RELIGIOUSLY MANDATED- HEAD
DRESS- GRABBED HIS HAIR AND- CUT
HIS RIDICULOUSLY MANDATED- TOP
NOT. IN THERE EVEN THERE BECAUSE
THERE ARE PEOPLE DON'T ALWAYS
USE THE N. WORD OR THE C. WORD.
AB BUT IT TAKES SOME TIME TO
INVESTIGATE. AND YOU KNOW WE ALL
KNOW THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS ARE SOMETIMES OVER TAX
THEIR OVERTAXED AND- WHAT THIS
BILL DOES IS IT HELPS ASSIST OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS BY
PROVIDING TRAINING AND POLICIES
SO THAT THEY- KNOW A THING WHEN
THEY SEE IT. THEY KNOW IT WHEN
THEY SEE IT. AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AT TEEN- WHO I THINK FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP- EXPRESSED THIS IS
NOT EXPAND PENALTIES IT DOES NOT
EXPANDED DEFINITION OF HATE
CRIMES IT S. SISTER LAW
ENFORCEMENT DEPARTMENTS BY-
MAKING SURE THAT OVER TAX POLICE
DEPARTMENTS I GET THE TRAINING
THAT THEY NEED TO DO A PROPER
INVESTIGATION. I'LL JUST CLOSE
WITH ONE PERSONAL STORY WHICH IS
- YOU KNOW THAT MMHM MY FAMILY
GREW UP IN DETROIT AND FLINT
MICHIGAN. AND YOU KNOW WHAT WE
SEE TODAY YOU KNOW- THE HIM MY
SISTER AND I HAD TO WALK THROUGH
A FIELD TO GET OUR ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL GILLISPIE ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL AND- WHAT YOU KNOW WHAT
WE WERE AFRAID OF WALKING
THROUGH THAT FIELD. BECAUSE. IN
THE PAST I REMEMBER THAT
DISTINCT. DID DISTINCT MEMORY OF
BEING CALLED A CHECK OR CHEN
CHONG OR GO BACK TO CHINA I AM
KOREAN BY THE WAY- AND- THAT
FEELING OF FEAR WHEN
NEIGHBORHOOD CHILDREN WOULD
THROW ROCKS AT OUR HOME. IN A
WET WHEN I MOVED TO CALIFORNIA
TWENTY FOUR YEARS AGO- AND
STARTED TO RAISE A FAMILY HERE
YOU KNOW I SAW CALIFORNIA AS A-
YOU KNOW BUT BUT AS A TRUE
MELTING POT A PLACE OF. BEGIN A
BIT THAT THAT IN MY VIEW HAD YOU
KNOW THAT THIS WAS A PLACE OF
REFUGE FOR SOMEONE FROM THE API
COMMUNITY- MY PARENTS VISITED ME
FOR EIGHTY EIGHT DAYS IN SAN
FRANCISCO EIGHTY EIGHT DAYS IN
THAT TIME THEY WERE ACCOSTED
THREE TIMES- VIOLENTLY ATTACKED
TWO TIMES AND THEY ARE AFRAID
THEY ARE AFRAID OF LIVING IN SAN
FRANCISCO THEY'RE FREE TO VISIT
ME THEY CAN'T LEAVE THEY ARE
AFRAID OF LEAVING THEIR HOUSE-
HATE CRIMES- THIS IS NOT GONNA
SOLVE. HATE CRIMES THIS IS NOT
GOING TO ELIMINATE HATE- BUT
WHAT THIS DOES DO IS. MAKE A-
MAKE A CHANGE TO HELP OUR
OFFICERS. I INVESTIGATE- AND SEE
IT WHEN IT OCCURS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU-
ANY OTHER WITNESSES. YOU'RE
RIGHT MCCARTY HERE WITH THE ARK
AND UNITED CEREBRAL PALSY WE
HAVE A YOU HAVE A MINUTE HE- WE
USUALLY FIVE MINUTES ALTOGETHER
BUT GO AHEAD I'LL BE BRIEF OF
CALIFORNIA CORPORATION ONE OF
THE SPONSORS I WAS ALSO AND
ASKED BY SEVERAL OF THE
SPONSORED GROUPS TWO X. WHO ARE
HERE AT TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT. THOSE ARE THE FEMINIST
MAJORITY. THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
OF CHURCHES IMPACT. THE HINDU
AMERICAN FOUNDATION THE-
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF HUMAN
RELATIONS ORGANIZATIONS. AND THE
CENTER FOR THE STUDY OF HATE AND
EXTREMISM AT CCAC CAL STATE OF
TIMBER DINO. THIS BILL IS BASED
ON THE- FINDINGS OF THE AUDIT
THAT THESE- RIBBON KANSEN CHU
GOT AT THE REQUEST OF- SO MANY
THE SAME SUPPORTING GROUPS.
WHICH FOUND THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
CALIFORNIA HAS NOT ADEQUATELY
IDENTIFIED REPORTED OR RESPONDED
TO HATE CRIMES IT IT FOCUSES
PARTICULARLY ON THE AUDIT
RECOMMENDATIONS CONCERNING. WHAT
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES SHOULD
DO WHICH ARE TO HAVE FORMAL
POLICIES TO GUIDE EVERY OFFICER
AND THE POLICIES BUILD OUT OF
THIS BILL ARE BASED ON THE REAL
WORLD EXPERIENCE OF- COMMUNITIES
IN CALIFORNIA THEY'RE VERY AT
THAT ARE SUBJECT HE GRABS THE
EXAMPLES ARE ALL REAL WORLD
EXAMPLES IS NOT HYPOTHETICAL
FROM THE- SECONDLY IS. ABOUT THE
USE OF A SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT
FORM TO THE OFFICERS THE FIRST
RESPONDING OFFICER CAN CONDUCT
AN INVESTIGATION ON THE SCENE-
INTERVIEW THE WITNESSES ON THE
SCENE LOOK FOR EVIDENCE ON THE
SCENE. AND THE THIRD IS- IS
MANDATED TRAINING WHICH- THE
LEGISLATURE ADOPTED LAST YEAR
AND THIS REQUIRES UP AS AN
ACTUAL SCHEDULE WHAT ACTUALLY
HAPPENS. ON THE FOURTH PART OF
THE- A RECOMMENDATION OF THE
AUDIT WAS THE DOJ SHOULD
EXERCISE LEADERSHIP. TO GUIDE A
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WHICH
THIS BILL DOES BY REQUIRING
AGENCIES TO SUPPORT SUBMIT THEIR
HATE CRIMES POLICIES TO CHEER UP
DOJ TO CHECK TO MAKE SURE THEY
USE THE STATUTORY DEFINITION OF
HATE CRIMES WHICH SOME STILL DO
NOT. AND THAT THEY OTHERWISE
COMPLY WITH THE LAW. THANK YOU-
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN THE ROOM
AND SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS DUANE CAMP
JUNIOR HERE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR RETIRED
AMERICANS PROUD CO SPONSORS OF
THIS REST OF THIS BILL- AND
HUMBLED TO JOIN OUR PARTNERS AND
ASKING FOR SUPPORT TODAY. THANK
YOU. WHEN I GO TO A FORMALIZED
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. I EIGHTEEN
T. OPERATORS YOU CAN OPEN UP.
THE PHONE LINES UP FOR AB
NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR THOSE WHO WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE NINE ZERO. AGAIN IF YOU WISH
ONE ZERO. AND WE HAVE THE BLUE
SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK.
WE'RE GOING TO FIRST GO TO LINE
TWO FORTY THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MOLLY BYNUM
WITH THE W. ASKED ME LOCAL THEIR
NINE THIRTY. OF YOUR TRUNKS
COURT IT IS NOT IMPORTANT FOR
THE- A- LINE. SIXTY TWO. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS SUPPORTERS A. B. NINETEEN
FORTY SEVEN THANK YOU. LINE TWO
FORTY FIVE. UNDER WATER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB.
NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN. WHY TWO
FORTY EIGHT. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS RICHARD KONDA EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE ASIA ALL I CAN
SATURDAY WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORTER AB NINETEEN FORTY
SEVEN THANK YOU. BY TWO FIFTY
THREE. HI DOMINIQUE THAN A WITH
THE CALIFORNIA HAWAII AND AT
LAKE SUPERIOR IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. BY TWO FORTY SIX.
I'LL BE HAPPY THE CALIFORNIA
FOUNDATION FOR INDEPENDENT
LIVING CENTERS AS YOU DANNO
CONTESTS IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE
NINE FOURTH UP. FIND TO FIFTY
ONE. FIVE THE ONE OF THE
CALIFORNIA NIN TWO FIFTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS ANNA HAD A CAT AND I'M
CALLING N STRONG SUPPORT. OF AB
FOURTEEN I'M SORRY NINETEEN
FORTY SEVEN ON BEHALF OF THE
LOTUS BUT THE FOUNDATION THANK
YOU. BY TWO FORTY SEVEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS JENNY OLSON ON
BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN FORTY
SEVEN THANK YOU. FIVE TO FIFTY.
MY NAME IS CENTER CITY WHATEVER
WITH PEACE AND FREEDOM PARTY OF
CALIFORNIA THE LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE CHAIR AND I'M CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN FORTY
SEVEN. LINE ONE EIGHTEEN. HELLO
THIS IS KEY TO MY MODEM SHARE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- I'M
NOT REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE FOR RETIRED AMERICANS
AND ON THE- ONE YEAR AND SIX
MONTH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
KILLINGS IN ATLANTA WE SUPPORT
THIS BILL. BY. TWO FIFTY TWO. HI
MARC LEVINE IN MARIN COUNTY
STRONG SUPPORT A. B. NINETEEN
FORTY SEVEN THANK YOU. BY. TWO
FORTY NINE. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES YES. SANDY HANCHER
CLICKING FOR NOAH MARIN NAME
OPPOSE AND ABOLISH HATE.
SPEAKING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN. K. LINE Q.
FIFTY FIVE. FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN.
ONCE AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
MOMENT.
THE MISTER CHAIR I PARDON ME
JUST ONE MOMENT. LINE. TWO FIFTY
ONE TO FIFTY SIX. HI MY NAME IS
COULD TURN AROUND THAT'S WHY AND
I'M ONE OF THE CO FOUNDERS OF
COMPASSION IN OAKLAND WE ALSO
HAVE CHAPTERS IN SAN FRANCISCO
AND THE SAN GABRIEL VALLEY AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AB ONE NINE
FOUR SEVEN. THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIR THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO
SIGNAL THEY WISH TO SPEAK OKAY
GAME TO WOULD NOW BRING IT BACK
TO. OPPOSITION ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM. WHEN OUR
PHONE LINES FOR OPPOSITION. AT&T
OPERATORS MAKE PUBLIC LIFE FOR
OPPOSITION. TO A ALSO WISH TO
SPEAK. GO AHEAD. FOR THOSE WHO
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO PRESS
ONE ZERO IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO LINE TWO FORTY
TWO. YES HELLO MY NAME IS NANCY
APPEL I AM SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE ANTI DEFAMATION LEAGUE
INTERNATIONAL LEADING ANTI HATE
ORGANIZATIONS WITH DEEP AND
BROAD EXPERTISE AND HATE CRIME
LEGISLATION RESPOND
INVESTIGATION AND PREVENTION. WE
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT SENATE DOUBLE THE
CONCERNS THAT WE HAD- WELL AS
INTRODUCED AND AS WE MENTIONED
IN OUR OPPOSITION LETTER HOWEVER
WE REMAIN OPPOSED TO THE BILL
DUE TO NUMBER OF CONTINUING
CONCERN WHICH WE HAVE CONVEYED
IN DETAIL TO THE BILL'S SPONSOR
. MISTER CHAIR THERE IS NO ONE
ELSE TO SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK. THEY WILL BE BACK TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS MR LACKEY YEAH I JUST
HAVE A REALLY QUICK COMMENT MORE
THAN A QUESTION- BUT THIS IS
CLEARLY A WORTHY CAUSE. AND ONE
THAT DESERVES ATTENTION BECAUSE
LIVING IN FEAR- MUST BE
CHALLENGED AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
COULD CERTAINLY USE. THE
ASSISTANCE THAT- HOPEFULLY THIS
THIS MEASURE WILL PROVIDE.
HOWEVER I KNOW THAT DOES BUDGET
CHAIR YOU UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF FISCAL NECESSITY.
AND I KNOW LISTA POLICY
COMMITTEE BUT I'M HOPING THERE'S
GOING TO BE SOME FUNDING.
AVAILABLE BECAUSE THIS IS GONNA
TAKE A LOT OF RESOURCES TO DO SO
AND IT'S WORTHY OF THAT. I JUST
HOPE THAT- THE FUNDING ASPECT IS
NOT IGNORED. IN OTHER MEMBERS.
WITH THAT YOU MAY CLOSE NO THAT
. THANK MISS LACKEY PUSH
PRESSURE THAT COMMENT OBVIOUSLY-
THE FIRST UP WILL BE WORKING
WITH POST TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
BEST PRACTICE POLICY GETS PUT
TOGETHER AND I'LL BE THE FIRST I
THINK THE FIRST STEP AND THEN
OBVIOUSLY WORKING WITH A
DIFFERENT AGENCIES WILL BE THE
NEXT BUT BUT AGAIN I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S.
SUPPORT AND THE COMMITTEE'S
FEEDBACK AND AGAIN RESPECTFULLY
I STRIVE VOTE ON AB NINETEEN
FORTY SEVEN YOU'RE GONNA NEED A
MOTION AND A SECOND. A BOB
SECRETARY MICHAEL WROTE. ON AB
NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN BY SEVEN
MEMBER TEAM THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER IRAQI.
LACKEY HI BONTA. BONTA HI BRIAN
HI BRIAN HI QUIRK. QUIRK I SAN
DIEGO. SAN DIEGO I SEYARTO. THEY
ARE TOO HIGH. THAT MEASURE
PASSED. NOW WE HAVE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KILL WEBER- AB.
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY FIVE. FROM.
YOU MAY BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE AND ITS
STAFF FOR ALL ITS WORK AND I
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. I'M HERE TO PRESENT
AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY FIVE WHICH
ALLOWSSURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE ASSAULT TO HAVE ACCESS
TO MEDICAL EVIDENTIARY
EXAMINATION. DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
IS A CRIME THAT OFTEN ESCALATES
WITHOUT INTERVENTION. RESEARCH
DEMONSTRATES THAT EVEN ONE
INCIDENT OF STRANGULATION IS A
PREDICTOR OF A FUTURE ATTEMPT OF
MURDER AND ONE OF THE MOST
LETHAL FORMS OF INTIMATE PARTNER
VIOLENCE. CURRENTLY SURVIVORS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE HAVE AN EQUAL
ACCESS TO CARE. AS THEY ARE NOT
PROVIDED THE SAME RIGHT TO
MEDICAL EVIDENTIARY EXAMS A
SEXUAL ASSAULT VICTIMS. SO
SPEAKING PLAINLY IF YOU HAVE
BEEN SEXUALLY ASSAULTED THEN YOU
WILL COME INTO THE HOSPITAL AND
SEE EITHER A SPECIALIST THAT'S A
SAFER SAME PROVIDER OR ANOTHER
PROVIDER LIKE MYSELF WHO HAS
BEEN TRAINED IN THE PROPER WAY
TO DO THESE EXAMS COLLECT THE
FORENSIC EVIDENCE AND SURE THAT
THE PATIENT IS GIVEN ACCESS TO
MEDICATIONS SOCIAL WORK AND
OTHER RESOURCES. THAT THEY MAY
NEED PRIOR TO BEING DISCHARGED.
THIS IS NOT THE CASE FOR MOST
VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. TO
ADDRESS THIS IN FEBRUARY OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. SAN DIEGO
COUNTY IMPLEMENT A COUNTY WIDE
PILOT PROGRAM WITH AN ON CALL
FORENSIC NURSE EXAMINER TO
DOCUMENT STRANGULATION AND OTHER
INJURIES FROM DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
ASSAULT. FROM TWENTY SEVENTEEN
TO TWENTY TWENTY THE PILOT
PROGRAM RESULTED IN MORE EXAMS
BEING CONDUCTED AND A 15%
DECREASE IN DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
HOMICIDES SINCE THE START OF THE
PILOT PROGRAM. AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY FIVE WOULD EXPAND THIS
NECESSARY TREATMENT FOR VICTIMS
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE STATEWIDE.
IT INCREASES A STATEWIDE FUNDING
STREAM THROUGH THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES TO REIMBURSE
PROVIDERS FOR THOSE CONDUCTING
MEDICAL EVIDENTIARY EXAMS FOR
DEMANDS FOR VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. IT WILL HELP EXPAND
ACCESS TO MEDICAL EVIDENTIARY
EXAMS WHICH WILL BRING ABOUT
EARLY DETECTION AND INTERVENTION
WHICH ULTIMATELY HAS BEEN PROVEN
TO SAVE LIVES AND INCREASE
FAMILY SAFETY AND WELLNESS. IN
ADDITION LOCAL SEXUAL ASSAULT
RESPONSE TEAMS SEXUAL ASSAULT
FORENSIC EXAMINER TEAMS AND
OTHER QUALIFIED MEDICAL
EVIDENTIARY EXAMINERS WILL
PERFECT WILL DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT BREAST PRACTICE
WRITTEN POLICIES AND PROCEDURES
FOR MAINTAINING PATIENT
CONFIDENTIALITY. THIS BILL IS
SPONSORED BY THE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE AND SUPPORTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS AND POLICE OFFCER
RESEARCH ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA. HERE TO SPEAK WITH
ME TODAY IS TRACI PRIOR CHIEF
DEPUTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY SAN
DIEGO COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE AND MICHELLE SOARES A
CALIFORNIA SEXUAL ASSAULT
FORENSIC EXAMINER ASSOCIATION
NURSE THANK YOU. THANK YOU MY
NAME IS TRACY PRIOR I'M A CHIEF
DEPUTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY IN SAN
DIEGO AND HAS SERVED AS A AS A
PUBLIC PROSECUTOR FOR TWENTY
FIVE YEARS OUR DISTRICT ATTORNEY
SUMMER STEPHAN IS A PROUD
SPONSOR OF AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
FIVE. MANY YEARS AGO I HEARD A
PHRASE THAT STUCK WITH ME. IN
THE PRESENCE OF VIOLENCE ONE
CANNOT ACHIEVE HEALTH. I HAVE
SEEN THE AFTERMATH THAT SERIOUS
SEXUAL AND PHYSICAL ASSAULT HAS
HAD ON THE VICTIMS OF VIOLENCE.
AND HAVE SEEN THE DIFFERENCE
THAT QUALITY HEALTH AND
SPECIFICALLY A FORENSIC MEDICAL
EXAMINATION CAN HAVE TO HELP A
VICTIM PROGRESS FROM BEING A
SURVIVOR TO A THRIVE ARE. IN A
FORENSIC MEDICAL EXAMINATION
ESPECIALLY TRAINED NURSE OR
DOCTOR EXAMINES A PATIENT WHO'S
EXPERIENCED VIOLENCE THEY
PROVIDE MEDICAL TREATMENT THE
DOCUMENT INJURIES AND THEY
CONNECT THAT INDIVIDUAL TO LOCAL
SOCIAL SERVICES AND DEVELOP A
SAFETY PLAN TOGETHER. THESE
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS ARE
UNIQUELY TRAINED IN THE
NEUROBIOLOGY OF TRAUMA AND BEST
UNDERSTAND THE PSYCHOOGICAL AND
SOCIAL PRESSURES THE IMPACT
PATIENTS AFFECTED BY VIOLENCE.
THESE EXAMINATIONS HAVE BEEN
DEEMED THE GOLD STANDARD IN THE
FIELD. THE PROBLEM IS THAT
CURRENTLY ONLY SEXUAL ASSAULT
RAPE VICTIMS ARE LEGALLY
ENTITLED TO THESE EXAMINATIONS
FREE OF CHARGE. DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE VICTIMS EACH DAY IN
CALIFORNIA EXPERIENCED SERIOUS
VIOLENCE ON THEIR OWN BUT
THEY'RE NOT NECESSARILY SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED AND THEY DON'T GET ANY
ACCESS TO THIS GOLD STANDARD
MEDICAL EXAMINATION WE CAN DO
BETTER. DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
VICTIMS ARE STRANGLED EVERY YEAR
WHICH IS ASSOCIATED WITH A SEVEN
TIMES HIGHER LIKELIHOOD OF THEM
BEING MURDERED BY THEIR ABUSER
YET THESE VICTIMS DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO A FREE MEDICAL
EXAMINATION WE SHOULD DO BETTER
. RECENTLY IN TWENTY SIXTEEN OR
LEGISLATOR PUT AN EXCLAMATION
POINT RIGHT IN FRONT OF US WHEN
IT DECLARED THE PROTECTION OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE VICTIMS QUOTE
HAS BEEN HAMPERED BY THE LACK OF
CONSISTENT AND COMPREHENSIVE
MEDICAL EXAMINATIONS. THIS BILL
WOULD MAKE US BETTER. THE BILL
PROVIDES EQUAL ACCESS FOR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE VICTIMS
ESPECIALLY THOSE HAVE BEEN
STRANGLED. AND THEY BRING
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE VICTIMS ON PAR
WITH VICTIMS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
AND THIS TRULY IS A PREVENTATIVE
PUBLIC HEALTH APPROACH TO PUBLIC
SAFETY. MY COUNTY RECOGNIZE THIS
GAP IN TWENTY SIXTEEN WE KNEW
THERE WERE SPECIALIZED MEDICAL
FORMS ALREADY DESIGNED TO TREAT
THESE HEALTH EXAMS WE KNEW THERE
WERE SPECIALLY TRAINED HEALTH
CARE PROFESSIONALS STANDING AT
THE READY TO PERFORM THEM. BUT
THERE WAS NO FUNDING AND NO
MANDATE IN THE LAW FOR THEM. SO
WE APPLIED FOR A CAL OH YES
STATE GRANT TO PILOT A PROGRAM
TO SEE IF IT WOULD WORK. AFTER
ALL THAT IS THE PURPOSE OF
GRANTS ISN'T IT TO TRY SOMETHING
INNOVATIVE AND SMART AND THEN
SEEK SUSTAINABLE FUNDING AND
LEGISLATIVE SOLUTIONS IF IT
TRULY MAKES A DIFFERENCE TO OUR
COMMUNITY. WE ROLLED OUT THE
PROGRAM IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND
NOW A SPECIALLY TRAINED FORENSIC
NURSE RESPONSE TWENTY FOUR SEVEN
TO SERIOUS DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND
STRANGULATION CALLS. TO DATE
WE'VE DONE A THOUSAND OF THESE
EXAMINATIONS AND OUR OUTCOMES
HAVE SAVED LIVES. WE'VE SEEN A
15% DECREASE IN DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE HOMICIDES AND AN 11%
REDUCTION IN STRANGULATION TO
BEING THE METHOD USED IN
HOMICIDES WHEN COMPARING THE
YEARS BEFORE THE PROGRAM. AND
AFTER. MY COLLEAGUE WILL SHARE
THE STORY OF A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
VICTIM WHO HAD A FRACTURED
LARYNX BUT WOULD NEVER WOULD
HAVE KNOWN IT AND COULD HAVE
DIED BUT FOR THE FACT THAT SHE
HAD ACCESS. TO THIS FORENSIC
MEDICAL EXAMINATION. THE NUMBERS
IN THE STORIES AND SAN DIEGO ARE
IMPORTANT BUT TAKING A STEP BACK
THIS BILL IS SIMPLY ABOUT
ACCESS. SEXUAL ASSAULT VICTIMS
IN CALIFORNIA GET IMPORTANT AN
LIFESAVING HEALTHCARE FOR FREE
BUT VICTIMS OF SERIOUS DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE DO NOT. IT'S TIME TO
CHANGE THAT. I STRONGLY
RECOMMEND YOU PASSED TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY FIVE OUT OF COMMITTEE
TODAY IN DOING SO YOU'LL CHAU
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND
STRANGULATION VICTIMS THAT THEIR
HEALTH AND THEIR SAFETY. DESERVE
AN A PLUS RESPONSE FROM ALL OF
US THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN. AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS MICHELLE SHORES. I'VE
BEEN A NURSE A REGISTERED NURSE
FOR OVER SIXTEEN YEARS I'M ALSO
A CERTIFIED EMERGENCY NURSE A
PEDIATRIC ADOLESCENT AND- ADULT
SEXUAL SALTS CERTIFIED NURSE AND
ACTIVISM INNER- I COME TO YOU
TODAY I AM THE DIRECTOR OF OUR
LOCAL PROGRAM HERE IN SAN DIEGO
WHICH GAVE ME A DEEP
UNDERSTANDING OF THE NEED A-
NEED FOR THESE EXAMS. BUT ALSO-
AS A BOARD MEMBER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA SEXUAL ASSAULT
FORENSIC EXAMINER ASSOCIATION
THAT. AND IT'S BEEN AN HONOR IN
MY CAREER TO SERVE THE MOST
VULNERABLE OF OUR POPULATION I
HAVE SEEN FIRST HAND WHAT TRAUMA
CAN DO BUT I'VE ALSO WITNESSED
WHEN A COMMUNITY COMES TOGETHER
WHAT TRAUMA INFORMED CARE AND
WRAPAROUND SERVICES CAN DO TO
SAVE LIVES. YOU KNOW AS A HEALTH
CARE PROVIDER I HAVE A DUTY AND
OBLIGATION TO ADVOCATE FOR MY
PATIENTS HEALTH AND SAFETY. AND
UNEQUAL ACCESS TO THESE EXAMS
FOR VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
HAS REALLY BEEN A CHALLENGE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND I'D
LIKE TO SHARE WITH YOU A STORY
THAT I HAVE CONSENT PERMISSION
TO SHARE FROM ONE OF OUR
PATIENTS AND I THINK OF HER
OFTEN. WHEN WE KNOW BETTER WE
CAN DO BETTER. AND BECAUSE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY HAS THAT PROCESS IN
PLACE FOR THE MEDICAL
EVIDENTIARY EXAMS. THIS IS
AVAILABLE TO OUR COUNTY WE HAD A
PATIENT THAT WAS ODD STRANGLED
IN OUR COUNTY FLED TO AN OUTSIDE
COUNTY. WHERE SHE WAS OT GIVEN
ACCESS TO MEDICAL EVIDENTIARY
EXAM. THEREFORE CAME BACK TO OUR
COUNTY AFTER SAFETY MEASURES
WERE IN PLACE. WAS OFFERED ONE
WHERE OUR NURSE- ASSESSED HER
AND RECOGNIZED SERIOUS
STRANGULATION- SYMPTOMS. THEY
HAVE NO VISIBLE INJURY. SHE WAS
RECOMMENDED TO GET FURTHER CARE
AND HAD A FRACTURED LENNIX. SHE
CAME TO ME AND ASKED FOR SOMEONE
THAT'S HAD THEIR VOICE BOX
BROKEN TO HAVE HER VOICE HEARD.
HAD THIS BEEN AVAILABLE IN THAT
OTHER COUNTY WITHOUT SPECIALIZED
TEAM THAT MIGHT HAVE BEEN AN
IMMEDIATE RESPONSE THAT WOULD
HAVE SAVED HER. HENSCHEL LETHAL
OUTCOMES SIX DAYS LATER AFTER WE
SAW HER. SO I COME TO YOU TODAY
ASKING KNOWING THAT DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE FOR CHILDREN WITNESSING
IN THE HOME KNOWING INCREASE FOR
A SCORES AND PUTTING THIS UP
FRONT RESPONSE ACCESS TO VICTIMS
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS OUR DUTY
AS HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS
INFRASTRUCTURE EXISTS AND I'D I
RECOMMEND AND I VOTE FROM THIS
COMMITTEE AND I THINK YOU ALL
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY. THANK YOU-
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN. THE
HEARING ROOM. SEEING NONE WE GO
TO THE PHONE LINES WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. OF AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
FIVE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. ONCE AGAIN PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE SPELL.
WE GO TO LINE FORTY EIGHT. SURE
NUMBERS ONE SHERMAN WITH THE
RESEARCHER SUFFICIENT SUPPORT
ALONG WITH THE POLICE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION OF ARCADIA BURBANK
CLAREMONT CHRONICLE OVER CITY
FULLERTON EAGLE WOULD LA SCHOOL
REPORT BEACH CAL POLY POMONA
RIVERSIDE AND I AM A UP WHEN
PLASTERED YES THEY. OWN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. BY TWO A- GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MARIA SPERBER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITALIZATION I'D
LIKE TO TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
THANK THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE-
WORKING WITH US ON THE WE DO- WE
COME TO AN AGREEMENT ON METAL
AND WE REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION. BY
TWO SIXTY ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHEN MEMBERS THIS IS JIM
LINDBERG I'M CALLING THIS
AFTERNOON ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA TO VOICE
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL THANK YOU. SURE THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO
SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH TO SPEAK IT
WILL BRING BACK TO ROOM FOR THE
PEOPLE THERE IN OPPOSITION TO.
AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY FIVE- I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR IN THE
COMMITTEE FOR TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS AND SAMARCO GEORGE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND WE
WERE MOVING OR OPPOSITION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. CNN
ARE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION THEIR ON LINE
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR YOU CAN
OPEN UP THE PHONE LINE. THOSE
WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. MR
CHERNOBYL THE SIGNAL THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK TO BRING ABOUT TWO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MOVED THE BILL
LACKEY AT THE MOTION. SECOND IS
SECOND BUT AND I ALSO WOULD LIKE
TO THANK MEDICAL DOCTOR WEBER.
FOR BEING AN ADVOCATE FOR
VICTIMS ORIENTED- SET OF
CIRCUMSTANCES IT'S VERY VERY
EXCITING TO SEE THIS KIND OF
FOCUS YOU KNOW TRAUMA INFORMED
KERR IS IRREPLACEABLE AND OFTEN
THE DAMAGES ARE RECOVERABLE SO A
VERY VERY THANKFUL FOR THIS-
THIS PROPOSAL IT MAKES A LOT OF
GOOD SENSE I AM VERY GRATEFUL.
SO THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE. BONTA
AS THE ONLY WOMAN ON THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE. I WANT TO
THANK AT DR WEBBER FOR BRINGING
FORWARD THIS LEGISLATION THAT
ESSENTIALLY ALLOWS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR WOMEN WHO ARE IN
A DOMESTIC RELATIONSHIP AND
PEOPLE WHO ARE DOMESTIC
RELATIONSHIP TO RECEIVE THE SAME
RIGHT OF CARE AND PROTECTION AS
THOSE WHO ARE NOT. THANK YOU. Q.
AND ANY OTHER. OKAY YOU MAKE
CLOSE. WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'D
LIKE TO THANK MY WITNESSES THAT
CAME UP HERE FROM SAN DIEGO
TODAY- TO JUST HIGHLIGHT THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS BILL AND
DONNA THANK ALL THOSE WHO CALLED
IN AND SUPPORT DISTINCT
INCLUSION- ACCESS TO THESE EXAMS
WILL EXPAND OUR JUSTICE FOR
SURVIVORS AND TRULY SAVE LIVES
AND SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE ON AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
FIVE. THANK YOU- AS CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE WOULD. WIDGET
COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS ALMOST
PRIMARILY FEMALE WE ALSO THANK
YOU. FOR BRINGING THIS FOR PORT
A COLORABLE. ON AB TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY FIVE BY SEVEN MEMBER
WEBER THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
AS AMENDED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER HI JONES
SAWYER HI LACKEY LACKEY HI BONTA
BONTA HI BRIAN BRIAN I WORK I
WORK AYE SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO I
SEYARTO THEY ARE TOO HIGH. THE
MEASURE PASSES. THIS DAVIES AB
TWENTY FOUR OH NINE THE LAST ONE
OF THE DAY. MOVE THE BILL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TODAY I'M HERE
TO PRESENT AB TWO FOUR OH NINE
AT FIRST I WANT TO THANK
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING WITH
MY STAFF AND STAKEHOLDERS AND
RECENT AMENDMENTS. UNDER CURRENT
LAW YOU KNOW COLD THIRTY FORTY
THREE A VICTIM OF A CRIME OR THE
VICTIMS NEXT OF KIN HAS A RIGHT
TO ATTEND THE INMATE'S PAROLE
HEARING WITH THE DESIGNATED
REPRESENTATIVE IF THEIR CONTACT
INFORMATION IS ON FILE THE
BORDER PRO HEARING WILL PROVIDE
THE NOTICE IN ADVANCE OF THE
HEARING. HOWEVER GIVEN THE
PASSAGE OF TIME ANY INFORMATION
IS USUALLY OUT OF DATE INSTEAD
THE PROSECUTING AGENCY WHICH IS
ALSO NOTIFIED IS IN THE BEST
POSITION TO CONTACT VICTIMS OR
THEIR FAMILIES USING DMV RECORDS
AND DATABASE. MOST ALREADY DO
BUT IT'S NOT A LEGAL REQUIREMENT
UNFORTUNATELY IF THE PROSECUTING
AGENCY CHOOSES TO ABSENT ITSELF
FROM THE PROCESS VICTIMS OR
THEIR FAMILIES ARE LEFT IN THE
DARK AS TO THE INMATES CONDUCT
WHILE IN PRISON AND THE
LIKELIHOOD OF RELEASE WHICH
COMPLICATES DECISION TO TEN OR
WHAT KIND OF STATEMENT TO MAKE.
AB TWO FOUR OH NINE IT'S A
SIMPLE MEASURE TO CODIFY THE
PRACTICE OF ENSURING DISTRICT
ATTORNEY OFFICES NOTIFY VICTIMS
OR VICTIMS NEXT OF KIN ABOUT
UPCOMING PAROLE HEARINGS. AS
WE'RE ALL AWARE OF THE LEGAL
SYSTEM IS FAR FROM PERFECT AND
CREATES MANY BARRIERS FOR
JUSTICE ENSURING WE HELP VICTIMS
UNDERSTAND THE PRO PROCESS. AND
THE RIGHTS TO HELP FIND CLOSURE
AND WHAT ARE MOST TIMES VERY
TRAUMATIZING EVENTS. IN THEIR
LIFE AGAIN MEMBERS THIS IS
STRICTLY JUST NOTIFICATION BILL
IT DOES NOT REQUIRE ANY MANDATE
TO THE DA. TO GET INVOLVED IN
PRO PROCESS IT MERELY JUST
REQUIRES THEM TO NOTIFY THE
VICTIM ABOUT A PAROLE HEARING.
WITH ME HERE TODAY VIA PHONE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS IS ATTORNEY
JOHN MCKINNEY I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. JOHN
MCKINNEY READY TO TESTIFY.
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATE OPEN UP LINE. ERARD MISTER CHIP. PLEASE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS JOHN MCKINNEY I'M A
DEPUTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY I WANT TO MAKE IT
CLEAR THAT I'M SPEAKING FOR
MYSELF TODAY MY OPINION DOES NOT
REPRESENT THE VIEWS OF OUR
OFFICE OR OF THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY- WE COME BEFORE YOU
TODAY. ASKING YOU TO SUPPORT AB
TWO PORT THERE ARE NINE WHICH
WAS INSPIRED. BY THE DEATH OF A
YOUNG MAN WHOSE CASES ARE
PROSECUTED. YOUNG MARQUIS FOR
BLOCK WAS EIGHTEEN YEARS OLD
HE'S AN AFRICAN AMERICAN TEEN.
THE ATTENDED A PARTY IN THE CITY
OF POMONA. NUMBER KNOWN TO HIM
THERE WAS A GAME OR SEVERAL GANG
MEMBERS PRESIDENT THERE WHO HAD
A PARTICULAR DISLIKE FOR AFRICAN
AMERICANS. IT WAS TARGETED FROM
THE MOMENT HE WALKED AND-
EVENTUALLY HE WAS CHASED DOWN
BEATEN. STABBED THROUGH THE
HEART AND SHOT IN THE HEAD. WE
PROSECUTED TEN PEOPLE FOR THAT
KILLING. SIX WERE CONVICTED OF
MURDER. HIS MOTHER ATTENDED FOUR
SEPARATE TRIALS COULD COVER ALL
OF THE DEFENDANTS. AND AT NO
TIME DID SHE EVER WANT TO SEE
PICTURES OF COURSE HAN. LAYING
IN THE STREET UNCLAD BLEEDING-
RECENTLY THE FIRST OF THE
CONVICTED- DESCENDANTS BECAME
ELIGIBLE FOR PAROLE AFTER JUST
ELEVEN YEARS IN CUSTODY AFTER
BEING CONVICTED OF SECOND DEGREE
MURDER. SHE DID NOT GET NOTICE
FROM THE PAROLE BOARD. OUR
OFFICE ACTUALLY REACHED OUT TO
ME ABOUT A WEEK BEFORE THE
HEARING AND BECAUSE I HAD HER
NUMBER OF MY CELL PHONE I WAS
ABLE TO CONTACT HER. BUT SHE WAS
FRANTIC SHE WAS CONFUSION WITH
THE WILDER SHE THOUGHT THAT THE
DEFENDANT WAS GONNA SERVE AT
LEAST FIFTEEN YEARS. AND TO ADD
INSULT TO INJURY I HAD TO TELL
HER THAT OUR OFFICE WOULD NOT BE
PARTICIPATING IN THE PAROLE
HEARING. SO IN A VERY SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME SHE DID
EVERYTHING SHE COULD TO TRY TO
PREPARE HERSELF INCLUDING.
REQUESTING ALL OF THE POLICE
REPORTS AND PHOTOGRAPHS REPORTS
. WHICH SHE LAID EYES ON FOR THE
FIRST TIME. SHE WENT TO THE
PAROLE HEARING- ALONE. IN THE
PAROLE BOARD GRANTED PAROLE. SHE
WAS DEVASTATED SHE WAS
HOSPITALIZED TWICE SHORTLY AFTER
THE HEARING SHE FELT THAT THE
HEARING WAS UNFAIR. SO AB TWO
FOUR ZERO NINE WOULD ADDRESS A
COUPLE OF THINGS- MOST
IMPORTANTLY IT SUPPORTS
TRANSPARENCY IN THE PROCESS. IF
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY OR THE
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE PEOPLE
REFUSES TO BE PRESENT THEN
CERTAINLY- VICTIMS HAVE A RIGHT
TO KNOW THAT THE HEARING IS
HAPPENING APPLE RIGHT TO BE
PRESENT TO PARTICIPATE IF THEY
CHOOSE TO. UNDER CURRENT LAW.
THERE REALLY IS NO THERE IS NO
MANDATE FOR DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
TO NOTIFY VICTIMS AND THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY IS IN THE BEST
POSITION TO DO IT. IN THE CASE
OF MARKIEFF WILL BLOCK AND HIS
MOTHER JUST COOKED TODAY
ILLUSTRATE THAT. BECAUSE WE WORK
SO CLOSELY WITH VICTIMS AND
THEIR FAMILIES MANY OF US
PROSECUTORS HAVE PERSONAL
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE VICTIMS.
AND EVEN IF THEIR RECORDS BECOME
OUTDATED IN OUR FILES OFTENTIMES
WE WILL STILL HAVE CON TO
CONTACT THEM. I WILL I WILL
POINT OUT ONE THING ABOUT MY
CURRENT BOSS TO DISTRICT
ATTORNEY MISTER GASTON WE ALL
KNOW THAT. ARE THE REASON WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THIS NOTICE
REQUIREMENT IS BECAUSE OF HIS
DECISION TO ABSENT HIMSELF OUR
OFFICE FROM THE HEARING. IN HIS
WRITTEN DIRECTIVE HE WRITES
QUOTE. THIS OFFICE WILL CONTINUE
TO MEET ITS OBLIGATION TO NOTIFY
IN IT BY THE VICTIMS UNDER
CALIFORNIA LAW. IN A COMMITTED
TO A PROCESS OF HEALING AND
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE FOR ALL
CLICK. UNCLE STRUGGLING AGAIN
I'M NOT SPEAKING FOR THE DELAY
BUT THAT IT'S IN HIS WRITTEN
POLICY WHERE IT APPEARED HE
ASSUMES THAT CALIFORNIA LAW
ALREADY REQUIRES THIS TYPE OF
NOTICE- SO DESPITE HIS DECISION
NOT TO PARTICIPATE IN NEEDS
HEARING IT DOES APPEAR THAT HE
SUPPORTS A NOTICE REQUIREMENTS.
ALL RIGHT WITHOUT NOTICES NO
RIGHT AT ALL AND SO OF ALL THE
RESULT STATE TRANSPARENCY
RESPECT FOR VICTIMS SUPPORT FOR
VICTIMS. UNDERSTANDING THAT.
THERE'S NOTHING MORE
TRAUMATIZING THAN HEARING AFTER
THE FACT. THAT SOMEONE WHO
KILLED A CLOSE LOVED ONE IS
BEING PAROLED AND YOU DIDN'T
EVEN KNOW THAT THE HEARING WAS
HAPPENING. I THINK VICTIMS
DESERVE THIS NOTICE THEY DESERVE
THE RIGHT TO MAKE THE DECISION
ABOUT WHETHER TO ATTEND OR NOT.
WHETHER WHETHER TO SUBMIT A
LETTER OR NOT. THEY DESERVE THE
RIGHT TO GATHER OTHER FAMILY AND
FRIENDS WHO WILL PARTICIPATE.
AND THAT'S ALL THIS IS A VERY
MODEST REQUESTS I THINK IT
DOVETAILS NICELY WITH A B.
EIGHTEEN FORTY SIX WHICH WAS
DISCUSSED EARLIER. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. AND ARE
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IN THE ROOM. ANY
WITNESSES TO SUPPORT ONLINE.
TELEPHONE OVER A TELEPHONE LINE
. TO HIS CHAIR FOR THOSE WHO
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO PRESS
ONE THERE ARE. MISTER CHAIR NO
ONE IS SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK. GARY ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME'S KEITH WIDELY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF UNCOMMON
LAW- WE REMAIN OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL- I HAVE PERSONALLY
PARTICIPATED IN HUNDREDS. OF
PAROLE HEARINGS- I HAVE
PERSONALLY WITNESSED THEM- THIS
BILL ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY
INVOLVE SURVIVORS OF VIOLENT
CRIME I'VE SEEN THEM BE RE
TRAUMATIZED BY THIS PROCESS OVER
AND OVER AGAIN- AND I'VE I'VE
STUDIED THOUSANDS OF HEARING
TRANSCRIPTS- AND SEEING THIS
DISPLAY A MAY TIMES. AND
IMPORTANT PORTENT CLARIFICATION
I NEED TO MAKE- YOU KNOW FROM
FROM A GOOD DISCUSSION WE HAD
EARLIER THIS IS ABOUT- MARSY'S
LAW AND- IT ACTUALLY EXPANDS THE
DEFINITION OF VICTIMS AND IT'S
IMPORTANT WE'RE CLEAR ABOUT THAT
. BECAUSE IT INCLUDES THE SPOUSE
PARENTS CHILDREN SIBLINGS
GUARDIAN AND A REPRESENTATIVE OF
THE PERSON ACTUALLY DIRECTLY
HARPER BACKGROUND ALL OF THEM
ARE INCLUDED AS DEFINITE BY
DEFINITION. AS VICTIMS. AND
UNDER THE OTHER BILL WE
DISCUSSED EIGHTEEN FORTY SIX
EACH ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE COULD
HIRE AN ATTORNEY. FOR THE TO
SHOP AT A PAROLE HEARING EACH
ONE OF THEM. SOME OF THE
SUPPORT- THAT THAT- HAS BEEN
OFFERED FOR TWENTY FOUR NUYS
BASED ON THIS THE ASSERTED NEED
TO SUPPORT- VICTIMS AND I
CERTAINLY- DON'T HAVE ANY
PROBLEM WITH THAT HOWEVER- THIS
EFFORT TO- REQUIRE ADDITIONAL
NOTICE IT'S DUPLICATIVE BECAUSE-
THE BILL IS ASSIGNING THE DA
RESPONSIBILITIES ARE ALREADY
HELD BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS. THEY HAVE ISN'T AN
OFFICE OF VICTIMS AND SURVIVORS
RIGHTS AND SERVICES THAT'S
ALREADY OBLIGATED TO PROVIDE
THESE NOTICES- THEY PROVIDE THEM
AT LEAST NINETY DAYS BEFORE THE
HEARINGS- AND ALL SURVIVORS NEED
TO DO IS REGISTER- WITH THE
BOARD TO GET THOSE
NOTIFICATIONS- MOREOVER JUST
LAST YEAR. CCR GOT AN ADDITIONAL
ONE POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS
TO HIRE ADDITIONAL STAFF TO DO
THIS VERY THING. TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL NOTICE- TWO SURVIVORS
OF THE CRIMES OF THAT THE PROBE
WAS BEING CONSIDERED- THE OTHER
POINT I MAKE IS THAT. TWENTY
FOUR NINE- I JUST DON'T THINK IT
RELEASED SUPPORT SURVIVORS-
BECAUSE AS WE INDICATED REQUIRES
THE A TO- REACH OUT TO ALL
SURVIVORS EVEN IF THEY'VE CHOSEN
TO HAVE NOTHING TO DO FURTHER
WITH THIS PROCESS NOTHING TO DO
WITH THE PERSON WHO CAUSED THEM
HARM OR THE CRIME BECAUSE THE
MARK- AND IN FACT MOST CRIME
SURVIVORS CHOOSE NOT TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROCESS- I
THINK IT'S BECAUSE OF CONCERNS
ABOUT TRIGGERING THE PAST HARMS
BASS DRUM- AND IT'S A PROCESS
THAT PROVIDES NO ACCESS TO
HEALING. I THINK THIS CHOICE HAS
TO BE RESPECTED- WHAT THIS BILL
WOULD DO IS IT WOULD FORCE THEM
TO BE A PART OF A HARMFUL
PROCESS SOLELY AT THE WHIM. OF
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO CAPITALIZE
OFF THEIR RAW EMOTION. TO
DISTRACT PAROLE COMMISSIONERS
FROM THERE NOT JUST THE PRIMARY
THIS SOLE RESPONSIBILITY. AS THE
CONSIDER SOMEONE'S CURRENT RISK
PUBLIC SAFETY- AND SO FOR THAT
REASON WE STRONGLY URGE A NO
VOTE ON TWENTY FOUR NINE. JAMES
GEORGE. THREE SHAPING AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS- AND MARCO GEORGE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION I WOULD
ECHO THE COMMENTS THAT MR WILEY
SAID- BUT ALSO I WOULD SAY AS
SOMEONE WHO HAS BEEN ASSAULTED
AND I DON'T THINK THAT BAPTISM
COMMON THAT- VERY LARGE
PERCENTAGE OF WOMEN IN THE FIVE
HAVE BEEN- AB TWENTY FOUR OH
NINE. DOES NOT HAVE ANY KIND OF
EITHER OFTEN OR OPT OUT OF THE
NOTIFICATION PROCESS. AND
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T- IT WILL
ACTUALLY HARM AND RECALL THE
TIME SOME PEOPLE. FOR VICTIMS
WHO ELECTED NOT TO BE CONTACTED
BE BY CDC. THEY'LL STILL BE
CONTACTED BY THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY UNDER THIS BILL FOR
VICTIMS WHO WISH TO FORGET. FOR
VICTIMS WHO HAVE SOUGHT TO
REBUILD THEIR LIVES. FOR VICTIMS
WHO HAVE UNDERGONE COUNSELING
AND DECIDED TO CLOSE THE DOOR
COMPARTMENTALIZE WHAT HAPPENED.
THERE'S NO NO WAY FOR THEM IN
THIS BILL THE SITE PLEASE DON'T
CONTACT ME ANYMORE AND FOR THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY TWO FIVE BY
THEIR WISHES FOR THEM FROM THE
BEGINNING TO SAY I DON'T WANT TO
BE INVOLVED IN THIS PROCESS. SO
I RESPECTFULLY ON BEHALF OF C.
P. A. ASK FOR YOUR NUMBER. THANK
YOU. NOW GO TO THE PHONE THIRTY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. I
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR COULD OPEN
UP BLIND. FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME PRESS
ONE AND ZERO. MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE SEVERAL PEOPLE SIGNALED
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK ONE
MOMENT.
WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO SIXTY TWO.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
GREGORY FIDEL ON BEHALF OF
INITIATE JUSTICE AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. ONE TWO
SIXTY THREE. JIM WEINBERG-
BEHALF OF THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA
ALSO IN OPPOSITION. MISTER CHAIR
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE PARDON ME
THAT ONE ADDITIONAL. LINE EIGHTY
TWO TWO HUNDRED THIRTY UPON
RETURNING ON BEHALF OF SOME
BREAKING UP WITH HIM ALL AND
PROJECT AMIGA IN OPPOSITION THE
CHIEF. MISTER CHAIR THERE IS NO
ONE ELSE IS SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH
TO SPEAK THANK YOU BRING ABOUT
TO COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
BONTA ANIMUS TO CORK THIS TWO
ZERO THE FIRST IS- IF A VICTIM
IS ALREADY A CONTACTED AS
REQUIRED BY. OVS R. S. WHAT IS
THE- PROBLEM THAT WE ARE TRYING
TO SOLVE BY ALSO REQUIRING THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY TO. ALSO
INITIATE THAT NOTICE AND THEN I
JUST AS A PRACTICAL MATTER- FOR
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY- TO
RECEIVE THAT NOTICE HOW WOULD IT
NEXT OF KIN IN PARTICULAR. THAT
NO TO REGISTER OR PARTICIPATE IN
THE REGISTRATION PROCESS- AND
GIVE THAT TO MISTER MCKINNEY FOR
ME. OKAY THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THAT. AB
TWO FOUR OH NINE DID NOT
DUPLICATE THE EXISTING NOTICE
REQUIREMENT I THINK WHAT NEEDS
TO BE UNDERSTOOD ABOUT THE GOOD
THING NOTICE REQUIREMENT IS. IT
REQUIRED AN OPT IN PROVISION
VICTIMS HAVE TO NOTIFY THE
BORDER PATROL THAT THEY WISH TO
RECEIVE FUTURE NOTICE THE BORDER
PATROL THEN SEND AN APPLICATION
TO THE VICTIM THAT THEY FILL OUT
AND THEN HAVE TO RETURN. SO
ALTHOUGH MOST ABOUT IT IF NOT IF
DE PROCESS WE KNOW THAT A LOT OF
OUR VICTIMS ARE NOT YET
SOPHISTICATED. AND ALTHOUGH THEY
WANT THE NOTICE ARE NOT IN THE
BEST POSITION TO FOLLOW THROUGH
WITH THAT PROCESS. AND EVEN IF
THEY DO OFTENTIMES THESE
HEARINGS WILL COME UP OVER A
DECADE AFTER THE REGISTER. WE
KNOW THAT WE HAVE POPULATIONS
THAT ARE VERY TRANSITORY SO THEY
MOVED AROUND A LOT. THEY CHANGED
THEIR PHONE NUMBERS ALL. AND
ONCE THAT HAPPENED THE BORDER
PATROL WILL BE IN A VERY-
DISADVANTAGES POSITION TO REACH
OUT TO THE- FOLKS. DISTRICT
ATTORNEY BUT THAT'S GENERALLY
ARE IN THE BEST POSITION TO DO
THAT AND THERE'S NOTHING WRONG
WITH THE PROCESS THAT DUPLICATE
ABOVE NOTICE THAT'S ALL WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT NOBODY'S BEEN
CRAFTED INTO PARTICIPATING. IN
THE HEARING IT'S JUST NOTICED
THAT THE HEARING IS HAPPENING.
ARE THERE ALSO BEEN A LOT OF NEW
LAW- THAT HAD ME PEOPLE WHO WERE
PREVIOUSLY INELIGIBLE FOR PAROLE
ELIGIBLE FOR PAROLE. WE'VE GOT A
LOT OF NEW LAWS THAT ALLOW
CREDITS FOR PEOPLE WHO SERVING
TIME FOR MURDER WHERE VICTIMS
MAY NOT EXPECT THAT A PAROLE
HEARING IS GOING TO HAPPEN.
FOURTEEN YEARS AND BECAUSE OF
CREDIT THAT ARE BEING- NOW
AGAINST A MURDER CONVICTION IN
TOTAL HEARING TO HAPPEN NOT
HAPPENING A LOT SOONER. AND
WITHOUT DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
REACHING OUT TO THEM DALY MAY
VERY WELL FIND OUT THAT SOMEBODY
IS PAROLED WHEN THEY SEE THEM IN
THE SUPERMARKET. WHERE THEY SEE
THE MEDIC STATE. AND OUR NO
THAT'S NOT WE WANT I DON'T THINK
IT'S FAIR MINDED PEOPLE. ONE
OTHER QUESTION. JUST A FOLLOW UP
I'M NOT REALLY UNDERSTANDING HOW
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY WOULD BE
IN ANY BETTER POSITION THAN
OVERLY THAN THAT- THE SRS TO-
ACTUALLY HAVE ACCESS TO. THAT
INFORMATION FROM THAT VICTIMS OR
AT THE NEXT OF KIN AFTER TIME
DELAY SO FOR THAT REASON I'M
GOING TO BE VOTING NO ON THIS.
MAGRIS THAT BRIEFLY. I'VE I'VE
PROSECUTED FORTY MURDER TRIALS I
PROBABLY HAVE THIRTY VICTIMS
FAMILIES OF MYSELF ALL. I TALKED
TO SOME OF MY VICTIMS NOT ALL
FORTY BUT I KEEP UP WITH ABOUT
TEN FAMILIES REGULARLY THEY
CALLED ME WE TALK ABOUT THINGS
YOU KNOW THAT ARE NOT RELATED TO
THE CASE. WE HAVE FILES IN OUR
FILES WE HAVE NOT ONLY THE
VICTIM BUT WE HAVE. OTHER
WITNESSES WHO KNOW THE VICTIM WE
HAVE. A PLETHORA OF INFORMATION
IN OUR FILES THAT WILL ALLOW US
TO FIND SOMEONE. EASIER MUCH
EASIER THEN THE BORDER PATROL'S.
BORDER POLL WOULD HAVE I MEAN
ALL THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE THIS
AT ONE TIME REGISTRATION
INFORMATION- SO YOU KNOW THERE'S
REALLY NO PROBLEM WITH THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY. MEETING FOR
REASONABLE EFFORTS DISCUSS ALL
THIS BILL REQUIRES AND
REASONABLE EFFORTS TO REACH OUT
AND FIND SOME EXCEPTION. THANK
YOU RIGHT OR VISIT PURPOSE TO
QUIRK WHO BETTER QUESTION.
MISTER CORK- HUMBOLDT LITTLE
BIT- CONCERNED THAT. WELL I
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERN THAT IF
YOU HAVEN'T OPTED IN SOME PEOPLE
JUST. YOU KNOW MAY HAVE LOST
THAT PIECE PER. TO- THAT PC PER
. PAPERWORK BUT I THINK THERE IS
A CONCERN THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
BE. REMINDING PEOPLE OF
SOMETHING THEY DON'T WANT TO BE
REMINDED ABOUT I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY BUT I
REALLY NEED TO THINK ABOUT THAT.
AND I HAVE CONCERNS AND I THINK
THAT'S SOMETHING YOU NEED TO
THINK ABOUT ALSO IT'S GOING TO
GO TO APPROPRIATIONS WHICH- NOW
ALL OF US HAVE BILLS TO DIE
THERE EVERY YEAR. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR YOU TO GET SOME
SORT OF- ESTIMATE FROM THE D.
A.'S THAT DOESN'T COME OUT TO BE
SEVERAL MILLION DOLLARS TO
AFFORD IT. BECAUSE- IT'S
SPECIFICALLY SAYS THAT IT MAY BE
SOMETHING THE STATE HAS TO
REMEMBER SO I THINK YOU NEED TO.
TALK TO THE D. A.'S AND GET THEM
TO COME UP WITH I HOPE A LOW
ESTIMATE FOR THE SAKE OF YOUR
BILL. BUT THEN I'M I'M ALSO
CONCERNED AGAIN ABOUT PEOPLE
BEING REMINDED ABOUT SOMETHING
THAT I WANT TO REMIND IT ABOUT
AND I'D LIKE YOU TO THINKABOUT
THAT- SO RESERVE MY VOTE FOR THE
FLOOR BUT I'LL HELP YOU GET IT
OUT TODAY. THANK YOU. YES ZERO.
THERE'S NOTHING IN THIS BILL
THAT- IS STEP HAS SUBPOENA POWER
OVER SOMEBODY WHO GETS NOTIFIED
THAT THEY HAVE TO GO TO THE
PAROLE HEARING SO THEY GET AND
PIECE OF PAPER THEY DON'T WANT
TO DO IT THEY WRINKLE IT UP TO
THROW. THE TRASH. AND THEY'VE
DEALT WITH IT. OKAY BECAUSE
THAT'S I. I'M I UNDERSTAND.
RIGHT BUT I'M JUST SAYING I GET
IT DID YOU KNOW SOME OF THE
ARGUMENTS SOUND LIKE YOU KNOW
PEOPLE ARE COMPELLED TO GO TO
THIS AND IT'S GOING TO DREDGE UP
MEMORIES- PEOPLE THAT HAVE
LEARNED TO COMPARTMENTALIZE AND
DEAL WITH THESE THINGS- WILL
WILL IF THAT'S WHAT THEY HAVE
DONE AND THEY DON'T CARE TO BE
NOTIFIED ARE THEY DON'T CARE TO
PARTICIPATE- THEY WILLSIMPLY
JUST THROW IT AWAY AND NOT
PARTICIPATE AND THAT TAKES CARE
OF THAT PROBLEM SO I'LL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL THANK YOU.
THE OTHER. JUST REAL QUICK GREAT
YET IT SEEMS LIKE. TO ME THIS
BILL IS BASICALLY SUPPORTED BY
JUST DECENCY OF BEING ABLE TO-
NOTIFY SOMEONE OF THIS LEVEL OF-
AND OFFENDER I I'D- I TOOK
UMBRAGE WITH THE FACT TO SAY
THAT- VICTIMS WOULD ACTUALLY
CAPITALIZE OFF OF THEIR SOUL OF
MOTION. I MEAN THAT IS INSULTING
TO ME. TO KNOW THAT- A LOT OF
THESE OFFENSES ARE VERY HEINOUS
AND- THE WAY THEY IMPACT VICTIMS
- SHOULD NOT BE HELD AND
JUDGMENT. I MEAN IT'S VERY VERY
UNFORTUNATE FOR ALL INVOLVED
THAT TO SOME PEOPLE TAKE THESE
COURSES OF ACTION BUT IN THE
INTEREST OF JUSTICE WE NEED TO
RECOGNIZE BOTH THE OFFENDER. AND
THE VICTIM AND THIS IS ALL THIS
IS ASKING OF THE VICTIMS BE
NOTIFIED. THAT THERE'S GOING TO
BE DISCUSSION AYE I FIND IT HARD
TO BELIEVE THERE'S OPPOSITION
BUT I'M I'LL BE SUPPORTING. DO
WITH THAT YOU MAY CLOSE EARLY
AND I JUST WANNA. TOUCH BASE IN
REGARDS TO YEARS ONE OF THE
THINGS WITH THE DA THEY HAVE
ACCESS TO DMV RECORDS A LITTLE
BIT MORE RECORDS THAT THEY CAN
FIND IF THEY NEED TO FIND THE
PERSON ESPECIALLY IF IT'S SPEND
FIVE TEN YEARS SINCE THIS CASE
HAPPENED. IN REGARDS TO YOU ON
YOUR OBJECTION REGARDS TO- THE
OPTING IN OPTING OUT RIGH NOW
YOU CAN DO THIS BUT BUT I'D LIKE
TO DO IS SIT DOWN WITH YOU AND
LET'S CLARIFY THIS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT THERE. AND WE COULD DO
THAT APPROPRIATIONS BECAUSE THAT
SEEMS TO BE THE BIGGEST THING IS
HAVING THEM HAVE TO DEAL WITH
TRAUMA AGAIN SO IF IT'S NOT
BEING CLARIFIED THERE THEN WE
CAN GO AHEAD IN MAY BE
RESTRUCTURED SO IT'S VERY CLEAR
THAT THEY HAVE A CHANCE RIGHT
THERE. TO OPT IN OR OPT OUT TO
HERE AND I THINK THAT WOULD SELL
PROBABLY WHAT YOUR CONCERNS ARE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NIGHT
THANK YOU- FOR. A JOB BROUGH. WE
WERE GONNA MMHM HOPEFULLY MOVED
ASIDE BUT I WILL PUT. I URGE YOU
TO LISTEN TO WHAT WITH SOME OF
THE MEMBERS HAVE SAID REALLY
WELL ACTUALLY MR CORK IN
RESPONSE TO A WIDER IT COULD BE
FIXED DREAMY DIFFICULT NOT ONLY
TO GET OUT OF. ROPES BUT- JUST
GETTING OFF THE FLOOR- AND I
LIKE MR CORKER WROTE. BROUGH FOR
TO HELP YOU GET OUT OF IT BUT
UNDERSTAND. IF CERTAIN THINGS
AREN'T RESULT WOULD BE VERY.
DIFFICULT FOR US TO A TO VOTE
FOR IT AGAIN I'D BE HAPPY TO SIT
DOWN WITH BOTH OF THEM. THANK
YOU. I'M AB TWENTY FOUR NINE BY
SEVEN MEMBER DAVIES THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER HI GENSER
IRAQI. LACKEY HI BONTA NO BONTA
KNOW BRIAN NOT VOTING BRIAN NOT
VOTING QUIRK I WORKED AYE
SANTIAGO. SAN DIEGO I. SEYARTO
THEY ARE TAUGHT BY. THE MEASURE
PASSED THANK YOU. SO WE'VE NEXT
WILL DO ANY ADD ONS LIFTING OF
CALLS AND VOTE CHANGES MATTER
SECRETARY GO THROUGH ALL THE
MEASURES TAKEN UP TODAY ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR QUIRK I WORK
AYE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I WENT TO.
ITEM NUMBER ONE HAS BEEN
DISPENSED WITH. I DON'T NUMBER
TWO AB EIGHTEEN FORTY SIX THIS
MEASURE WAS ON CALL SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I THAT MEASURE PASSES.
BUT ITEM NUMBER THREE AB
EIGHTEEN FORTY SEVEN THIS
MEASURE WAS ON CALL SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I THAT MEASURE PASSES.
I AM NUMBER FOUR AB NINETEEN
TWENTY FOUR LACKEY NOPE BLACKIE
KNOWS THEY ARE TO SAY OUR TURN
NOW. WE'RE ITEM NUMBER FIVE
WITHOUT. ITEM NUMBER SIX HAS
BEEN DISPENSED WITH ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN HAS BEEN DISPENSED WITH
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT WAS PULLED BY
THE AUTHOR. ITEM NUMBER NINE
WITH ON CONSENT. ITEM NUMBER TEN
AB TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN BY MEMBER
TROY SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO KNOWN
RECONSIDERATION. A
RECONCILIATION I. I DON'T NUMBER
ELEVEN AB TWENTY THIRTY THREE
HAS BEEN DISPENSED WITH. I DON'T
NUMBER TWELVE AB TWENTY THREE
THIRTY THREE BY SEVEN MEMBER
SMITH SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO NO. I
AUTHOR ITEM FOURTEEN WAS PULLED
BY THE AUTHOR ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
FIVE HAS BEEN DISPENSED WITH
ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN WHAT'S ON
CONSENT ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN
WAS PULLED BY THE AUTHOR ITEM
NUMBER EIGHTEEN HAS BEEN
DISPENSED WITH. I MADE AN ERROR
. RICHARD I DON'T REMEMBER THE
TITLE BUT- WE- HI YOU GO BACK
AND DOUBLE. KALRA THAT WOULD BE
A NONVOTING NO. ON ABC OH THREE.
NOT VOTING TO KNOW. RIGHT YES.
THANK YES THE RETURN OF. THE
PROBLEM WITH THAT YEAH. AND THAT
DISCONTENT THE BUSINESS FOR THE
PUBLIC SAY CAN.